e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs as uh
indicated in the calendar we have
several public hearings on various bills
today but before we get to those I'd ask
you to please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you
everyone first bill to we considered
this morning is House Bill 704 FNA the
prime sponsor representative Mary Jane
walner and um representative wner if
you'd like to come forward or would love
to hear your
testimony thank you chairman McDonald
and members of the committee I'm Mary
Jane walner I'm a state representative
from conquer and I'm very happy to be
able to bring forth uh House Bill 704
um this is a bill that is really a
funding bill it's requesting funding for
four well-established programs that
support older adults and caregivers and
is an immediate way to assist families
and help fill the gaps in New
Hampshire's long-term services and
support system family caregivers are the
major providers of long-term services
and supports and are essential in
sustaining a viable long-term services
and support delivery system in New
Hampshire The CARE
program provides families with much
needed assistance from the physical and
emotional stress of 24hour a day
care this program is administered
through local aging and disability
Resource Centers the Statewide respit
program provides comprehensive training
programs and the funds are used to pay
for needed respit services for
caregivers
the bill also provides funds for three
senior volunteer programs the senior
companion program and RSVP both provide
transportation and visits to isolated
older adults and the Foster grandparent
program volunteers provide one-on-one
support for children who benefit from
the stability of the support of a
grandparent there are many people here
today to testify on this bill both
people who are caregivers and people who
um know these programs very well and
they can go into much more detail than I
can on each of the programs um I hope
you
will vote in favor of the bill and move
it on to the finance committee it is
actually really an Appropriations Bill
and um needs to be in front of the
finance committee as we consider the
budget in the next uh few weeks so I'm
glad to try to answer any questions you
have you have the experts behind me
thank you any
questions representative Nel thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
just simple question is this new funding
or is this just restoring old funding
this is this is making sure that the
funding that has been in place for these
programs stays in place thank
you anyone else
no saying no one other questions so
thank
you I'm moving forward we have quite a
few people signed up to speak so I would
ask you to try to keep your your um
testimony at three minutes uh and then
we'll know that that does not include
questioning time so that allows the not
only the people other people who want to
testify the chance to testify but it
also allows the committee to have um
time for questions so so again please
take that in
consideration also signed up to speak
are Brian Clark and Wendy Alman from the
Department of Health and Human
Services thank you um Brian Clark um
Council for the Bureau of adult and
Aging
Services good morning um my name is
Wendy Alman and I am the bureau chief
for the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services at
thhs we are here and available to answer
any questions of the committee um we'd
also like to say that the intent of this
bill is in alignment and in support of
um the supports and services that we
offer through the Bureau of adult and
Aging Services it's in alignment with
our DHHS roadmap for our system of care
for healthy aging and the work we do for
our New Hampshire family caregiver
program um and the adrd the Alzheimer's
disease and related dementia work that
we do within the bureau to offer respit
and support family caregivers around the
state um in conjunction with our older
Americans act uh family caregiver resp
bit program um and I'm happy to answer
any questions as it relates to how we
operate our programs and support
volunteerism and how it aligns with our
state plan on aging and the work we do
with the
bureau thank you representative
palazov thank you uh Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so am I
right in assuming that uh adrd is
increasing in New Hampshire and could
you put some numbers uh uh on
increase and uh second question uh is it
relate to to this
programs like what percentage of uh
adrd uh patients are treated by these
programs and uh is is there any
alternative
uh where where where patients who are
not treed in this programs uh where they
could go thank
you um I believe the first question was
related to the adrcs and the operation
of the program can you repeat that um
about Alzheimer disease and related
disorder adrd with aging population and
generally like uh is it true that cases
are increasing in New Hampshire and can
you give any numbers like are we looking
into increased numbers in the coming
years yes and I believe that there will
be testimony coming forward from people
who are um experiencing and um are able
to access the Grant and how it helps
them but overall we serve a little over
um 250 individuals with our current
aging um Alzheimer's diseases and
related demena
respit Grant um in addition to that we
serve um a few hundred more um through
our family caregiver program um
currently we are uh
uh having a brain health campaign um
that's both going to Medical providers
and the general public um really to um
get education and Outreach and an
understanding of Alzheimer's disease and
related dementia and early screening um
so we expect um as a result of that
campaign and based on the trends that we
have for the people that were serving
that we will um need to have more
capacity um to serve individuals and
assist
caregivers other questions
representative
Missour thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here today so this $900,000 that I
see in the fiscal note is that are
those caregiver or DHS DHHS salaries or
are they just funds of overseeing the
program and the way we operate our
family caregiver program um within the
bureau is that the uh majority um the
vast majority of the Alzheimer's disease
and related dementia uh funding that is
appropriated in the budget that you see
here um it goes directly to respit
Grants so uh the way we operate the
program is that we leverage our older
American Zach Services um and the
matching General funds that are required
for our older American Zach caregiver
program to operate the contractors that
provide caregiver support and counseling
and our Financial Management Services
contractor that and administers the
grants directly to the to the caregivers
followup yes just quick followup so this
doesn't include like let's say for
example a caregiver's salary that's not
included in
this the the respit grant would pay for
um an individual to provide Direct Care
so when we work with a family caregiver
who needs respit they will um often
times need help finding a direct
caregiver or they may have somebody in
mind and we use our contractor to be the
employer of record and pay for the
direct care for the rest
bit thank you other questions
representative Woods um thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
um what is the cycle uh this is U sort
of peeling in on funds you've had before
is that something that comes up
periodically is it going be every
bium yes we do have an accounting unit
and appropriation currently for both um
the Alzheimer's disease and related
dementia General funds as well as
support for volunteerism and that would
come up every budget year okay follow
follow up um now is this budget you've
sort of alluded to other programs is
that sufficient to expand it both in
terms of what's been referenced an aging
population well the need is bigger and
we know that people that stay at home
generally do better and less cost uh so
expanding it both in terms of just the
numbers but also the types of programs
is this budget sufficient to accomplish
both of those um it certainly uh the
appropriation that's um proposed in this
bill certainly builds the capacity to
serve additional individuals um with the
resic grant we could probably serve um a
few hundred more um respit grants
depending on the uh the volume and the
Outreach and the results of our uh brain
health campaign and the Outreach and
education that um we do um through the
bureau thank you representative
Weber and just so I'm sure that we're
all on the same page am I correct in
thinking that the vast majority of care
is provided usually by family members at
no cost to the public and at enormous
cost to the family
caregivers and what we are trying to do
here is give somebody who spends
247 with a beloved family member who may
be very difficult to live
with a small amount of time where they
can breathe and be themselves and know
that their loved one is
safe yes I would agree with that we um
and we see that and there's many people
here that can speak to their experience
and um the difference that it's made um
in their lives as a family caregiver um
and and that's really the vision and the
goal for providing these supports is to
ensure people can um stay at home in the
community where they want to be and that
the people who are getting really that
uncompensated uh service um and care
that's being provided um some some
relief um and support um so that they
can continue doing
that other question representative
cofal thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so uh would it be
accurate to say that um this program is
potentially preventing some patients
from being shifted to a a much higher
cost um um you know in home nursing care
or you know full-time Care
Facility um yes I would think that
that's fair to say um in terms of the
the caregivers who we see um benefiting
um from the program and from the respit
um and the counseling and education that
we're able to provide through the
through the bureau that um definitely is
a outcome that we're
seeing representative Markel thank you
for taking my question um ma'am can you
tell us um about how many people do you
expect to serve with this program in the
state of New
Hampshire um well with the Alzheimer's
disease and related dementia Grant we
currently um sort of a little over 250
individuals um our respit grants
currently are about $2,000 which um
depending on what the needs are of that
individual it can give them a a good
amount of RIT um and support but we can
approve uh more if needed so it is
individual um and we would be monitoring
um how much we would be um able to
authorize for each family caregiver to
receive that support so we anticipate um
you know a range of between um 100 to
another 200 individuals could um receive
that respit Grant depending on
follows are follow follow up thank you
and so how did you arrive at okay I
heard you what you just said in terms of
your funding um how did you arrive at
that number that you that you have in
the bill here um we we use that um to
align with the parody or the um the the
grant that we offer through our older
Americans act um uh family caregiver
program so we we benchmarker that's the
Baseline for what we would offer for a
grant but if the needs um are are more
we are able to take that into
consideration and approve more thank you
no further questions other
question say no other questions okay
thank
you also signed up to speak is Doug
mcnet from the commiss on
Aging good to see you again Mr
mcnut so well whoops I'll be quick for
the record my name is Doug mcnut I'm
here today representing the commission
on Hampshire State Commission on Aging
which is fully supportive of this bill
in a prior life I served in Wendy's
position within the department so I'm
very familiar with the programs and
really what I want to emphasize this
morning is these are programs that take
advantage of small amounts of money and
in particular with the non Alzheimer's
funding these are volunteers who are
providing these services so if you think
about an aging population and how are we
going to take care of them uh for
example my wife does transportation
services here in conquered for the
friends program she's a volunteer she
does shopping for people these are vital
services that keep people at home and uh
again at very low cost because we're
talking about volunteers and so given
the fact that we have the kind of work
force shortages that we do these
programs are vital and not only that
these programs take advantage of federal
funding most of these agencies do their
own internal fundraising so there's a
real bang for your buck in the small
amounts of money that are involved you
know in this legislation
in terms of the uh Alzheimer's and uh
disease Related Disorders grants that is
a program that is very effective in
terms of not only keeping people at home
potentially off Medicaid as well so you
know there's a real value in doing this
and uh taking advantage frankly of a
volunteer force that is growing uh in
terms of uh Alzheimer's and Dementia
Related Disorders we know that
as people get older they're more likely
to to uh end up with dementia so these
are really important programs I would
argue they're real bang for your buck
and uh that's all I have to say I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
uh representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I've heard this from now three
people and I'm really curious do you
have any idea having been in that
position previously what percentage of
the people that administer services are
actually volunteers
well when you're talking about the
senior companion Foster grandparent and
uh RSVP programs those are
volunteers when you're talking about the
Alzheimer's program you're talking about
grants to caregivers to provide respit
so that's paid but um they're run
through the service link program which
is run by the state and so there's other
volunteer efforts that are associated
with that as
well follow up follow up I'm curious
where do the grants come from so the um
senior volunteer programs are run by the
um
uh well the admin what used to be called
the administration on Aging I don't know
what it's called now Administration for
Community Living I think and those are
grants that are funded to the states and
uh the senior volunteer programs are
actually senior volunteer programs are a
separate Federal program there is a
federal agency that runs all these
senior volunteer programs and the Name
Escapes me at present but that's where
the funding comes
from other
questions seeing none thank you
thank also signed up to speak is Lily
Wellington from the friends
program um ma'am you've asked for 10
minutes minutes I can't give you that
much time that's totally fine I
completely understand three minutes
please yep it was actually wonderful to
follow uh Mr mcnut um my name is Lily
Wellington I'm the director of volunteer
services at the friends program um it's
my pleasure to speak to you today about
two senior volunteer programs that we
operate one is the retired and Senior
volunteer program that is um what Mr
mcnut was talking about with the
americore senior Grant um and the other
is the fost grandparent program so I
want to start with RSVP which is what
it's often reduced
to this is essentially a program there
are six operating currently in the state
of New Hampshire and our job is to
assess where the gaps in each Community
are how do we fill those gaps with
volunteers specifically senior
volunteers so we are recruiting training
and supporting anyone over the age of 55
who wants to help us meet these critical
Community needs so for the program that
we operate we cover Rockingham marac
bellnap and straford counties one of our
main components is around caregiving
Medical Transportation has skyrocketed
the need for seniors vulnerable citizens
to get to and from medical appointments
I can't stress enough how significant it
is um we received a phone call several
months back from a woman who said I can
see conquered Hospital from my house I
can't get there three times a week for
dialysis she had no other option other
than to go into long-term care we thre a
Hail Mary we asked our volunteers if
they'd be able to transport her three
times a week for 6 a.m. dialysis and in
one day we had six months of medical
rides secured for her to and from
dialysis that saved someone's life in
addition these volunteers are filling
their days with something deeply
meaningful and they are the best
advocates for this programming we hear
time and time again that they get more
out of it than they could ever possibly
give I could speak for a very long time
about the stories of impact I won't but
long story short this is keeping elderly
vulnerable citizens at home we had
someone who was discharged this week
following an extensive abdominal surgery
she's 90 years old she would not be able
to return home if it were not for her
volunteer sh shoer who not only arranged
to pick her up he's going to pick up her
prescriptions he's going to grocery shop
for her he's going to make sure that
she's settled in at home she's 90 and
she gets to go
home I also am here today to speak about
the Foster grandparent program so this
is the other program that we operate
again it's using exclusively senior
volunteers this is a often misunderstood
program it's really classroom
grandparents so so our foster
grandparents classroom grandparents are
in schools across New Hampshire they are
in nonprofit preschools and daycares and
after school
programs thank you you could start
wrapping up though yeah this is a
program about deep meaning um they are
serving anywhere from five all the way
up to 40 hours a week they receive a
tax-free Federal stien for their service
as well as mileage and meal
reimbursement keeps them active keeps
schools supported they become an
embedded part of the community thank you
okay thank you any
questions wow unusual okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Olivia
paric I believe it is from the
Alzheimer's
Association I how many are there three
oh sure did you all do separate cards
yeah so also John
zimba okay and Jenny Horan okay okay
there we
go yeah
not there there three of you again we're
asking each individual three minutes so
we'll give you extra time where there's
three of you
so thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jenny Horan and I am the senior public
policy manager for the Alzheimer's
Association here in New Hampshire in New
Hampshire there are
26,500 individuals um that are living
with Alzheimer's or dementia and roughly
48,000 caregivers providing support to
their loved ones caregiving as have been
has been mentioned repeatedly in this
hearing already is an incredibly
challenging job people who are caring
for their loved ones with Alzheimer's or
dementia are assisting their loved ones
with daily activities such as bathing
dressing eating and then instrumental
activities in the day-to-day such as
paying bills shopping and
transportation more than 80% of the help
provided to older adults in the United
States comes from family members friends
or unpaid caregivers and in 2024 alone
caregivers in New Hampshire provided 77
million hours of unpaid care for loved
ones experiencing Alzheimer's and
Dementia at an estimated economic value
of $1.5
billion in order to provide this care to
their loved ones caregivers of people
with Alzheimer's or dementia experience
higher rates of emotional Financial
physical and emotional difficulties than
caregivers of people who are caring for
loved ones without Alzheimer's and
Dementia further over 66% of caregivers
of people living with Alzheimer's or
dementia in New Hampshire have chronic
health conditions over 28% of those
caregivers experience depression and
almost 15% are in poor physical health
to help the reduce the burden on
caregivers New Hampshire has the adrd
breast bit grant program which one
receives can assist a caregiver in
acquiring alternative temporary care for
their loved one so that they may take a
break while knowing that their loved one
is safely cared for these services can
provide be provided in a variety of
settings including in a home at a
nursing facility or in assisted living
facilities and this provides temporary
relief that enables an opportunity for a
caregiver to deal with their own manage
and improve their own health New
Hampshire's adrd breast bit grant
program is one of the services that the
brain health public awareness campaign
as Wy alluded to is going to be
highlighting and given the fact that New
Hampshire continues to age and we exper
expect rates of Alzheimer's dementia to
continue to grow we do anticipate an
incre increased need for this program
with hp704 we will be increasing the
funding to the adrd reate grant program
and it will not only help reduce burnout
for caregivers that people who care for
loved ones with Alzheimer's or dementia
experience at very high rates but it
will also help delay individuals from
needing to go into more costly living
situations in a more restrictive
environment um it is vitally
inappropriate is vitally appropriate
excuse me that when appropriate if an
individual so chooses that they're able
to stay at their home as long as
possible and preventing caregiver
burnout for those caring for loved ones
with living loved ones living with
Alzheimer's or dementia is instrumental
ensuring that choice exists so we're
definitely in support of hp704 and happy
to answer any
questions thank you very much
representative Nagel thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question would you
believe that I'm fortunate enough to
work with highlevel athletes and one of
the most important parts of training is
called rest and we actually pay them to
do that and I would say that it's
wonderful work you're doing that allows
these people to have that same
opportunity to rest I I would absolutely
believe that representative thank you
for the question other
questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
so uh I'm trying to divide 20 600 uh
26,500 by 250 so it looks like this
programs serve approximately 1% 1% of uh
of population uh who might need it is it
accurate uh assessment thank you for the
question representative math is
definitely not my strong suit so I I
won't question your math certainly it is
a small population that is being served
by this program and that is definitely
part of the reason why we're increasing
looking for an increase and funding
specifically for that we're so grateful
to partner with the Department with the
funding that the legislature provided on
the public awareness campaign to shine a
light on this program so that more
individuals who may be able to access it
will be able to access It ultimately
benefiting them as caregivers their
families and the state as a whole in
terms of allowing individuals to stay in
their homes um longer if that's what
they so choose to do thank you other
questions representative
Maser yes thank you for taking my
question um so I am looking back at the
fiscal note and it says so fiscal year
2025 there's no allocations there so
what are you currently using for what's
currently being used for funding this so
for the adrd RIT Grant specifically I
believe and I'm sure the department
would be able to give more accurate
numbers but it's funded with General
funds at $32 or so thousand this would
be a year this would raise it up to
about $552 00,000 for the adrd Prospect
Grant specifically and I will Wendy is
nodding that I am correct in
that so it about it' be roughly an
increase in this specifically for the
adrd program of about
$250,000 representative
wver thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question do you happen to have
off the top of your head or could you um
provide us or perhaps somebody in the
department provide us uh the cost of
caring for somebody who receives
Medicaid and who is uh in a nursing home
and needs dementia care I do not have
that number off the top of my head
representative but I'd be happy to get
it from you or make sure it would be
helpful in terms of understanding the
costs that the state is being spared if
people can appropriately remain in their
home with the appropriate support
I will I will make sure we get you that
number representative thank I will point
out attorney Williams had given me
numbers indicating that people Aging in
place and again this could vary
depending on their condition but it's
24,000 if they stay in home versus
74,000 if they go to a nursing home so I
don't know if that's true in all
incidents but that's I guess that's an
average number so I I don't know if that
sounds I I certainly would say that I
think we're all definitely aware that
allowing a person to be able to stay in
their home if they so choose is at a
much lower cost than someone who needs
to be in more intensive environment and
especially if someone is able to stay in
a less intensive environment of care
that's appropriate for them and that's
what they want to do that is absolutely
beneficial to them in terms of of their
situation as well thank you other
questions seeing none okay thank you
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Olivia parik and I live in Bow New
Hampshire I'm here today to testify in
Court of House Bill
704 I'm here today as someone who has
lived the reality of caregiving at just
21 years old my grandfather battled
Alzheimer's disease for four years and
my family did everything possible to
care for him at home after his diagnosis
in 2021 we made the decision for my
grandparents to move in with us ensuring
that he had the support he needed
especially during the uncertainty of
covid-19 at first we managed my
grandmother served as his primary career
giver and we all stepped in where we
could but soon it became
impossible he could no longer be left
alone he wandered outside and forgot
which house was ours he became confused
anxious and
paranoid late afternoons and evenings
with the sun Downing were the worst he
would become angry and argumentative my
grandmother exhausted could no longer
sleep in the same room because he didn't
recognize her and he would become
aggressive nights were unpredictable he
would stay awake wandering the house we
installed cameras door sensors and took
shifts just to ensure his safety caring
for him wasn't just a responsibility it
consumed Our Lives even when we hired
help we were never truly off the clock
but it provided my family with the S the
small necessary breaks to keep up with
work and school having even a few hours
of rest bit allowed us to recharge and
continue providing the best care we
could supporting like this is essential
for families navigating the Relentless
demand of
Alzheimer's it helps prevent burnout and
ensures loved ones can remain at home
longer with dignity and comfort
Alzheimer's care is not just emotionally
exhausting it's financially
crippling from October to December 2023
we spent
$22,000 on home care for just two months
and that wasn't even 247
coverage that cost exceeded the monthly
cost of a nursing home where meals and
around the-clock ha were included
when my grandfather eventually
transitioned into Memory Care the
financial strain only grew
$67,000 for five months at one nursing
home which is $113,000 per month
$448,000 for four months at another home
for $12,000 per month families like mine
will do whatever it takes to care for
our loved ones but it comes at an
unbearable cost the $2,000 program
provides it barely scratches the surface
but this is still a life
line and as the New Hampshire brain
health public awareness campaign
highlights this initiative more families
will discover this resource meaning
demand will rise without increased
funding many will be left without
options this issue is bigger than just
my family more than 11 a million
Americans provide unpaid care for a
loved one with Alzheimer's adding up to
18 billion hours of unpaid caregiving
each year the financial and emotional
burden leads to devastating burnout
nearly 60% of Alzheimer's caregivers
report high levels of stress anxiety and
depression I urge you to support House
Bill 704 and increase this funding
because caregivers need care too thank
you for your time thank you any
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr chair sorry for asking this but how
old did you say you are 21 wow yes thank
you very much thank
you anyone
else seeing no one else
morning good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
uh taking the time to listen to us this
morning my name is John zimba I live in
eeping I am a lifelong resident of
Rockingham County I grew up in New
Market went to school in New Market went
to UNH met my high school sweetheart in
New Market and we were married in New
Market we raised our family in Sandown
and the last 20 years have lived in
eping unfortunately I lost my wife for
50 years years to alzheimer's in
November 14th in
2022 I was a primary
caregiver a caregiver is someone who
helps another person on daily activities
or medical tasks a generic definition
very nice it's true a primary caregiver
for someone with Alzheimer's is much
more than that it's exhausting it's ugly
and is desperate those are the words
that I would have have to explain that
think of an airline attendant telling
you to put on your your mask before
helping those around you and imagine
there's only one mask and it's only good
for your loved one that's the example
that that I would
give once I was so
exhausted that I set the security alarm
of my home shut off my phone and went to
bed in hopes that my wife would get a
few hours sleep I would as well I was
awoken about 2:00 in the morning with
the police at the bottom of my stairs
with my wife during during the evening
she woke up went downstairs and
proceeded to leave the house the alarm
went off and it scared her so she sat on
the front front steps the alarm company
called me but my phone was off because I
wasn't thinking they called the police
and luckily the police came over and was
would rectified the
situation that was quite alarming quite
honestly because without the alarm
system or without the care or without
the the quick response to uh the police
department my wife would have wandered
off at 2 or 3:00 in the
morning during this time I learned to
take a shower in under two minutes to
brush my teeth while talking to go to
the bathroom with the door wide open to
take naps rather than restful sleep and
to pretend to pretend things were better
than they actually were respirate Care
is a temporary short-term service that
provides relief to primary caregivers
who are responsible for the ongoing care
of a loved one with chronic illness
disability or other meth other health
conditions it allows the caregivers to
take a break recharge and attend to
their own
needs I was fortunate enough to have a
couple of friends that helped me in that
area one very special friend took my
wife once a week every week it allowed
me to go grocery shopping to run
necessary errands uh to go to medical
appointments Dental appointments I
cannot begin to tell you how important
that day was to me
not to be confused with a vacation
respirate care is desperately needed and
much appreciated please support this
Bill thank you thank you any questions
representative Nagel sorry I have so
many questions thank you Mr chair um you
you've highlighted the three of you and
those before you've highlighted a number
of the problems that people incur by
taking care of their family members but
I'm just curious and this is very uh
important to me because yesterday I
actually took care of somebody that was
injured um on a memory unit taking care
of a combative um patient but I'm just
curious do you have any data on how many
family members are actually injured by
their loved ones and what the
ramifications are taking care of a
combative person Alzheimer's um I don't
have that data right now but I'm
certainly happy to look into it and see
if we can track down that information
for you but I would you know number of
people who are living in their homes
those challenges it's it's it's hard as
you alluded to and as you know Olivia
and John shared people can be combative
it's such a horrible disease that that
really can result in that and and there
is you know challenges with injuries and
Care follow up follow up so if if
somebody gets injured doing this is
there like a um outside of respit is
there a fallback position or um to help
them because suddenly they don't have
anybody for the primary caregiver that
who was injured um not to my knowledge
now other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Karen
Hao I believe it
is I don't know if I pronounced your
last name
right is it
okay
that's is it ha a TA the last name H
sorry h a
t oh okay
hat and Joseph hatch my husband thank
you good morning everybody my name is
Karen hatch and this is my husband
Joseph hatch um we live in Salem New
Hampshire with our adult daughter
Michaela who also
experience oh sorry sorry about that
sorry uh good morning my name is Karen
hach and this is my husband Joseph hatch
we live in Salem New Hampshire with my
adult daughter m who experiences
developmental disabilities and also
requires 247 care I'm a full-time
caregiver for both my husband and my
daughter um we appreciate the
opportunity to testify today in favor of
H Bill
704 my husband Joe um experienced
symptoms of uh Alzheimer's for several
years prior to being diagnosed with
early onset Alzheimer's
um in June of 2021 at the age of
56 he uh was diagnosed with early onset
Alzheimer's at the time we were under
the impression that it was going to be a
slow process and we'd have time to
prepare for the different aspects of the
disease but this was not the case for
Joe
um sorry he he experienced a um
a rapid motor
Decline and in August of
2021 his job identified him as safety
risk and he was no longer able to
work um all the physical fun things that
he was able to do like snowmobiling
driving making things out of metal
um Qui quickly disappear
appeared in a matter of 3
years and he is currently in the severe
stages of Alzheimer's and he needs uh
24/7 support in all aspects of
life um Joe cannot be left alone he he's
a wonderful um person he he he likes to
come up and make a difference um I have
trouble getting everything that is
needed to be down around my house
because he used to to do a lot of things
around my house with my daughter I take
care of and
um there's not much out there in the way
of supporting someone so young with
Alzheimer's um to continue trying to
live a quality life while keeping my
house running so uh I was at a loss what
to do in the beginning and was so
thankful when uh Tina goulette from the
Department of Health and Human Services
contacted my family and told me about
the resit program
through service link and
gateways and um I can't express the
relief that it has been to get we
generally do four hours a week um my
brother who is retired um supports Joe
and he looks forward to it every
Wednesday as a matter of fact he comes
at 12: and takes him to the dump to the
grocery store and they go out to lunch
and he looks forward to it as much as
you know it it benefits me um the respit
um I'm able to do my h a little bit of
housework and go to the gym um to try to
maintain my own health um this grant has
served a two-fold purpose it's helped my
husband maintain his strength by going
into the community and building
Community around him um and also um
helps him to feel productive um in the
community um and it helps me to maintain
my ability to take care of both him and
my daughter currently L I received
$2,000 in respit which lasts about five
to six months my brother um so what
happens is when you apply for respit you
go through a company which is gateways
and service link and they will take a
portion of it so it's about you get
about 17
$1,750 and my brother I is paid $20 an
hour that helps to pay for like going
out to lunch taking him like the gas the
mileage um
in the community it lasts about five to
six months and most recently because of
my husband's decline um I have to get um
home modifications in my home and um so
it puts me in a difficult situation to
like I have to start funding my brothers
uh to to maintain the um to to maintain
uh his ability to come to my house along
with getting a ramp getting um different
things to help um him be able to
modulate in in my home you good start
please W start wrapping up please sorry
if you could start wrapping up your tesy
so um I would hope that um we would uh
be able to access this grant year round
and um hoping that you would support
this bill most recently my husband
participated in the ad campaign for
early
diagnosis uh which which we we'll share
with this legislative body which
illustrates how important it is to build
community and to um have a caregiver
kind of free
Workforce um and uh hoping that you
would support this bill House Bill 704
thank you thank you are there any
questions representative Nel thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking that question
thanks for being here today um that's
very nice of you I I had a question that
something that you said really intrigued
me you said that they reached out to you
how did they find out about you my uh we
had I think we had um I have my husband
out in the community a lot and I do um a
lot of things Joe used to testify for
different things relative to my daughter
who was disabled and I don't know how
she learned about what was going on with
my family my husband had attempted to
commit suici side um when this first
happened because of you know the way it
was presented to him and just basically
a hopeless kind of uh disease and
so I do not know how she learned about
that and so but it was a little bit of a
security risk when he came back to the
house because it happened when I was on
my walk in the morning and so they
helped me to put a security camera into
my house and and um I think that's how I
learned of the respit program I don't
remember how she knew about it you know
and so I was very grateful at the time
um that this was offered to help
maintain my ability to keep my husband
and my daughter both at home you know
so appreciate that representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh would you believe
believe uh how much as a committee we
appreciate your coming today this is not
easy for you and I understand that and
it helps us
tremendously uh at least I do uh to
support this legislation thank you very
much for
coming representative palaza thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh can you talk to your
experience of filing for this uh uh
resit program uh um like did you have
to um was there some requirements like
did you have to disclose your personal
financial situation or did you have to
take any training to qualify this
program or was there any requirement
making sure that you are vaccinated to
be in this
program no there was no no training um
it's I think it's to help um maintain
your ability to there is no training for
this type of a disease spr basically
going to you're going to learn it as you
go and um the Alzheimer's Association
helps a lot they have a lot of um videos
on the on TV they have they don't have a
lot of support groups for people with
early onset Alzheimer's um it's
different it's a different um it's a
different diagnosis because so young and
it sometimes it happens quicker um and
um I don't think there was um trying to
remember
um I had to apply for it I believe had
to app I had to do like an application
for it and
um but I don't think there's a train was
there another question I'm sorry if I'm
not covering all your
questions oh J was it an easy process
and do do you have like to file any
reports like at the end of period uh um
like uh is it e a program to
apply you mean like any reports on what
I do with him you mean no I mean they
know I like I pretty much um tell them I
I do it with my daughter too I developed
a a program so my husband can go out
into the community and to um be
supported to be able to the community
gets to know him and they get to know
um like you in the community they get to
know me and they just will offer help
sometimes you know so it's a great way
to
um to get the community to know a lot of
times people get isolated in their homes
um which is what's happens a lot of
people are afraid of the disease even
happens with my brother it's a very it's
very difficult because as a disease
Progressive you have to do all
activities of daily living and um so
when a person that doesn't have a lot of
experience because this is not you get
you're making they're not making money
they're just it's their time so a lot of
time so people that are they're not
going to have experience in it but it's
like instead of you know like just
keeping somebody at home or having them
see somebody socially it's really an
important program to keep funded and
actually it would be great to able to do
it throughout the whole year um the
funding Runs Out unfortunately like in 5
to 6 months because um some the company
has to get paid a little bit to run the
the grant you know so um it makes it
difficult like last week the VNA people
came because my husband's motor issues
increased and I have to bring all kinds
of things into my house like a ramp like
a oer lift like a you know and so we're
not like we're just above I worked when
I my husband had worked so we're not um
you know going to qualify for like real
poor we're just right above that like
line and um but I have to I have to
budget because I also have a daughter
that has uh 247 developmental
disabilities as well so I have to kind
of take care of both of them in my home
and um which is okay but appreciate the
support that this office because it
helps me every tiny little bit helps to
be able to sustain that it's a long like
when they say it's a long journey it's a
long journey and it's years of of of
having to uh think outside the box but
in terms of actual reporting there's not
a lot of actual reporting you have to do
though so sorry you you don't have to do
a lot of actual reporting to no
appreciated that was representative
bazo's Main questions oh okay sorry so I
can show you I mean you guys need that
type of thing I can any other question
come to my house and I can show you any
any other
questions I'm uh seeing no other
questions but thank you very much thank
you best of luck thank
you e
they also signed up to speak is Judith
Jones from new futures
good morning I'll keep my comments brief
because the folks who have speak have
spoken today from their hearts have the
best information for you but I I wanted
to express my gratitude to this
committee as you wrestle with these
issues and have the expertise in policy
and have had so many people come before
you with complex problems and happy to
say that this bill in New Hampshire
would provide direct benefit to
individuals who are providing so much to
New Hampshire this bill is unique in
that you're supporting individuals
who've already given their time
commitment and energy to the state of
New Hampshire you've heard some
testimony about the need in New
Hampshire and I think of the word
stunning the need for these programs is
stunning if you were to ask me to choose
just a few phrases what capture the
essence of these programs the words that
come to mind are wellestablished proven
track records existing
infrastructure targeted to the needs of
the local community cost effective and
the other word I have is common sense
these are common sense programs that are
coste effective in my written testimony
what you'll find are some citations to
studies that document the benefit of
both of these programs and also of
course were're concerned about the cost
of programs and what you'll find in the
written testimony is documentation
regarding cost
Effectiveness what you'll hear today in
the testimony what you've heard and also
through online words is that the
caregivers they want to keep providing
the care they're here and they want to
keep providing the care what you'll hear
about the senior volunteers is they're
ready they're skilled and they're
they're ready to f fill that hole in the
community what we're asking for from
this committee is to support House Bill
704 thank you thank you any
questions seeing no questions thank
you also signed up to speak is Roger do
Roes from AARP
dear members of the House Health and
Human Services committee my name is
Roger D roier and I'm here today on
behalf of ARP New
Hampshire we want to express our strong
support for House Bill
704 this bill work represents a critical
investment in the well-being of older
adults and caregivers in New
Hampshire ARP supports House Bill 704
because it funds well-established
programs that provide immediate
assistance to families and helps fill
the gaps in New Hampshire's long-term
service and support
system these programs are essential for
enabling older adults to remain in their
communities which is not only beneficial
for the well-being but also a wise use
of
resources investing in programs that
support older adults and caregivers can
delay or avoid the need for more costly
long-term Support Services the targeted
programs under house bill 704 include
caregiver respit
programs these provide respit services
for Alzheimer disease and Related
Disorders offering much needed relief to
caregivers
also
americore senior volunteer programs
these include the senior companions
Foster grandparent program and retired
senior volunteer program which provide
invaluable support to older
adults funding these programs is a smart
investment for New Hampshire by enabling
older adults to remain at home and in
their communities we can reduce the
demand for more expensive nursing home
care for example getting a ride to a
medical appointment or having access to
resfit care can mean the difference
between remaining at home or needing
institutional Care One program reported
a 50% increase in requests for rides
last year highlighting the growing need
for these
Services as a caregiver for over 15
years I can personally attest to the
need for respit services it helps
sustain the caregiver and help helps
maintain an older adult in their home as
long as possible my dad died of
Alzheimer's at age
97 in in conclusion House Bill 704 is a
crucial step towards supporting our
older adults and caregivers ensuring
that they have the resources they need
to thrive in their
communities ARP New Hampshire urges you
to support this Bill and make this
important investment in the future of
New Hampshire thank you for your time
and
consideration thank you any
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Kathleen
Stewart
good morning everyone my name is
Kathleen Stewart I am the program
manager for the americore senior
companion program we are one of the
three americore seniors programs uh
described today Lily Wellington directs
the RSVP and the Foster Grand parent we
are the senior companion program um and
our volunteers are all older adults over
the age of 55 that receive an hourly
stien in mileage reimbursement to go
into the homes of homebound seniors uh
to provide companionship and also rides
to doctor's appointments and for
groceries and maybe just out for lunch
uh lastly and very important as we've
heard a lot this morning we provide
respit to caregivers um so our
volunteers are older adults that cannot
they're not trained to provide any
Hands-On care but they can provide
respit to caregivers who might just want
to take a nap or mow the lawn or maybe
go out and tend to their own medical
needs so there are so many things that
I'd like to talk about today that I we
don't have time for um first the health
benefits of volunteering later in life
uh there's been a lot of research about
how uh volunteering over in your 50s and
and above um provides all kinds of
health benefits it gives our a sense of
purpose it also is a big cost savings as
we've discussed earlier today and the
list goes on but there's also the
numbers involved um it for 50 years
approximately um our program has
partnered with cap um from in conquered
belut Marat cap U to provide
transportation respit and companionship
to New Hampshire residents for nearly 50
years last fiscal year we provided
32827 7 hours of companionship to
343 homebound residents of New
Hampshire these aren't just numbers
these are 343 people who would otherwise
most likely have little to no human
interaction or access to the
community 343 people who without the
support of our program may not have had
enough food to get through the week or
access to routine medical appointments
or prescribed medications these 32,8
27 hours are life sustaining yes but
they are so much more they are a few
hours every week where the primary focus
is the person making them smile making
them laugh reminding them that someone
in the world cares about them their
existence and their happiness
matters on the other side of things we
do the resit piece
4,968 hours of respit was provided to
caregivers in the state of New New
Hampshire at no
cost these hours provide rest um excuse
me these hours provide caregivers the
opportunity to tend to their own medical
needs to like I said MOG a la take a nap
these little time small breaks in time
are essential to these caregivers as
we've heard again this morning many
times and also our program contributes
to their well-being and their preventing
them to uh burnout care caregiver
burnout thank you
any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Kay
Taylor from the Foster grandparent
program good
morning good morning my name is k Taylor
I'm a foster
grandparent this is my eighth year in
the
program the program means a lot uh in
many different
ways um I tried retirement wasn't for me
I needed something to do and I needed a
purpose I work uh I'm currently at
Beaver Meadow School um I'm split
between a kindergarten class with 16
kids and a second grade class with 14
kids um the teachers all love and
appreciate the help and it's very
rewarding to be with the kids to see the
little the smiles on their little faces
uh you walk in in the morning you know
they come running up Grammy Kay Grammy K
they want
hugs we do a lot of different things in
the
school um we help maybe you've got a
child that needs a little extra help in
learning to write their
letters or maybe they just want to play
a math game with you give them some
one-on-one time a lot of our students
nowadays don't have that at
home this this help helps them
emotionally
um and they appreciate your involvement
in their
lives um I foran like to bake I'll bake
many muffins and take in for the kids
they're very
appreciative uh I had one child tell me
they had never had a homemade
muffin for me it has out both emotional
and physical
healthwise I
don't I I get up in the morning I know
I've got somewhere to do to
go and help the the students and the
teachers um in October of 23 I received
an award from Spirit of New Hampshire
for my work with the Foster grandparent
program
and I plan to stay in the program as
long as I am physically and mentally
capable and I hope that you will
seriously consider
this and make this part of Bill
704 okay thank you any
questions okay thank you
ma'am also signed up to speak is Kevin
Moore good morning members of my name is
Kevin Moore I'm here to support
704 I have dealt with a family member
who has who had Alzheimer's I was trying
to get him help in clamont New
Hampshire and he
declined really bad ended up salivan
County nursing home which was really
wonderful to him he could not live on
his own he was wandering around in
Claremont he got to salivan County I
went to visit him he had no clue who I
was um he actually raised me um as a
child growing up and this bill is very
important I would encourage you all to
deeply ask yourself what does it mean to
you because I'm sure you all must have
someone struggling and I would ask that
you all would highly take this bill
seriously thank you thank
you uh no one else has signed up to
testify before I close the public
hearing does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on HB 704 FNA
and open the public hearing on 743 FN
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Julia sodi and pink card
is coming great thank you for
okay representative sodi yeah thank you
for your patience good morning committee
members uh for the record I'm
representative julus soti from uh wiam
also representing London Derry and and
um well this HB 743 this bill is looking
to uh get some upfront uh price pricing
and also some pricing transparency which
the uh Federal Law requires and I've had
a few constituents who've also been you
know complained to me about this matter
not the least of which is my wife as
well uh one of my constituents writes uh
that he got a $1,800 bill with no
details no clues what it's for leaves
leads to an very awkward situation when
you have to call them up and battle
after the fact of what's going on what
other industry gets away with this uh
can you imagine a Contractor Building
your house and then sending you the bill
when it's when it's all done later
totally
intolerable so the bill you have in
front of you is uh well inspired by the
bill that passed in Maine bipartisanly I
asked OS to rewrite it to make maybe
work for New Hampshire um I've already
got some criticism about it that it
doesn't go far enough so there's other
other states out there that have also uh
uh done this kind of stuff um Rhode
Island Florida
Colorado and I also like to point out
that uh on the federal level there's
some more stuff coming down the pike
which uh gives some price transparency
to um well every aspect of uh the
medical Comm Community all the way down
to your doctor's office and I think
that's being inspired by Bernie Sanders
of all people so I would suggest that
maybe we could get out front on this
issue uh with that um I think I'm
done any questions for representative
sodi representative Nagel thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question
thank you for bringing up this topic
it's a really important one um I I just
had two questions actually um what does
this bill accomplished that federal law
does not accomplish now well right now
uh it's woful inadequate what's going on
uh because you're not getting the prices
up
front uh in fact uh the testimony that's
going to follow for my wife will be some
extra examples of that so I don't want
to spoil that testimony yet can I ask a
followup followup I'm just curious why
were pharmacists excluded from this oh I
think uh there's some other bills that
some other representatives are going to
be working on uh that are going to be
putting that in
other questions representative
McLean uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so um you say
that this bill uh passed in Maine but
also that there are versions in Rhode
Island Colorado and Florida yeah um how
long has that uh how long has that been
the case I'm assuming Maine is just very
recent yes it is um what about these
other states can you give us Rhode
Island is pretty recent as well and and
I think they're all pretty recent
actually okay followup question Mr chair
followup thank you Mr chair um so have
you spoken to anybody um in theur in the
insurance department or because I
noticed that the the first part of it
kind of Builds on the federal no
surprises law for the uninsured um but
there are certain mandates that you're
putting in on the insurance companies
and I was just wondering if the
insurance department had any feedback oh
they're coming up they're here oh he
already I've already got some complaints
hold fire thank
you other
questions saying no other questions
thank you
okay also signed up to speak is Ben
Bradley from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Ben
Bradley I represent all 26 hospitals in
the state of New Hampshire as well as
all specialty hospitals um we appreciate
this opportunity to discuss HB 743 we
are opposed to the bill not because we
oppose patient access to healthcare
prices and billing practices but because
the bill is redundant and could create
conflicting standards between federal
and state law in a way that duplicates
Federal requirements for transparency
and increases regulatory burden and cost
on Healthcare Serv services and patients
Federal Hospital Tri price transparency
rules went into effect on January 1 2021
and require all hospitals to make
available on their websites a single
machine readable digital file containing
the standard charges for all items and
services provided by a hospital Federal
Regulations also give hospitals two
options to let consumers determine their
potential out-of-pocket costs for common
Services an interactive price estimator
tool or a static spreadsheet listing 300
common Services those regulations are
required by federal law and are enforced
by the centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services CMS I also want to point out
New Hampshire led the nation several
years ago when the department of
insurance first published the
comprehensive New Hampshire Health cost
website which allows consumers to
compare prices for various procedures
across several providers including
hospitals contrary to the comments from
Advocates supporting this legislation in
previous
years in New Hampshire there are several
ways for p Pati s to view costs for
services and receive a good faith
estimate of those Services prior to
receiving care as already required by
fed Federal Regulations while some
advocates for this bill claim the
legislation is necessary due to lack of
enforcement and negligible fines on
hospitals data from CMS available
publicly on their website shows exactly
the opposite anyone can go on the CMS
website and view the thousands of
compliance notifications and fines
imposed by CMS across the country since
the rule took
effect this bill resembles HB 389 from
last legislative session that was ited
by the house on the consent calendar in
previous
testimony Advocates said the purpose of
the bill is to hold hospitals
accountable for not complying with
federal law as noted CMS is the Arbiter
of compliance for these regulations and
we ask why duplicate efforts that would
require State Investments for the
Department of Health and Human Services
to do investigations into hospitals
compliance with Federal transparency
regulations when CMS is already doing
that advocates for this bill have also
highlighted that other states have
enacted similar legislation I've talked
to my colleagues in other states around
the country one in particular said their
Department of Health and Human Services
has not received a single complaint for
non-compliance with Federal transparency
regulations since their since their
state law passed this is a solution in
search of a problem that does not exist
of all I've included additional material
with my testimony that you may find
helpful when considering this bill
during the summer of 2022 our hospitals
began receiving emails from a national
special interest group called patient
rights advocates.org making misleading
claims about individual hospitals
compliance with the federal no surprises
act these claims are false I've attached
a chart that shows the inconsistency and
inaccurate criteria used by the special
interest group in their analysis of
Hospital compliance with the NSA and
they do not use the same requirements in
their
analysis for these reasons we cannot
support hb5 uh excuse me HB 743 and I'd
be happy to answer any questions thank
you Mr chairman thank you any
questions representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um just for
for and it's my understanding that no
surprises does a lot you know for the
uninsured and stuff like that but if you
are insured like an employer insured
like a lot of people people you you you
don't get the same kind of quoting and
things like that so with the tools that
we have set up in the state already
could you maybe walk me through a
scenario where a person who maybe is
going in for hip surgery for example but
they have employer-based
insurance how are they what what what
mode would they take to go through to
get the The Upfront pricing that they
needed so not unur they have employer
based Insurance maybe we just kind of
walk us through what that path might
look like thank you for the question
representative sorry for rifling through
my testimony I really just wanted to
make sure I got it on the record and I
appreciate the opportunity to discuss
this further New Hampshire has done a
great job of uh establishing a health
cost website through the Department of
Insurance it does afford uh uh an
ability for patients to compare prices
across multiple providers and they can
can select whether they are insured who
their um insurance provider is and whe
or whether they're uninsured and it will
provide estimates across several um
several uh
procedures uh several common procedures
uh that patients can uh filter through
select multiple providers uh that are
included in that uh database and then
get an estimate for what that uh cost
could be out of even out of pocket um I
believe the department of insurance is
here and they be may be able to speak
more into the capabilities of that uh
platform I think it is actually probably
even more useful than the
federal um uh resources that are a
static spreadsheet uh or um their their
price estimator tool so this is really
local this is focused on what's going on
here in New Hampshire uh and I would
just point patient to that as well as uh
our providers uh at hospitals who are uh
required to provide a good faith
estimate of the expected cost for those
Services if they are
uninsured follow
up thank you and thank you for taking my
question so um and and I'm aware of the
uh the the the cost estimator um on on
the government website um but one of the
things about no surprises it's my
understanding is that it has teeth
because if the quote is provided and the
final bill comes in and it has
absolutely no relation um to what the
quote was that
there's the patient is really going to
be insulated a little bit from that can
you speak a little bit to um with the
the State website um is there anything
binding uh if uh a provider really um
goes far off pace from from that um from
what is being put out on the website
thank you I I don't know the answer to
that specific question but I do want to
hit on the no surprises acts act
legislation at the federal level because
CMS does say that if the estimated
amount is a difference of
$400 you know one way or another then
you can um you can dispute that that
that price uh compared to the estimate
that you received you can dispute the
the cost if it is uh in excess of
$400 um and and that uh then has binding
expectations for the provider um Who
provided that um Who provided that good
faith
estimate other
questions seeing none thank you thanks
Senator also signed up to speak is
Adrienne sod
red all right hello everybody um as you
know I am uh Julia sodi the primary
sponsors uh wife living in wiam New
Hampshire um before I begin my testimony
I would like to
uh quickly address um actually some of
the points that uh the hospital
Association repres representative Ben
Bradley just brought forward um he
mentioned that uh consumers nowadays
have multiple Avenues of uh getting to
the the prices Healthcare prices and he
mentioned that website established by
the insurance commission just recently I
was on that website to look for how much
a particular procedure costs which is
also um a matter of legislative action
recently
circumcision was not listed in there I
don't know if he can find it I put in
the word and that's a pretty common
procedure and no price has come up on
that another thing that uh women
unfortunately often encounter is
hysterctomy I put in the word nothing
came up another procedure that I
actually recently had which I will
include in my testimony testimony was a
breast MRI women with dense breasts
often um get a breast MRI that would be
the most definitive um test to determine
if they have any cancer uh in addition
to a mamogram and an ultrasound nothing
came up on that website I don't know if
I'm doing anything wrong but uh I have
looked at other procedures that have
come up these have not so just to bring
that up and uh what Bill uh what this
bill would accomplish that the federal
doesn't um I assume also is um to
provide the information to patients that
they can request us that this actually
would be displayed in hospitals very
often um patients have no idea what the
federal law is I myself didn't find out
about this until recently when somebody
brought to my attention Dr Marty mcui
who's a um a hot thing nowadays who has
written a blind spots in medicine he
also has uh written uh unaccountable and
the price we pay books I've all listened
to which all address this issue and he
was behind the federal law um and which
fortunately has passed um um Mr Bradley
has referred to the patient advocacy
organization um as a special interest
group which I have also found and I find
that they are volunteers who are doing
an amazing job I have also printed that
list which he calls misleading I don't
know maybe that's something the
committee should look into who am I to
say if it is leting or not but it says
New Hampshire's largest hospitals are
listed over there as non-compliant on
pricing data sufficiency rating perhaps
for the same same reason where uh which
I just mentioned that the other website
U has that you can't find all the
procedures or what I found in one
um well the three minute went by
fast in in one situation they say um
that the details are not available so
it's sort of like a kevat there's the
list but they say sorry we don't have
the details of the price so something
for for the committee to look into am I
able to uh a few minutes that was your
testimony if you written a written copy
we're happy to put it on record and and
or if you want to submit copies online
or whatever thank you but are there any
questions for Mrs
S representative
mlan thank you Mr jar and thank you for
taking my question um your husband
mentioned uh
that you had gotten into a bill dispute
um with the insurance company and that
it was difficult because you didn't have
a breakdown of all the different items
and so it's very difficult to dispute
something because I just have an overall
um did you go back and require or or
request um a breakdown and it was not uh
offered or what was the situation with
that I I do think they have to provide a
breakdown list yes yes and I think he
was actually referring to another
constituent who had that issue recently
uh I personally had that issue and yes
once you request it they will send you
an itemized list in my particular CL uh
case what they are uh billing me and
actually what I'm in collection for um
is the doctor's uh reading fee so a
radiologist's fee for for that breast m
which I had done which Salem Radiology
the company I went to to find out how
much uh I would pay for this as a
self-pay because insurance said they
wouldn't cover it now they said they
have a policy that if you have insurance
even if Insurance decides not to cover
it you have to use your insurance so
they wouldn't give me a price at first
the technician told me oh if you are
self-paid did you know how expensive
this procedure is I said yeah probably
about $11,000 I'm prepared to pay that
he's like no this is 9,000 like are you
kidding me so I got dressed and left and
called my insurance company and said um
I have to go through you how much how
much am I going to be liable for and
they said we have no idea you have to
ask the provider said how come the
provider is not telling me you don't
know could you help me could you call
the provider to get this price so they
were on the phone with me and they
called a number of providers some of
which they couldn't reach just like I
couldn't they wouldn't pick up the phone
they left a message
and so what I ended up doing going into
Salem R Radiology sitting down and
finding a person who could actually give
me a quote they said it's going to be
$400 big difference between 9,000 and
400 I was like oh sure you know I'm
ready for that I'm going in for that
procedure um they said if you pay now we
even give you a 10% discount and I said
okay great so here's the money am I am I
do I owe you something for the
radiologist I'm sure there's going to be
a radiologist involved oh we have no
clue about that I thought there was a
law
and it is part of this bill that any any
radiologist or basically additional
third party provider will have to be um
to displayed or what is the word to so
that the patient knows who that person
is so that at least if they don't know
the price I could call them up and say
how much are you going to charge
interestingly that $200 is in collection
and I just found out most people have no
idea there is a law against that so I
have no idea how to fight it so now I'm
going to call the collection agency and
say New Hampshire has this law you can't
ask me for this money CU nobody told me
about it is that right so other
questions thank you representative
Weber have you ever contacted the
insurance department about resolving
this dispute no I have um no idea how to
access them I I don't know is there
phone number do I just type into Google
New Hampshire insurance department and
that would pop up and would you believe
that I my understanding is there's
somebody who's going to testify from
them but they have a very extensive
website yeah yeah so most people I
consider myself pretty educated in
health matters and being able to
advocate for myself and I had no idea so
I think the average person has no clue
that they have options that they are
supposed to uh be given prices that is
the federal law they don't know so are
there notices and and one thing I wanted
to to mention about ambulance fee that I
got charged it was over
$4,000 for for something that could have
been completely avoided because I had my
car and I was able to drive but at that
point I was already in Parkland
Medical's computer system and they
needed to Transit transport me to
Portsmouth Hospital and they said we
would prefer you take the ambulance
because now you're in our system we
don't have to re-register you nobody
told me how much it was going to be and
even though the insurance pay over 3,000
they wanted to collect the 1500 left
over which I fought and they waved it
but what a waste of resources even for
the insurance company I could have just
driven and saved that money and an
insurance cost would be much
less other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank
you and speaking of the New Hampshire
Insurance dep Department uh Jason
AIS uh from nhid which I believe stands
for New Hampshire insurance department
so good morning Mr chair committee um my
name is Jason AIS director of Health
economics at nhid or the New Hampshire
insurance department it's so nice to see
your beautiful faces and smiles today
thank you for the opportunity
um the insurance department has no
formal position on this bill excuse me
can can everybody hear I'm
okay could you move that so the
insurance department has is neutral on
this bill um as a note there is another
house bill House Bill 705 that is within
our oversight and Authority it's about
price transparency and um our data unit
at the insurance department our Central
focus is healthc care price transparency
and the uh the woman previously
testified
delineated a plethora of different
issues with that and we concur it is
indeed um a a Thicket of perplexing
price information oftentimes inaccurate
that the average consumer it's not
plausible that they can navigate through
that so we we acknowledge that is a
problem it's noteworthy that there are
indeed two federal laws one pertaining
to um hospitals and one pertaining to
health insurers that
NE necessarily organized like that to
kind of help patients and um analysts
and Regulators like us understand what
you might expect to pay when you have a
a real encounter versus just reference
pricing which has lower utility for for
the patient and and oversight individ
individuals um our New Hampshire Health
cost website which is referenced in this
bill I think there's some
misunderstandings about how prices get
reported on there it's a very different
criteria compared to what both Federal
rules require for hospitals and insurers
to post the CMS it used to be the CMS 50
it turned into the CMS 300 and now it's
actually the CMS 500 medical services
that meet the eligibility requirement to
be reportable on those transparency um
mechanisms whether they're the consumer
friendly um mechan isms on their website
or these machine readable files which
the federal rules also require for both
entities to
report um the machine readable files are
not consumable by our public they're
really for analysts researchers and
Regulators to essentially serve as a Rec
a validation data set or reconciliatory
data set to ensure that using other more
empirical observational data like the
claims data that there's Fidelity in
Billing with what the self-reported data
from these Federal requirements pose so
that's important to understand and it's
really a key limitation of these machine
readable files those are self-reported
by entities on what they say that they
charge the claims data is empirical it's
observational it's what the patient is
actually exposed to it's if you can
contextualize what I'm trying to say is
they're not always equal in fact the
insurance Department's primary interest
in getting the the transparency and
coverage data from insurers is to
validate that there's great Fidelity in
that and what the P the patient might
see what they can expect to pay and what
they actually pay but I did just want to
make note you could start wrapping up
though please on the section that points
out the New Hampshire Health cost
website that is probably not comparable
with regards to serving the consumer on
all of the different services that are
delineated in the hospital price
transparency legislation which I see
this seems to
parallel with that I'll end there if you
have any questions thank you
representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question at the beginning
of your testimony you referenced a
different bill on price transparency
could you give me that number again and
is that a bill before the legislature
right now now or is that one that we
passed previously current currently
being heard right now um House Bill 705
705 thank you that re regards insurance
carriers not Hospital providers I I
think to mirror the federal approach it
might be most suitable to keep those
mutually exclusive from each other thank
you other questions representative Woods
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh sometimes uh
getting data down to the public is
difficult uh you've alluded to that um
and just to point out and maybe you
could help uh identify how the disparity
because uh uh and you mentioned the word
uh charges versus
reimbursement uh and a a a particular
entity May charge X for a procedure but
after negotiation are completed except
far
lower uh as those two numbers sometimes
really don't Jive and how do how is that
sorted out for the person who's trying
to find out what I'm exposed
to that thank you for the question and
it's a good one complex one one thing we
aim to do on New Hampshire Health cost
is to do that we stratify by insurer
type of insurance including the
uninsured as Mr Bradley said as well as
by provider and tangentially the
transparency and coverage files from the
insurers also are required to have three
files in network negotiated rates out of
network maximum charge amounts in a
prescription drug file the significance
of that is that Network status is a key
driver to Pro to cost exposure to a
patient so if a if a provider is in
network they will have a contract in a
negotiated allowed amount that's the
maximum amount that a provider will be
required to pay for any given service
services are classified by codes billing
codes usually CPT codes or hipic codes
but so the the negotiated amounts are
the best approximation to the cost that
a patient will be exposed to and that's
that's one albe it not a perfect but one
of the most precise approaches to
informing patient populations about the
economics of healthcare
encounters other
questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um we we heard
a lot of discussion from the hospital
Association about the the State website
and the you know the amount of
transparency that it provides um but
you're understanding of the role of that
website if I understand you correctly is
not that it is going to be giving you
cost information in the same way that no
surprises would give cost information to
the uninsured who are requesting a quote
it has a completely different role am I
correct in that your assessment of what
that is you're really smart about
insurance everything I've heard you say
just shows how much Insight you have I
AG AG ree mostly with that I think one
key thing to point out our um
responsibility with New Hampshire Health
costs is in fact that to be responsible
in publishing claims-based price
estimates that are are very um stable
what we notice is wild price variability
with with providers for any given
service it's astonishing to see for any
given individual CPT code individual
health care service how wildly variable
the prices are that's the essence of the
issue the these other advents to
communicate price information they do
not use claims-based data to do that
they they use contractually based
self-reported information which
presumably within each entity will not
vary nearly as widely as the claims
based approach so there's advantages and
disadvantages to each and I think after
after having heard some of the testimony
from people from the public and and
members uh you know from the hospital
Association we probably can do a better
job communicating that to the reader you
know the nature of these data and how to
best interpret them to get a sense for
you know what their true exposure to
cost implications from an individual
healthc care encounter might be but we
published the median paid amount for
services that are ubiquitous in the
state of New Hampshire we often times
find ourselves censoring certain
Services because they start to not meet
the condition of what we call curtosis
or essentially wild price variability we
want a very
narrow range of variation in the price
and when we can't ensure that we can't
responsibly share that with the New
Hampshire or American public and that's
important to us that way follow
up so I I think then that might be why a
hysterctomy for example which was cited
earlier was not included on the list but
just as a different question um
obviously you have no position on this
bill but is there anything about this
bill um that would potentially
jeopardize the insurance Market um in
New Hampshire do you see any concerns
from the insurers about that that they
see red flags uh with respect to their
ability or to deliver service in the
state thank you for your question the
only thing I would point out is what I
previously mentioned that there the
section on here that uh relates to
insurance carrier price transparency and
given the fact that there already is a
current bill and that the federal
government has chosen to bifurcate the
the two entities and rightfully so I
wholly believe in the Credence of that
that we should aim to do the same in
this state I do LW representative so
sod's efforts on this and think that
state authority to oversee ensure and
and at times if necessary
enforce um
non-compliance with the with these
report reporting uh standards I think
that there's Merit in that I I wholly
agree with Mr Bradley's commentary about
CMS reporting their non-compliance
issues and there there is rather modest
if little at all um enforcement action
taken on I know two hospitals in Georgia
had last year been fined mightily might
I say but I think that different than
how I think a lot about government this
is a good example of how State Authority
might better serve the citizenry because
we can we have a more intimate knowledge
of the healthc Care delivery system and
we could act more swiftly and I think
have suff efficient resources to ensure
stronger compliance from both hospitals
and insurers and taken
together that's um I'm very optimistic
that that that there is Credence here so
I think that if we separated the two
bills and we're fortunate enough to see
them move forward then that could help
citizens in the work that we do and the
New Hampshire Hospital Association
does representative Weber
representative Lucas did you still have
a question
or representative McLean addressed my
question thank you thank
you representative Weber thank you so if
a consumer has a concern about um the
payments made under their employer
insurance or other insurance do you have
in the insurance department because I'm
far less familiar than is my my
colleague to my right uh do you assist
people who are in dispute with their um
insurance carriers or health care
providers and is some kind of Ombudsman
or uh consumer protection available
through your department thank you for
your question yes oftentimes multiple
times a week we get through our consumer
services division um citizens call and
providers sometimes call on with
grievances about those those disp
arities and we use many different data
sets to help investigate and and often
times it really comes down to educating
the the patient the citizen and it's not
always a comfortable situation because
ouch I mean I'm hearing the work that we
do every day to to be responsible about
communicating price information on New
Hampshire Health cost I'm hear and that
get criticized and we we do we become
conditioned to that criticism because
we've learned that it it's a very
challenging economic and
financial um construct to to educate
people on and we never we're never
dealing with people who are happy at the
moment with our with the insurance
department nor the health care delivery
system so we use the claims data and
we've been successful with both the
transparency and coverage data and from
insurers and the hospital price
transparency data finding their
self-reported reference
charges and comparing them to what the
patient has seen on New Hampshire Health
cost to to validate and reconcile that
and so we there's High utility for
US Representative Nagel thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question this
is going to be Wicked complex I'm sorry
I'm a dinosaur I've been in private
practice for 35 years the guy next to me
is even more of a dinosaur as I think
you know but anyway I have felt I need
to say that um I've this bill really
strikes a nerve with me because it's a
big problem it's forced me to do
something I really don't want to do it's
I have to look at the insurance status
of all my patients which I really don't
like doing we're seeing a number of
Trends and I think it's a good thing but
there are unintended consequences to
everything prior authorization is a good
thing however now I have an entire
department in my office that does
nothing prior but prior authorization
which creates cost for me and the
patient and the system workers
compensation same thing it same thing
the reality is is the dollar amount for
each patient is patient centered it's
very individual and every patient's
circumstances are different so now we
have to have a department that will talk
to each individual patient at Great cost
what do you see as the ramifications to
cost to the system of doing this and are
there better ways to do
this thank you and indeed I agree that
is a complex question question so you
know economic theory might pause it such
that the the reason why that price
variation exists and exist so mightily
and is in fact a problem for the Whole
Health Care system is the fact that we
have very little price awareness and
uing to that is very little price
sensitivity price sensitivity is a a
concept where people will seek out lower
cost Alternatives holding quality
constant if they're aware of prices we
do it in all segments of our economy and
Healthcare is just one of the segments
where we don't do that and I argue one
of the main reasons why is because why
would we if we have no idea what the
price is there's no underlying Financial
incentive or motivation for us to do
that so in economics too we have short
run intermediate and then long run
effects what you're talking about to
make it better I I perceive as a long
run economic effect of making all mooms
of trans Arcy available to the system so
that people can get more price aware and
more price sensitive it's not going to
happen in next legislative session see
we we pass these bills and the prices
are the same I knew that wouldn't work
that's not something that we should ever
expect by the power of our pens in this
room rather we need to start
incrementally and systematically making
people and making entities more um
transparent about the prices and it over
time I think and I think a lot of my
colleagues Nationwide who I work on
these same
Endeavors um think that holistically
price transparency will make our system
function more optimally and that's
that's important it's a thoughtful
question and that's how I think of it
it's really the long run um effect of
multiple iterations in multiple sectors
of the healthcare industry being more
trans trans arent it's astonishing that
we don't know what we're going to pay if
you go to any Supermarket that has over
180,000 distinct units with distinct
prices we know within the 5cent in
increment what we're going to pay
gasoline is within the n910 of a cent
increment what we're going to pay yeah
for something so important as health
care even people who are Health policy
experts that work on this daily don't
know what they're going to pay until 3
months later when they get that
hyperbolic bill
this this endeavor May aim to offer
relief in
transparency follow a a followup rep
fair to say then we're looking at a
short-term increase in cost for a
long-term decrease in
cost it's not unfair to say that I think
the magnitude everything comes with a
cost our our health care System comes
with Mighty cost I'll refer you to the
insurance Department's total healthare
expenditure model that we just published
in our fall annual hearing that showed
13.2 billion in the small state of New
Hampshire for Total Healthcare
expenditures
$933 per capita so if you're looking at
the marginal cost of compliance for
Price transparency at the insurer level
and at the hospital provider
level the marginal cost compared to the
absolute cost of$ 13.2 billion is
negligible so
that's a cost that I would be I'm a free
market conservative person and think
much about incurrent cost that's
unnecessary had I thought that about
this I wouldn't have it in my heart to
be able to sit here in front of you nice
folks doing this great work and say that
yeah we should do this I would encourage
otherwise but so it's worth the cost
it's really
important representative Weber and then
representative
Woods thank you and thank you for taking
my question and I I would very much like
a very short answer to this
um listening to you just now I am
remembering back that at the beginning
of the testimony you said you were
neutral and it sounded very much to me
by the time that you were finished
talking just recently you were far more
positive than what I would consider
neutral given with the exception of your
point
about divorcing the two different
components of the bill so are you in is
the department in fact neutral or do you
in fact think this is something we
should go ahead with I'm neutral on this
bill as it pertains to hospital entities
for which the insurance department has
no authority over
so so followup well but you stated you
were neutral on the bill are is the
department supporting the other part of
the bill or is is the department neutral
on the other depart part of the bill the
the other the other part of this bill or
the how's Bill 705 I'm asking I'm just
trying all I'm trying to do is write
down on my piece of paper in front of me
whether the department supports the bill
or doesn't support the bill and it
sounds like you support one part of the
bill and do are neutral on the other I
just want to write it down the right way
so I'm not misrepresenting the
Department's position if you're neutral
on everything that's fine if you're
supporting part and not supporting part
that's fine thank you representative
Weber I'm just asking you to be clear
because I mentioned House Bill 705
that's in we that's an insurance
department Bill we spon we encourage the
legislator to sponsor this bill we're
neutral on this bill with the one
exception is the part about the
insurance I would I would suggest we
censor that from this
given that it's probably
not in the appropriate statute it might
better be served to be communicated in
House Bill 705 which indeed it is it's
it sits redundantly in this Bill thank
you for the question representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question this is very
short but um given the complexity and
the inroad that goes into almost every
aspect of Medical Care um how much of
this uh would be obviated if we had
Single
Payer that that's beyond the limits of
my knowledge that's a thoughtful
question but extends beyond the limits
of my knowledge
yeah other
questions see no other questions thank
you sir thank you so
much no one else has signed up to
testify on hb7 743 FN does anyone else
wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on this bill
and open the public hearing on HB 524 FN
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative
Granger uh thank you Mr chair and uh
members of the committee I'm going to be
introducing this with uh Laura here you
should have her pin card up there as
well this bill repeals the vaccine
Association and the primary reason to do
that is to save a large amount of money
um because right now uh the state is
spending a lot of money on this vaccine
Association for alleged cost savings
that aren't actually there and uh
therefore I will turn it over to Laura
who has been on the board of the vaccine
Association in the past and can speak
much more fluently on it than I
can much
good morning chairman McDonald and
committee members I support this bill I
do not believe that DHHS should be in
the business of buying and selling
vaccines for commercially insured
children through the vaccine
Association and I repeal and and I
support repeal the law that created this
costly and unnecessary
Association it is best to remove
government from involvement in the
purchase of medical products when
Private Business does quite well and
cost effectively for vaccines for adults
in fact the legislature rejected a bill
not too long ago as too costly
unnecessary growth of government that
would have swept in the purchase of
adult vaccines into this program it is
especially timely at this time of
significant budget crisis that
legislators support the governor and
look to programs that are costing
taxpayer dollars that can be better done
by Private
Industry it's time to shrink unnecessary
government and vote to pass HB
524 by way of background I am a
volunteer New Hampshire director of
advocacy with the national vaccine
information center a position I've had
since
2011 I work to educate the public on
vaccine policy and law and advocate for
informed voluntary consent I have
attended the New Hampshire vaccine
Association board meetings for probably
about 15 years in June of 2014 I was
appointed by the Senate president to
serve as a public member on the board a
position I served in for 5 years I have
remained a committed attendee and active
commentator at all board meetings during
my time on the board I worked on the
board to adopt Common Sense best
practices and push for greater
transparency and disclosure to the
public with regard to vaccine purchases
and practices of DHHS in this
Association I had some successes but in
recent years have found that DHHS and
the board have not only backtracked on
those measures but are now actively
withholding information from the public
about this program their practices and
expenditures I was actually bound from
the board in
2019 in replace by an industry Insider a
Right Aid pharmacist um hardly
represented of the public interests you
know someone is up to no good when they
work extra hard to avoid transparency
and disclosure any quasi government
Association that seeks to shut out the
public from truthful and proper
disclosure of policies and spending
deserves to be eliminated you know
someone is up to no good when they work
extra hard to avoid transparency and
disclosure why do we even have this
vaccine Association in 2002 RSA 126 Q
became law based on the false premise
that government can do this cheaper than
Private Industry it was based on the
false representation that vaccines
purchased through the CDC and the
federal vaccines for children contract
was a savings on vaccines compared to
market pricing but market pricing is
just like manufactured suggest a reeal
price on a car no one is actually paying
that price in fact vaccine providers in
New Hampshire all purchase vaccines for
adults through very costeffective group
purchasing organizations and
manufactured discount programs without
the unnecessary cost of government
involvement saving up to 60% depending
on the vaccine in interestingly at the
same time this original legislation was
being passed a new private business was
created to offer administrative services
to run this Association and was awarded
a multi-year no bid contract that
repeated for 16 years this private
business worked to pass similar
legislation in five other states where
it also secured the contract for
administrative Services Beyond this and
a study was done that shows other states
have looked into this model and have
rejected it soundly as unnecessarily and
too costly so what will this bill do
because there's a lot I've seen the
comments online a lot of confusion about
what this Association is and what this
bill will do and won't do what it will
do it will save money by removing
government employees and cost from the
ordering purchasing distribution
marketing and monitoring of vaccines
purchase for commercially insured
children the New Hampshire vaccine
Association will claim their
administrative costs are a small
percentage of the cost of vaccine
purchases and that's true um but that
claim completely ignores the staff at
DHHS involved on this board working to
purchase distribute and monitor this
state vaccine inventory doing site
visits at doctor's offices that sort of
thing how many employees and how much
cost well that's hard to know but
certainly you should be offended by the
fiscal note that's attached to this bill
because it fails to disclose those
obvious savings instead make makes two
absurd Claims One absurd claim is that a
part-time staffer would need to be hired
to tell providers you're getting
vaccines in a different through a
different process you'll purchase your
own instead of using one of the many
employees they will no longer need so
it's absurd they would be hiring
additional people by eliminating this
program the second false claim and the
fiscal know is that there is an there
are additional General funds would be
needed um to be build um Health insurers
would be needed excuse me to purchase
vaccines during a Public Health crisis
uh outbreaks or disaster relief effort
if DHHS has been billing Health insurers
for that now they are violating state
law as they have no authority to Bill
insurers for those government use
vaccines for the vaccine
Association but then DHHS vaccine
program has never been audited it is a
$40 million year vaccine purchase
program and there's been no audit and I
know that for certain because I might
made a 91a request to DHHS and I asked
for the most recent two years of audits
or their vaccine purchase program and I
was informed there's never been an audit
the vaccine Association does their own
audit but that's just money going in and
out it does not tell us about the
purchase of
vaccines it will it will the claim is it
will put the purchase of child vaccines
back in oh it will um put the purchase
of child vaccines back in the hands of
private providers just like they
purchase vaccines for adults quite
effectively and efficiently it will
reduce waste Fraud and Abuse many
vaccines can be used for children or
adults there is no control over who
providers are using these vaccines for
they've got a
refrigerator please stop wrapping up
okay um taxpayers will save millions of
dollars for reductions in staff at
DHS what it won't do some people think
that it's going to remove requirements
it does not it does not make vaccines
harder to get it does not make vaccines
more expensive it does not eliminate
vaccines for poor children that's the
vaccine for children program entirely
separate it won't suddenly require costs
of deductibles and co-pays federal law
prohibits that vaccines still will be
free for any parent who want them for
their children um this bill does not
take a position on the benefits of Merit
vaccines it's um it is is simply a long
overdue Bill removing uh what should be
a private function the purchase of
medical products from government and
shifting that back to Private Industry I
ask that you vote to pass thank this
bill please any
questions representative palaza and then
representative
mlan thank you uh Mr chair and uh thank
you for your testimony um could you uh
am I correct in understanding that Most
states don't have this body similar to
New Hampshire vaccine
Association that that is correct um it
was initially created in New Hampshire
and then the the fellow who created the
business to offer his administrative
Services he got a no big contract that
that continued for this he went on to
other states five other states and
legislation was passed there and
interestingly he secured the
administrative contracts in those States
as well so I'm I'm not sure who this
Association is
serving representor
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question you you touched
upon this you know tangent but let's
just say we don't need the vaccine
Association for you know General ronal
the mill but let's say there's a zombie
apocalypse I won't use covid because
that's too political but let's say
there's a zombie apocalypse and there's
a a vaccine that comes and we really got
to distribute this quickly and
efficiently um how do you see that
happening in the absence of the vaccine
Association simply the the way that they
would purchase any other routine
vaccinations you know once it's
commercially available they can purchase
it with regard to covid it took some
time before it was commercially
available so all the covid shots were
being purchased with federal dollars um
by the federal government and supply to
the state so um if it was that sort of
thing I think it would go through that
same scenario and and no money goes to
this Association in that scenario if it
was similar to co interesting that you
didn't want to touch on the covid shots
but since you brought them up I will
touch on those I did raise the question
of why the vaccine Association is um
reimbursing DHHS for the purchase of
covid shots because under the definition
of vaccines in their very own statute
126q the $3.6 million they spend on
those does not they do not qualify as
vaccines under the definition in their
own
statute other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you there oh sorry representative
kof fall uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so you
know one of the criticisms that I've
heard and I don't think I heard it in
your testimony was around um audit um
and sort of to what extent has the
vaccine Association been
audited
um I so i' I've I've heard that and yet
I've also heard that they have an audit
so I'm I'm just trying to get
clarification on if you're familiar with
that what what does it mean yes having
you know attended all their board
meetings and serve for five years as a
public member yes the vaccine
Association is audited I've I've
reviewed that audit um so they are
audited year but that is simply did we
provide um the money to DHHS that we
collected and that they ask for what it
does not do is it does not audit that
$40 million annual purchase of vaccines
by DHHS are they purchasing and
requesting for reimbursement from the
association vaccine products that are
qualify as vaccines are they actually
Distributing those there's there's no
audit zero oversight on that there is a
second report that the vaccine
Association provides to the legislature
that's called their annual report it's
generally a two or three page document
it's it's really a marketing um brochure
uh put out by DHHS and large part of it
it's a letter from DHHS so kind of a a
poor report of anything that's
material any other questions
representative
Drew uh thank you Mr
chairman my question is this I I read
through the statute on this and it very
much seems that this
is for all intents and purposes a tax
and it's a tax that's set by the vaccine
Association assessed from insurance
companies who essentially have no choice
because if they don't pay they lose
their license and then it's handed over
to DHHS for the purchase of something is
that an accurate assessment of how this
program operates um you you could call
it a tax I mean obviously it's it's it's
called an assessment but you know I'm
glad that you you raised that because
one of the the other concerns is um the
entire cost of this vaccine Association
including administrative costs legal
fees is being written off as Medical
Loss and that the statute allows them to
do that so those administrative costs
with any other company um the federal
government requires those administrative
costs be separate and they're limited to
15 or 20% of Premium costs anything
above that is refunded to Consumers so
this artificially increases health
insurance premiums to Consumers unfairly
that um they they shouldn't be paying
those administrative costs as if they
were Medical Loss other question I hope
that's
helpful seeing no other questions thank
you thank you thank you
uh Carla Smith is she still
here
okay sorry we be high in schedule this
morning I know you're on a tight time
frame thank you chair and thank you
committee I greatly appreciate you
letting me um present to you today so
hello everybody my name is Carla Smith
I'm a registered nurse here in New
Hampshire and my position is strongly
about preserving access to care and
maintaining costeffective care and
thereby I am opposed to this bill in a
former role as a school nurse I have
seen firsthand the critical importance
of vaccination in ensuring children can
safely attend school vaccines protect
children from dangerous diseases and
historical outbreaks such as polio
highlight just how devastating these
diseases can be more recently we've seen
an uptick in measles outbreaks which
underscore the ongoing risk of vaccine
preventable diseases when New Hampshire
families have access to immunizations
our entire state benefits creating a
healthier and safer Community for
everyone that's why I am deeply
concerned about House Bill 524 which
threatens to dismantle our state's
children's vaccine program right now New
Hampshire's immunization system is
designed to be efficient and cost
effective insurance companies contribute
to a central f fund that is managed by
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
which allows the state to purchase
vaccines at a 30% discount these
vaccines are then provided to families
at no
costs hostel 524 however would eliminate
the vaccine Association forcing doctors
offices to manage their own vaccine
inventories in Bill insurance companies
at full
price this would likely mean higher
out-of-pocket costs for families
including C pays and co- insurance and
added administrative burdens of doctor's
offices this bill would create
unnecessarily
unnecessary cost barriers for both
families and health care providers
making it harder for children to receive
the vaccines they need to stay safe and
healthy in school at a time when vaccine
hesitancy is increasing and compliance
in school vaccine requirements are
decreasing New Hampshire needs the
vaccine Association to avoid any
contribution to these Trends we must
preserve our state's immunization
program to ensure that every child has
access to vaccines without Financial
hurdles thank you so much for your time
thank you I know you have to leave are
you taking questions or I'd be happy to
take questions any questions for Carla
Smith yes representative palazov thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh you you mentioned uh poo uh
elimination
so um given uh it was probably a long
time
ago uh am I correct in assuming that New
Hampshire vaccine Association had no
role in it and what was there any
disease that was eliminated since we had
New Hampshire vaccine
Association no um I use that as an
example I think childhood immunization
requirements for schools is very very
important and it's near to dear to me um
in my experiences being a school nurse
I've been very fortunate I've never seen
a child with polio I truly hope I never
see a child with polio I hope all of you
in this room never have that happen
diseases
reemerge when vaccine vaccine rates go
down and we're really seeing a trend
right now in measles um and I think we
have to make this about accessibility to
care this is not a debate or bill that's
about whether to vaccinate or not it's
not about what to require in schools
those we've had those bills I'm sure
more of those are coming up again they
always do it's like round hog
dayve sorry about that um but this is
about this is a cost efficient mechanism
to make vaccines available and I do not
want to see that go
away other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak a Colleen Smith
and anarie marcoon from the Department
of Health and Human
Services they'll structure okay you want
to go later on the okay are we talking
about Patrick Miller
great good morning Mr chairman and um
members of the committee appreciate the
opportunity to speak today my name is
Patrick Miller I currently serve as the
executive director for the New Hampshire
vaccine Association um currently we are
opposed to House Bill
524 uh for those of you who are not
familiar with the purpose or the work of
the association it is a not for-profit
independent 501c3 voluntary corporation
that was formed under RSA 292 and
created by State Statute 23 years ago
the association was initially
established for the convenience of
Health insurers and third-party
administrators payers to ensure stable
and Equitable contributions to the
state's Universal uh vaccine purchase
program the uvp combines federal funds
designated for the state's Medicaid and
uninsured children with private funds
from the association's member pay ERS to
enable provider practice locations to
have access to all vaccines at no cost
to them or to patients New Hampshire was
the first of 14 states to create
Universal vaccine purchase programs
additionally all 50 states and
territories have programs supporting
Medicaid and uninsured children with
federal
funds the association has a limited role
in the state's uvp the association
itself does not purchase
vaccines it does involve multiple
constituencies the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
they currently have 209 Pediatric and
family care provider practice sites
enrolled the New Hampshire insurance
department there are currently 91
Commercial Health insurers and
thirdparty administrators that pay into
the
program our board consists of
Representatives of payers providers and
consumers as well as the commissioners
of both nhid and
DHHS I just want to take a minute to
explain the mechanics of the program um
they're quite
straightforward um in August of each
year the association receives an annual
estimated invoice of the funds it needs
from the association to fund the program
in September we calculate the rate that
the insurance companies will pay and
approve that and then four times a year
we collect money from the insurance
companies and then in June we had a
final invoice that's been Tred up from
the department and we remit a check at
the end of the
day this pass through funding mechanism
helped support the Department of Health
and Human Services in their ability to
provide these free vaccines to healthc
care providers whether the patient is
privately insured has Medicaid
Etc it is expected to save about 30% on
childhood immunization purchases this
coming year and has total administrative
costs of less than 1% which are born
100% by the payers not the state and to
put this in perspective we spent
$154,000 last year on Administration on
a program that had $18.3 million
attached to it I really challenge
anybody to find something that is
running more efficiently than the
vaccine Association at
84% we do have accountability in
multiple areas we have reporting
requirements and statute to the governor
the Senate President Speaker of the
House the commissioners of DHHS and nhid
these reports are public on our website
we have an annual report an annual
Financial audit and we have uh five
board and three committee meetings each
year that are held online and open to
the
public we're fundamentally opposed to
this as it has met and currently meets
its established attent of ensuring
stable and Equitable contributions from
payers to the state's
uvp Additionally the association saves
administrative billing costs for payers
and providers by eliminating them it
saves cost on immunizations and that
acrs to the payers employers and
ultimately consumers it allows providers
to avoid the burden of inventory
carrying costs in the case of one
immunization for RSV providers would
need to front $4,500 just to be able to
offer a single dose of the immunization
if you could start wrapping up Sir Y and
then ultimately it allows providers to
offer these no cost vaccines in summary
this pass through mechanism has been
working well for nearly a quarter of a
century as the addage says if it's not
broken don't fix it I really thank you
for the opportunity to present this
testimony happy to answer any questions
if there's any regulatory questions uh
the association's outside council is
here today and my contact information is
enclosed thank you thank you
representative Nagel thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question this is
kind of a crystal ball type question but
um if you cease to exist as this bill
passed um and as the first I'm sorry I
don't remember names well the first
person who testified suggest that this
could be handled better privatized um
what do you envision would happen to the
provision of I think what will happen is
the state could continue to participate
in the childhood for vaccine program for
Medicaid children and then on the
commercial side providers would have to
decide whether one they could afford to
purchase and stock the vaccines they'd
then have to go through the
administrative billing practices if they
did choose to stay and and offer them
they would then have to um build the
carriers get money back from the
carriers and move forward and what I've
heard and I believe there's people here
to today that we'll talk to this more
specifically whether it's a federally
qualified Health Center or even large uh
medical centers that whole process is
extremely costly for them especially the
carrying cost of the vaccines and I
think we've all listening to the prior
Bill heard about medical billing and and
what that entails so this really
eliminates all of that thank you one
more thing not all childhood vaccines
can also be given in retail say Pharmacy
locations and so I think that's another
another issue that would be
faced representative
lamon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question have any of your
um member providers pediatric practices
asked to not participate and buy their
vaccines on the free market I will defer
that to the health department because
they actually manage the provider
relationships our job is really to
collect funds from the insurance
companies and remit that back to the
department but as as far as I know no
but I when they come up I think it'd be
great to ask them thank you
representative u u
palaza thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question sure um so there
was a a question about uh U assessment
uh uh um whether it function like uh
attacks so could you confirm that uh if
uh uh Insurance uh uh some
company uh is not paying into it uh they
will lose their
license um I would have to have somebody
from the insurance department you know
respond to the license they are required
under RSA
126q uh both fully insured plans as well
as self-funded plans which are typically
through the third party administrators
or some of the larger carriers to
participate um again when the program
was put together uh it initially was
based on uh some voluntary funding back
in the early '90s and then everybody
figured with more companies coming to
the state it made sense to standardize
this to make it Equitable across all
carriers uh and later additional things
were changed in the program to continue
that such as it's only on child assessed
lives it doesn't include adults as an
example so um right now it's based upon
statute other
questions representative Lucas thank you
chair and thank you for taking my
question um there's crystal ball
question if I may um in the absence of
the
association and in private practices
that decide that they cannot afford the
cost of carrying the
vaccines where do the patients go if
they choose to have the vaccines right
so currently there is no plan for that
because we've got so many practices that
do participate in other outlets for them
um potentially it would disrupt the
relationship between the pediatrician
and the patient because i''d have to go
somewhere else to find the vaccine um
and I'm not sure that from a um from
sort of a cost perspective as well
whether it may be you know travel to as
well as just a general disruption like
it would create a lot of problems and
I'm guessing some folks today will also
talk to that specifically that are
providers but there's there's no other
place to go currently and especially
because of the age you can't just walk
into a pharmacy and vaccinate your child
with the requirements thank you yes uh
other questions represent uh
representative Woods did you have okay
representative palaza thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my other
question yes so could you talk about
other states so there was some
conflicting uh numbers today uh first I
heard uh about five states have similar
programs and uh you told 14 or 15 uh so
if you could help with how different
states do it and if we see different
results comparing to uh other 35 or so
States who don't have a centralized uh
purchase program sure so the um
Association of immunization managers
does publish a map of the country and
which states have these programs and
again the fully Universal states which
means you've got private money and uh
money from the federal government
involved there are 14 of those States
currently um and so I'm sure that could
be provided to you if you'd like to take
take a look at that and I apologize I
forget the second part of your
question uh so if you could compare
those 14 states with program with uh
states without program do we see any
differences in cost and immunization
rates or anything I know there are wide
variations across the country in terms
of immunization rates I'm not an
epidemiologist so I think I would defer
that question to the department if that
would be okay with the committee
anyone else representative Nagel thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question sure you're I don't want you to
give me the entire budget but um the the
money youve taken where does all that
come from so the money that we receive
um comes from individual insurance
companies and third party administrators
so they're currently 91 that pay into
the program and that number fluctuates
it goes up and down as carriers come in
and out of the state and have uh
pediatric patients
um and so what happens is on a quarterly
basis um each one of those child covered
lives that each carrier has gets
assessed and uh funds are brought into
the association and then we write
essentially one large check to the state
at the end of the year and can I ask
follow up so why is there such a large
savings listed on the fiscal note to the
state that's what confuses me I will
have the state respond to the fiscal
note because that's a that's something
that they wrote that's
okay anyone
else seeing no one okay thank you okay
thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Kim
Bernard from the nashille division of
Public Health and Community Services
oh if
I uh if Mr Bernard I've already called
Mr Bernard but if uh he's willing to
defer to you that's fine and what's your
name I have a card from you right
yeah as you can see there's quite a few
here we go
yeah can you put your mic on
please um good morning members of the if
I could just interrupt you briefly uh to
the committee we're going to do a
rolling lunch today we're going to go
continue to go not take a formal break
for lunch if you want to go just go at
your leisure and I'm just want to get us
back on schedule so yeah without that
you please proceed okay thank you thank
you for hearing my testimony my name is
Dr Christine arnow I'm a pediatrician
here in conquered I'm the vice president
of the New Hampshire chapter of the
American Academy of Pediatrics and I'm
also a mother of three I think that um
the um I am here to ask you to oppose
house built 524 I think that what the
New Hampshire vaccine Association does
has been well outlined it saves money by
having a group purchase for vaccines and
then having those vaccines distributed
to
practices um if this bill were to pass
pediatric practices would have to buy
vaccines and charge patient insurances
for them as been described this gives
the insurance companies power
essentially to
charge theoretically whatever they want
for those vaccines and for that cost to
theoretically be put back on the patient
right now these vaccines are given to
patients completely free of
charge um one thing I wanted to speak to
is that the process of vaccine
management is appropriately very heavily
regimented we have you know a
refrigerator that has to be kept at a
certain temperature certain humidity we
have I work for a small Private Practice
here in town and we have um a employee
who works 20 hours a week just on
vaccine management
ordering communicating um with the state
database and that's just for our small
practice that is a mere you know small
fraction of the the number of kids in
the state getting vaccines
um the author of the bill estimate that
it would take a single part-time state
employee
to work work out this transition based
on my experience this is a gross
underestimate um this bill would require
the staff support of multiple employees
perhaps a whole team which would be very
costly during that transition as um the
individual from the New Hampshire
vaccine Association mentioned the system
we have works very well it allows us to
give kids who want vaccines vaccines at
no cost to those
families and for this reason um house
bille house bill 524 asked the state to
spend money to create a problem the
authors of this bill agree that it will
cost the state more money we disagree
exactly how much um but I believe that
it would be far far more than they
anticipate and anyone who works in a
medical office knows that it will hurt
pediatric practices and patience um for
this reason I urge you to please oppose
House Bill
524 and I should mention I speaking on
behalf of the New Hampshire Academy of
American Academy of Pediatrics as well
as myself thank you y any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you okay let me try that again Kim
Bernard from the national division of
Public Health and Community Services
here I am we have a a police chief in
London areas called his name is Kim
Bernard so if I refer to you as he
earlier I apologize that's okay I saw
Kim Bernard and I I think of our police
chief so
anyway all right good
morning my name is Kim
Bernard I am a registered nurse with
over 30 years
experience I currently serve as the
chief public health nurse at the
Nashwood division of Public Health and
Community
Services we serve the greater naswa area
which includes the naswa and the 12
surrounding CI in
towns we are fortunate enough in our
great state of New Hampshire to have
both the vaccines for children the vfc
program and the state funded program so
that all children under the age of 19
can be vaccinated at no
cost why would we want to change
this why would we want to make it harder
for parents to keep their children
healthy we do not have this Equity with
adult vaccines and we see the challenges
it
causes without the New Hampshire vaccine
Association program increased barriers
may keep children from becoming
vaccinated which also opens up children
to diseases that are
preventable and in turn increases cost
to the
state for example there are actual
scenarios of access barriers we have
assisted with in our work as public
Public Health nurses and here are a
few we cared for a 2-year-old boy in our
Clinic who needed a hepatitis A vaccine
because his provider does not carry
it we've assisted a mom who brought her
one-year-old baby to our Clinic to
receive the covid vaccine because his
provider did not carry
it we we um served a family with six
children who wanted to space out their
childhood vaccines we worked with this
family and it's very challenging for a
practice to do
that in terms of flu vaccines it's
sometimes difficult for busy working
families to get a visit at their
provider's
office we assisted an 18-year-old going
to college who needed their menitis
vaccine to complete College admission
paperwork we also recently cared for an
18-year-old who was never vaccinated and
now he is making an educated decision to
protect himself and others
we also often see kids who need routine
vaccines for the school year but could
not get an appointment at their
provider's office due to challenges with
limited
Workforce as public health professionals
our core role includes protecting and
promoting the health of our
community a key factor in facilitating
this is through
prevention as leaders in our community
we need to do better to decrease
barriers to health care for all people
as well as keep costs down in our
state I sincerely appreciate the
opportunity provide testimony and strong
opposition of House Bill 524 and urge
you to oppose this Bill thank you thank
you any
questions I don't see any thank you
thank you so
much okay Colleen Smith and anmarie
mccon do you I want to
testify good afternoon chairman McDonald
members of the committee thank you for
allowing us to testify today on House
Bill 524 my name is Colleen Smith I am
the bureau I'm the bureau chief for the
Bureau of infectious disease within the
division of Public Health services
within the Department of Health and
Human Services and today I'm joined by
an Mercury anarie Mercury who is our
immunization Section Chief and we are
here to oppose House Bill
524 we want to we want to Echo what you
have heard in previous testimony that we
believe that the New Hampshire vaccine
Association helps create the best access
for New Hampshire families and children
to access immun immunizations in our
state
we also want to Echo that it will it
does save money to insurers and group
health plans and also we want to Echo
that because the department is integral
in vaccine management and education to
healthcare providers we we assist
healthcare providers in minimizing waste
which is a savings and efficient in
establishes efficiencies with within
that provider practice
if House Bill 524 was enacted there
would be an immediate impact to healthc
care providers they would again have to
as was expressed in previous testimony
have to bear upfront cost for vaccine
managing separate inventories of vaccine
the department did provide a fiscal note
to this and I'm going to turn it to
anarie to give more details on that
fiscal
note
hello shove myself off sorry about that
good afternoon thank you very much um
I'd like to share some information about
the fiscal node and then I'd like to
provide further details from the
Department because I think there's been
a lot of questions that we um are able
to answer so regarding the fiscal note
um if this bill were to be enacted um
the department would no longer be able
to purchase vaccines for privately
insured children so the fiscal note was
entered in for $150,000 for year one and
then
$100,000 each year um p pass that and
that is to prepare for an event of an
outbreak um outbreaks can be extremely
expensive for vaccination um when we are
looking at a vaccine of uh $25 per dose
and we have to administer four to 5,000
doses that comes to uh pretty close to
$100,000 um so outbreaks are very very
expensive to control without the vaccine
Association we would not have the
universal program and we would need some
funds if the department were to be able
to to assist providers and um handle a
vaccine outbreak um so I would like to
then move into additional uh details
about how the department works with the
vaccine Association to answer some of
the questions that have come up um about
our role so the vaccine Association as
mentioned it saves money it reduces the
provider burden and it ensures the
universal access for all children um
each year the department estimates the
number and cost of the immuniz that will
be needed for children to cover the
entire child population of New Hampshire
we recognize that not every child will
get vaccinated not every child will get
fully vaccinated so our estimate is
based on the actual Doses and cost of
the vaccines that were purchased the
prior year so we um have you know those
projections that we provide to the
vaccine
Association um we do have a uh cost
split between the federal vaccine for
children program they cover 40% to cover
the costs for vaccinating children who
are Medicaid uninsured underinsured um
American um Indian and Alaskan natives
and then the vaccine Association covers
the non-vf eligible children which is
primarily the commercially
insured so um what we want to do is to
ensure that the vaccine Association is
only reimbursing the department for the
the cost of actual vaccines that are
administered so what we do is we have
very very tight controls of inventory
and fiscal management um we are um
monitoring how much vacine is going out
to each of the providers and we actually
apply a split funding per provider so we
collect data from the providers on an
annual basis they report to us the
numbers of vfc eligible children the
numbers of non-vf C eligible children
that way we know that provider office
has a specific percent split when a
provider places an order the department
goes ahead and applies that percent
split to that actual provider's office
so in the case of an fqc federally
qualified Health Care Center they may
have more Medicaid eligible children
than a provider who is in private
practice we apply different splits based
on their patient populations you ask for
four minutes so if you could start
wrapping up okay thank you um so we um
are VI Vigilant about controlling the
waste um how the cost savings comes into
play is we are a volume uh purchaser we
purchased through the CDC contract which
is a 27% cost savings as compared to
private market we've talked to the
manufacturers manufacturers would
consider a 4 to 11% discount based on
provider volume of vaccine purchase um
but there's no way near that they're
going to get um the savings that is um
afforded to the um insurers through this
program um and I would be happy to
answer any questions because I do want
to be respectful of your time thank you
very much representative
Weber sorry I I want to be sure that
I've got my uh gotten straight with the
uh fiscal note because they they talk
about $4 million decrease in in federal
spend in in state spending but am I
correct in reading this fiscal note as
there is an absolute wash because you
have the 24 million that comes in and
the 24 million that goes out
so that is uh there there's no
expenditure of General funds it's all
the money in and the money out and then
the vaccine is
distributed to each provider according
to what they have told you in advance
that they need is that correct that that
that is correct um the department does
not have any Financial gains or losses
it's um the expenditures and the
revenues are an exact wash for the New
Hampshire vaccine Association we would
need those additional funds for outbreak
control as mentioned right thank you
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman and thank you my friend for
that clarification on a fiscal note I
appreciate that um I I still want to
understand one thing though is this
functionally a self-funded organization
or is there a state contribution to it
and if so how much is
that so there is not a state
contribution um we are uh funded through
um federal grants to operate the New
Hampshire immunization program and um
because of that work our program and our
infrastructure is in place um the
additional costs of managing the vaccine
Association is is fractional um we um do
request uh six 60% of a few positions
because we are monitoring so much more
for the vaccine Association than we are
monitoring for the vfc program um but we
we do that in kind spirit because uh
we're good steward W of the dollar we
don't want any wastage uh we allow our
providers to transfer vaccine from one
another prior to expiration so that it's
used we worked very closely with the
providers uh we do not have them replace
any vaccine for uh circumstances beyond
their control so if there's a power
outage they're not responsible for
replacing that that loss if the vaccine
Association were repealed they would
become responsible for that um so
there's extreme cost savings to the
providers representative palazov thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh did I hear you correctly
that your fiscal note assumes outbreaks
every year and generally how many
outbreaks uh did we have in the last
decade um so the fiscal note is to
ensure that the funds are available in
the event of an outbreak so those funds
would not be used unless an outbreak
occurred
um our last outbreak uh we were dealing
with hepatitis A up until about
2021 um we went ahead and gave thousands
of doses of hepatitis A vaccine um so
and also obviously the pandemic um but
in general uh we do have low levels of
outbreak because of our vaccine coverage
if access becomes an issue fewer
children may get um may not have the
option to get vaccinated when they
choose to be vaccinated and they're
going to be more likely to be
susceptible other
questions representative
Drew so this is uh a hypothetical
question that I'm asking in order to
help me understand how this works let's
say we repeal this
statute what would stop the vaccine
Association from Simply continuing to
operate as a private entity
I believe without the statute they would
not have the authority authority to
collect the funds from the assessors I
would um refer to the vaccine
Association to answer that question um
but it would become a voluntary
contribution and not all payers May
contribute um so there would be no
problem with them giving that money to
DHHS to continue the program as is well
that would if the Association didn't
exist that would not be an option the
insur there's no mechanism for insurance
to pay the department directly without
the vaccine Association okay thank
you other
questions okay I'm seeing done thank
you I'm going to step out for a while
and turn the gavel over to the vice
chairman representative masor and
um let to take over for a little while
thank
you next we have Damian
Santana you have three minutes sir
thank you to the chair and the other
committee members for allowing me to
speak today my name is Damen Santana I'm
the public health emergency preparedness
coordinator for the capillary Public
Health Network and I'm here a little
closer to the microphone sure happy to
thank you is that better uh my name is
Damen Santana I'm the public health
emergency preparedness coordinator from
the capitol Area Public Health Network
which is one of 13 public health
networks in the state of New Hampshire
and I'm here to testify in opposition to
this bill and the reason for that is one
of the added benefits of this stream of
funding is that it does cover privately
insured children uh and where we use
that at the public health network level
um as an opportunity to both vaccinate
and also train emergency responders like
Medical Reserve Corps volunteers and ser
volunteers is um by holding school-based
flu clinics during the school season
so without that funding we would of
course still be able to vaccinate
um students that are vfc eligible but
that's a small portion of the students
that we do vaccinate and this gives a
creates an opportunity for the particip
participating public health networks to
carry out uh point of dispension uh
vaccination clinics in a real way that
we don't have an opportunity to practice
otherwise we can of course set up mock
drills but it's really not the same
thing uh and this allows us to run
through the practice of performing these
with in Cooper in cooperation with
Department of Health and Human Services
and other entities so the uh increased
accessibility also creates an
opportunity for families that for other
reasons may not be able to get
vaccinated uh at a provider's office or
have difficulty we certainly have built
a lot of strong relationships with
School nurses and school um and schools
that are working with our program to
help us to vaccinate kids that just may
have a difficult time uh getting
vaccinated else for other reasons uh
that's all my testimony but if anybody
has any questions I'm happy to do my
best to answer them thank you any
questions oh representative Paul is off
thank you uh Madame chair and thank you
for taking my question so we heard that
most States uh in the United States
don't have Central program like that so
have you heard any uh problems from from
those states do they have any problem
getting reimbursement for childhood
vaccination or
anything uh thank you for your question
representative uh paulov I'm afraid
that's outside of my purview because I
only operate at a regional level uh here
around uh the capital area so I serve 24
towns in and around conquered New
Hampshire um so I couldn't speak to what
other states do or how the reimbursement
process works um my testimony today is
just to explain that one of the other
added benefits of this is that it
creates an opportunity for us to take
volunteer emergency responders that
would be called to action during um any
kind of outbreak and gives them an
opportunity to put those skills into
practice to be better prepared uh if the
time needed so just an additional
benefit that I wanted to share with the
committee thank you representative Nagel
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
out of the 13 Community public health
networks how many do participate in the
process I'm sorry I don't have those
numbers either I work for um Grant
United Way so we're an initiative of
them we share that with uh the Capital
Area Public Health Network so I can say
for certainty that uh our two networks
do participate the total percentage out
of 13 I'm not
sure thank you any further
questions seeing none appreciate it
thank you for your time thank you next
we have Kate Frey from new
Futures you indicated two
minutes good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Kate fry vice
president of advocacy at new Futures
thank you for your time I know you've
had a long morning uh we are nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that um Works to
improve the health and wellness of New
Hampshire residents and in this role we
work extensively with policy makers and
Healthcare Providers and communities to
improve overall public health and
improve health Equity um I won't repeat
what was said I have my testimony that
really spells out what the um New
Hampshire vaccine Association does and
what it doesn't do I think you heard a
little bit about that today I want to be
very clear that they do not set vaccine
policy they're they're only a funding
mechanism um they don't mandate vaccines
or limit parent choice um they and they
have nothing to do with determining the
vaccine schedule again they're funding
mechanism only one thing that hasn't um
been covered is you've heard proponents
of the bill say that the state should
not be in the business of vaccines New
Hampshire was the first state to create
this Innovative costeffective model now
82% of states have policies to purchase
vaccines beyond what is aail available
through the federal vaccine uh program
to reduce cost barriers 14 have
replicated New Hampshire's Universal
purchasing program I think many people
would agree that it is the state's
business to use taxpayer funds wisely
while providing equal access to
life-saving immunizations and keeping
health care cost down this is good
business and all of this is made
possible by the New Hampshire vaccines
Association role in our state's public
health infrastructures for these reasons
new Futures urges this committee to vote
itl and I'm also going to be handing in
testimony from Dr suan tansky a
pediatrician um and who works at
Dartmouth hitchock who is also opposed
to the bill and has pointed out some
really great um what the impacts would
be to uh providers into
families right on time thank
you any questions from the
committee yes representative Weber did
you did that start around that testimony
or it afterward okay thank you I'm
losing track of my paperwork here thank
you all right next we have Christine
Stoddard do have
a okay
good now afternoon it's nice to see you
uh my name is Christine Stoddard and I
am the senior director of New Hampshire
public policy at viate Primary Care
Association by state has the pleasure of
serving and representing New Hampshire's
community health centers there are 10 of
them they serve including Planned
Parenthood we serve over 102,000
patients 20% of which are children so
20,000
kids are served by federally qualified
Health Centers across the state of New
Hampshire 36% of their patients are
commercially insured 31% of their
patients receive Medicaid if this bill
were to pass you're asking clinicians to
treat patients who have Commercial
Insurance differently than their
Medicaid patients and I'm here to tell
you in no uncertain terms the federally
qualified Health Centers cannot afford
to buy vaccines for their pediatric
patients they cannot afford to buy
vaccines for their adult patients who
are uninsured those patients are forced
to pay out of pocket or the fqc sends
them somewhere else like a commercial
Pharmacy where they would have to pay
out of pocket we cannot buy
vaccines in 2023 the ferally qualified
Health Centers had $14.5 million in
uncompensated care this would add to
that uncompensated care burden they
can't do it they would have to shut down
SES and stop serving patients and also
as a parent I implore you to oppose this
bill one of my kids is
autistic he is 10 years old it has taken
him 10 years to feel comfortable to see
a clinician my daughter is
neurotypical we would have to find a new
pedi pediatrician or pay out of pocket
we are not unique in this situation
there are many families with kids with
disabilities in the state of New
Hampshire I don't want to have to choose
a new pediatric practice when my son
with a disability has learned to love
his pediatric practice it would be
horrible for us I would also want to
share with you that in Coos County the
only primary care provider in gorm and
Berlin is a federally qualified Health
Center they treat almost 13,000 patients
many of whom are children they cannot
afford to buy vaccine scenes out of
pocket I'm happy to answer any questions
but I'd also like to allow Dr Peters to
speak from the perspective of Amis
Health which is in
Manchester hi I'm Kate Peters and I'm a
family doctor at amamos health I'm also
on the uh Board of the New Hampshire
Academy of family physicians and both
those organizations have said that I may
speak on their behalf today as well as
on my own um as a doctor but also as a
mom uh we are soundly opposed to HP 524
um for many of the reasons that have
already been mentioned uh amamos Health
where I work is a not profit uh
federally qualified Health Center and we
provide comprehensive primary care which
includes vaccines to people of all ages
um in the Manchester area and
surrounding towns um the NHA has been an
asset to folks like us um and to
healthcare providers across the state
since it was formed 23 years ago and
it's hard to imagine as described how we
would survive without it at this point
um you've already heard what the program
does let me just say from a provider
perspective and from the perspective of
you know running a large organization
that cares for a lot of people um as my
bosses have shared with me um if this
bill passes and the nhba goes away we
will have to create more cumbersome
systems um to order and pay for vaccines
and and that will be awful for us I hope
that you're already aware that we are in
a time of unprecedented Financial
fragility for our health centers um
organization like ours can't afford to
purchase these vaccines um paying
upfront and not knowing whether the cost
will be adequately reimbursed um we
don't have a budget for it and we don't
have a system for it um so as a family
doctor I can see how that's going to
cause chaos for lots of families like
yours across the state um and as a mom I
can see how damaging this would be this
would result in families needing to
change practices or take their kids to
separate appointments to get vaccinated
which means more days days off work more
stress um and fewer kids getting
vaccines overall and this is going to
disproportionately harm needy families
um you know my job as a healthcare
provider at an fqc and your job as
lawmakers is to protect equity in our
Health Care Systems and this build does
the opposite of that um it asks us to
dismantle a well-established highly
effective highly efficient organization
that saves money for our state and keeps
people healthy so the obvious choice is
to vote itl and I encourage you to do so
I'm also happy to take questions if you
have
any thank you representative
poov thank you Madame chair and thank
you for taking my question uh uh it's
probably uh for first Speaker Christin
St that uh you mentioned uncompensated
uh uh care so given that we are talking
about different demographics some people
ensure it and ensure it on Medicaid so
in what groups do you fore
uncompensated uh care uh do you expect
um private insurance companies uh
denying reimbursements for vaccines do
you expect uh I don't know Medicaid not
reimbursing and so on sure so this bill
is only applicable to commercially
insured kids so what would happen is is
if the fqc could theoretically buy
vaccines which they cannot they would
buy the vaccines magically and store
them and then wait for the insurance
carriers the commercially insured
carriers to reimburse them for that
their vaccines when the new RSB vaccine
came out our community health centers
were heartbroken because here's a
resource that they know their patients
need but they could not buy them out of
pocket so this bill would contribute to
the uncompensated care of the
commercially insured population not the
Medicaid
population if that makes
sense thank you any further
questions seeing none thank
you all right next we have Patricia
glastetter
if you could turn on your microphone
thank you you hear me
now H actually good afternoon um my name
is Patricia glastetter I'm a public
health nurse at the city of Nashville
Public Health Department get closer to
your Micha of course
yeah that better yes thank you thank you
um again I'm a public health nurse at
the city jhua Public Health
Department um I'd like to thank you all
after this long morning and afternoon um
for giving me the opportunity to speak
in opposition of House Bill
524 the New Hampshire vaccine
Association has created a bridge for
vaccine providers to receive all acip
recommended vaccines at no cost and they
have lowered barriers for families to
help prevent vaccine preventable
diseases now can you imagine our world
without Bridges
we would all have to take the long way
around and it would cost a lot more
money to drive completely around a river
if it was even possible and would it
surprise you if folks chose to drive
through a river because it was faster
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
Along with the state's private insurance
companies allow Public Health
departments medical providers as well as
federally qualified Health Care Centers
to bridge a very important Health Care
Gap vaccines for all of New Hampshire's
children as a public health nurse and
the vaccine coordinator for the city of
NASA Public Health Department I see the
health and human worth in protecting our
children as well as the beneficial
Financial impact of providing vaccines
to all of New Hampshire's children
regardless of their insurance status or
ability to
pay without the New Hampshire vaccine
Association healthc care providers like
myself and my colleagues would be unable
to provide no cost vaccine
to all of New Hampshire's children
shouldn't our goal be to bridge gaps and
reduce barriers for our children's good
health so now I ask you to consider our
great beautiful state without our
bridges this is Sim similar to how
repealing the New Hampshire vaccine
Association committee could affect our
children do we need to be reminded of
what life was like without our bridges
or when children were dying of polio and
diptheria please do not put another
barrier up for our families who need
help in keeping their children safe and
healthy and if you aren't able to see
the health benefits of what the New
Hampshire vaccine Association does
please think about the financial benefit
of keeping our children our future
healthy out of the hospital and
Alive please please allow the New
Hampshire vaccine Association to bridge
the gap for our children in aose House
Bill
524 thank you all for listening thank
you any questions does the committee
have any
questions I'm seeing none all right
thank you very
much next we have the honorable Jerry
kerk welcome back sir good to see you
again for the record for the record I'm
Jerry kerk uh for full disclosure though
I have to re uh St that uh Senator
Bradley appointed me to the New
Hampshire vaccine Association board last
fall but I am not speaking on their
behalf I'm testifying as a retired
physician and
legislator vaccination is one of the
most effective Public Health measures in
history if you've explored our old
cemeteries you'll see lots of uh
tombstones from the 18th and 19th
century with little kids names on them
and note that frequently several
children would die in the same month in
the same family why is that because of
communicable diseases things that we do
not see anymore and of course polio and
small pox are great examples of the
impact of vaccination now here's the key
issue the great majority of parents in
New Hampshire vaccinate their children
against communicable diseases that
demonstrates that your constituents need
and want access to vaccination it is our
duty then to provide those vaccinations
in the most coste efficient fashion and
with the least administrative burden on
providers and insurers the universal
vaccine purchase program established by
RSA 126 Q provides precisely that and I
won't go into the details because it's
already been given the old-timers here
will remember that I tried to expand the
New Hampshire vaccine Association to
cover adults as well back in 2020 it was
not rejected due to cost it failed since
the pharmacies refused to to participate
and they were significant uh providers
of adult vaccinations and therefore it
was just not a viable option so if this
bill were to pass there will be one of
two outcomes either we would not have a
system for childhood vaccine or a new
system would need to be set up in the
first scenario where there's no
Universal vaccine purchase program there
would be an increased administrative
burden on providers for ordering
vaccines increased cost to the vaccines
and increased administrative costs
associated with billing for both payers
and
providers therefore cost was increased
for insurers and providers resulting in
increased cost to all of us it would
likely result in decreased vaccination
rates leading to outbreaks of
communicable diseases and ultimately the
biggest cost vaccine preventable deaths
of our children the other scenario in
which a new system within DHHS would be
created would require ire authorization
of the department to hire individuals to
perform the Service rulemaking authority
and appropriation to cover those costs
but none of that is in this bill and
there's probably not much appetite for
another appropriation in this already
somewhat difficult budget year it would
also take time to become functional
during which time we would see the
problems of not having a
system the current system works very
well with an extremely low overhead we
owe it to our providers insurers and our
children
to maintain the current system which has
given New Hampshire one of the highest
vaccination rates in the nation with
excellent cost savings and minimal
administrative burden so please itl this
bill and I'd be glad to take any
questions thank you representative paaz
off thank you Madame chair and thank you
for taking my question uh so regarding
the cost uh to
DS uh we heard in testimony that they
don't uh expect uh much savings because
um all the current uh administrative
cost uh inside the department is covered
federally so I would assume if they need
to create a new system uh for for the
same purpose it also would be covered
fully federally so I think uh in your
second scenario we actually looking do
you have a question for him uh would you
agree that we are looking to saving
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
administration cost because they will be
covered
federally the federal does not cover the
private insurer
aggregation so that I'm pretty sure I'm
correct on that and so as a result the
issue is again it was a dichotomous
either we don't have a system or we've
got to set up a system and if we set up
a system we need to actually fund that
and that's not in this
bill represent of
Sebert um so I was so in your opinion I
guess overall um is it your opinion that
the vaccination Association if dis if
dissolved
would within the hell hold on so if this
if if the vaccination Association were
dissolved would all of these providers
and health departments be able to
um absorb the costs to vaccinate
children to keep children vaccinated or
what would happen in that case I think
that's beyond my knowledge but you've
heard multiple providers and practices
in by State uh already explain that they
will have a very hard time absorbing
that so I think that's the answer to
that thank you any further
questions saying none thank you thank
you thank you appreciate it next we have
Robert Lawless
is he still
here no
okay Madam chair could I just ask if Mr
laws who is not here could you tell us
what position Mr laws took um he he
opposed the Bill thank you from and
representing himself thank you okay
that's helpful uh next we have Meg overb
still here
no also oppose the
bill okay so lastly I have Kathy
Stratton oh oh
okay from New Hampshire Medical Society
okay you have three minutes thank you
thank you is it it's up oh turn it back
on there you go red means stop I guess
in my head yes
excuse
me
um dear chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is Kathy Stratton
I'm the CEO of the New Hampshire Medical
Society I'm representing the Medical
Society on behalf of our nearly 2,000
members today we strongly oppose House
Bill 524 the legislation that seeks to
disband the uh New Hampshire vaccine
Association um the medical society's
mission is to advocate for the
well-being of our patients and promote
Public Health HB 524 poses a direct
threat to both of these goals the New
Hampshire vaccine Association plays a
critical role in safeguarding public
health particularly by increasing access
to life-saving immunizations and
reducing the financial burden on
families in the state um we urge you to
vote itl on this bill I'm not going to
repeat a lot of the the testimony that
we've heard today but I do want to
highlight the clinicians and the
Physicians who have spoken um and I want
to highlight that several of our members
have also submitted uh testimony online
today um this bill allows healthc care
providers to administer vaccines to any
child regardless of their insurance
status or family income this ensures
that all children have access to
vaccines that prevent serious illnesses
hospitalization and even death um our
second point today is that the New
Hampshire vaccine Association Collective
purchasing power allows New Hampshire to
negotiate better rates for vaccines
saving taxpayers Millions each
year it's important to note that the New
Hampshire vaccine Association does not
set vaccine policy or create vaccine
laws in the state its sole purpose is to
collect and distribute funding as we've
heard um so vaccines can be purchased
and administered to Children across the
state in conclusion the New Hampshire
vaccine Association is key a key
component of our state's Public Health
infrastructure it increases the access
to vaccines save saves the state money
and most importantly protects the health
and well-being of our children the the
Medical Society strongly opposes House
Bill 524 and urges the committee to vote
itl thank you for your time and
consideration of Our Testimony thank you
appreciate it representative paulov
thank you Madame chair and thank you for
taking my question uh I have a question
about insurance
part uh so I I never heard New Hampshire
insurance company coming out and saying
that uh they opposed to vaccination that
the data showing it's ineffective so if
they think that it's a good thing and
it's helps uh uh wouldn't they be
willing to cover the bill and fully
reimburse vaccination effort even
without vaccine
Association thank you for that question
you you've essentially stumped me I
think I would have to go back and and
and talk with our you know our our
resources and and get an answer to that
um thank you any further
questions seeing
none are there any
other testim people here that would like
to testify because I don't have any pink
cards
left all
right I'm going to go ahead and close
the public hearing for HB
FN and we are going to recess until 100
p.m when our next public hearing
is I was going to ask
[Laughter]
you
hello
e
e e
oh no okay like it's this whole block
no here's another
548 that
is all right
I'd like to call to order the public
hearing for HB
dfn the prime sponsor representative
mlan you ready to present the bill to
us thank you madam
chair
um thank you madam chair and honorable
members of the Health and Human Services
committee for the record my name is Mark
mlan representing Hillsboro district 15
which is Manchester Ward 8 I'm here to
introduce HB
548 which builds upon the direct Primary
Care legislation we passed in 2019 by
extending that Health Care model to
Health Care Facilities it amends RSA 151
colon
2-f um one by allowing those Health Care
Facilities that operate on a membership
based model or exclusively take direct
payment for services to be excluded from
an requirement to accept all modes of
payment
so the legislation is being brought
forward in attempt to drive towards
increased transparency we heard a little
bit about that this morning um in uh HB
uh 743 to drive towards increasing
transparency in health care pricing but
also to introduce uh new service models
to underserved
communities I think that one of the
areas where the Affordable Care Act fell
short was in its promise to bring health
care costs under control it expanded
access but it really didn't do a lot on
the cost Side in New Hampshire healthc
care costs have gone up at 1.8 times the
rate of groceries two times the rate of
transportation and four times the rate
of clothing only housing and energy
costs have gone up at a higher rate and
I think you know we understand a lot of
of what the drivers are behind that a
key element in bringing the promise of
the Affordable Care Act into reality was
supposed to be the introduction of
clearer more understandable pricing
information that would encourage people
to shop around and enhance competition
and they did put the charge Masters out
there but really um this full
transparency never really happened and
as you heard from testimony this morning
um uh Healthcare building remains as
Byzantine as it's always been so I want
to give you a quick history on how I
came to this bill a few years ago I was
in a minor car accident I felt fine my
wife she's paranoid you got to go down
you got to get checked out so I go down
to the Urgent Care and I said hey you
know I was just in a minor fender bender
I'm fine but could I get checked out and
they said sure we can check you out and
I said well how much is it going to cost
and they said well we can't tell you
until after we render service and I said
listen if it's going to be one or two
$0000 that's fine I'll give my wife
peace of mind but if I'm going to get
slammed with a $1,200 bill or something
I'm sorry you know my wife is just going
to have to suffer a little bit and do
without transparency but again they said
there's no way we cannot tell you the
price not even the ballpark um until uh
we render the service and really guys
can you imagine that happening with the
delivery of any other kind of service
it's just it it it just doesn't happen
so I've tried a couple times one of my
first legislative attempts at
introducing transparency was a bill
requiring Health Providers to provide a
reasonable estimate of non-emergency
Services kind of along the lines what we
heard this morning was 743 but I
promptly got a call from the deputy
insurance commissioner on that one he
said hey because New Hampshire is a very
small state such legislation might
actually lead to price increases or even
have insurance companies pull out of the
state all together and it didn't have
some of the nuances that the bill we
heard this morning had but I was left in
the unin position of that one going to
the Commerce Committee and saying uh I'm
going to P pull my own bill um but then
no surprises became federal law and I
said hey maybe this is is is an Avenue
and maybe what we can do is you know New
Hampshire is a small state so we
wouldn't have the Firepower to do that
just here but if we can kind of move in
with no surprises and build on what is
already there federally um maybe we can
do something but as I sadly discovered
no surprises only covers the uninsured
and the self-insured and it's completely
inadequate as a foundation really on
building the tri transparency that the
majority of New Hampshire residents
would want so that's where we come to
this bill this bill it adopts an
alexandrian approach to price trans
transparency by just cutting through
that gordian knot of Healthcare billing
to go to the direct pay model as I said
the direct pay model this is a model
that we've already seen operate
successfully you know when it comes to
the direct Primary Care you know because
in order for such a model to work there
truly has to be no surprises in pricing
because most people get their insurance
from the commercial Market or enrolled
in Medicare or Medicaid uh the use R I
think for facilities using that model is
going to be relatively low it's not like
it's going to be all over the state and
we haven't even seen the direct Primary
Care go all over the state so I think
the uptake is going to be low however
for those folks who are uninsured
self-insured or have high deductibles
the idea of knowing upfront how much
your colonoscopy is going to cost may
have enormous appeal and even a small
amount of competition may start to
generate change so I kind of think this
is the incremental change that the
gentleman from the insurance department
was talking about when he talked about
743 there's not going to be anything
that kind of gets us all the way there
but this by building on this direct
Primary Care model that we already have
it it just starts to open things up a
little bit releasing facilities from the
all payer model will also release them
from the enormous administrative burden
that it genders and we heard
representative Nagel talk about that
doctors become doctors because of the
desire to care for others they're not
accountants they don't want to be
accountants but close to half the
administrative burden operating a
facility is tied to billing if that can
be eliminated there's potentially we may
see the expansion of services in
underserved areas and again we're
already starting to see that on the
direct Primary Care front it won't be
for everyone but it will introduce
competition new approaches and possibly
exposure to innovative ways to deliver
healthare now one of the main objections
to HP 548 and those you guys been around
a little bit know is the fear that it's
going to decimate New Hampshire's
critical access hospitals okay that's
that's a fear I personally think looking
at the update rate on the direct primary
care it's not going to be enough that
this is going to hit like a hammer um I
think it's going to be slow on the
uptake um you know and one thing to note
though is that the benefit of being a
critical access hospital and the
protections of RSA 151 remain unchanged
by this bill okay so the exclusion Zone
remains intact the 100% Medicare
reimbursement remains intact the 247
emergency room requirement for new
facilities remains intact so critical
access hospitals are still going to have
a lot of insulation a lot of armor
against competition but you know but the
question question is this are we
protecting critical access hospitals
merely for the sake of protecting
critical access hospitals the federal
critical access access Hospital act went
into effect in 1997 in attempt to
preserve Health Care access in the
nation's rural communities okay that's
the real goal the real goal is to expand
and preserve access not to preserve the
critical access hospitals for their own
sake but one of the ways that I think
the critical access law actually impedes
the expansion of access is that it caps
the amount of hospital beds at 25 so I
asked legislative research about Trends
in the bed count in the state's
hospitals and quickly discovered that
the trend obviously is flat even though
the population of New Hampshire has
continued to increase we've gone up
450,000 in the last 4 years since the
last hospital was built in in New
Hampshire yet Alice peek 25 beds
andersin Valley Hospital 25 beds Cottage
Hospital 25 beds Franklin Hospital 25
beds all these hospitals 25 beds they
will never have a 26th bed they will
never have a 27th bed because if these
hospitals even if they could if they
staff beyond the 25 bed count you know
what's going to happen they're going to
lose their critical access Hospital
status so I think in that way it's
actually an impediment to to growth so I
think recognizing this um I think if new
methodologies emerge that can offer an
alternative way to expand access I think
that they should be explored I don't
think this is going to happen overnight
but I don't think we should be Tethered
to a single path to providing Health
Care um you know medical access is
increasingly a threat we hear it on the
news all the time they're closing down
this they're closing down that we hear
that in this committee all the time I
think we should be considering an all of
the above approach and I think just like
the gentleman from the insurance
department said this morning this is
kind of that incremental path or at
least a part of it so um with that I'll
take any questions I do have some uh
subject experts that I'm bringing in
behind me uh so I'd ask you to save some
of your Firepower for them but I'll do
the best I can to ask any questions you
may have to the next bill are did you
testify the wrong Bill no I'm going to
testify the next they're all over laugh
Jerry all right thank you representative
mlan representative
Weber thank you and
um I
appreciate although I don't agree with
your issue your your point about the
critical access hospitals uh we do have
here some eloquent testimony that you
probably haven't seen yet from the uh
Roman Catholic dasis of Manchester on
behalf of Catholic Charities and the
nurse in homes that they run and there
how do you respond to their concern
which is that the nursing homes that
they run and I think this also applies
to the County nursing homes and others
as well they depend for their funding on
a mix of Medicaid um a little bit of
Medicare and some private pay and if you
allow now facilities completely
unregulated because it removes the
regulation for private pay um Cash basis
payment
facilities uh how do you respond to
their concerns that the top payment
Source the ones who pay the most to
their facilities uh will be skimmed off
and that leaves their facilities to in
in more financial Peril with respect to
the nursing
homes so um I I think that most people
um they they they have a variety of
sources Medicare Medicare I know the
Hillsboro County nursing home um is
reasonably solvent because it's it's got
a higher percentage of of Medicare um
but I I I do believe that for
most people um you're just not going to
have enough people that are going to opt
for that that you're going to be able to
make a heavy business case early on so I
don't think um you're going to see
nursing homes going up on across the
field that are all private pay I just
don't think that there's enough of a
population to support that I did ask
legislative research because I'm trying
to understand the penetration um and
it's very hard to get Beno pelier worked
on it for like two and a half months and
he sent me the final email last night
and he said I'm sorry but it's it's a
dry desert of data out there but you
know based on what I do know um I I just
don't think that there's enough of of a
business case but I don't unfortunately
represented we I don't have any hard
data to support that what I would say
and I didn't because I didn't want to
get I didn't have time to get into all
my testimony but one of the things that
the bill does do is it does you know ask
HHS to do a study looking at the
penetration of of the direct pay models
and the impact that it would have uh
this is kind of my third time coming
back to the well and and and I I wish I
had more hard data to give you that
answer but my gut is telling me that the
uptake is not going to be heavy follow
up so uh my guts giving me a different
reaction but that's not the purpose for
right now um my followup is with respect
to that
study are you not putting the cart
before the horse would it not be best to
have this bill create the
study and then based on the results of
the
study
decide how much and which areas because
this bill paints with a very very very
broad brush across health care
facilities and as I say I I'm concerned
about all of them but I'm particularly
concerned about the nursing homes
because I see no reason
why a facility isn't going to be built
that is completely unregulated because
it's you know anybody can build one and
all they'll do is take the private pay
so and and and but the real question was
about the study committee I mean and and
I I I understand so um so the the to
have the study committee would be great
um and that's why we put it in uh I
think though that you know based on what
we see with the primary care but let's
let's let's take your concern to its
full extension let's say that somebody
um was to look at a model that says hey
you know I think that um there's a
market here that we could have you know
a high-end nursing home that is going to
be you know just direct pay or or
whatever um and and and that could that
could very well happen the but for your
scenario to be realized there would have
to be enough of that happening that it's
going to be siphoning off all of the
people who um are operating um you know
that are going to be C and I just don't
think I just don't think that there's
going to be enough um demand that you're
going to be seeing 20 nursing homes that
are all going to be on a cash pay basis
um I I just based on what we're seeing
with the direct primary care I I just
don't see that that would happen so um
you know based on that I think um there
are states for example Oklahoma that
that has uh this uh structure
with respect to um allowing for the
Direct Cash pay model and and we don't
we just don't see uh uh
a a plethora of new nursing homes being
built there so it's very limited there's
not a lot of states that have this but
where it has been applied on a limited
basis I'm unaware of everything where
it's just basically you know run away
like a chain reaction
so other questions representative
lontine thank you Mr chair CH thank you
for taking my question I'm sort of
following up on um representative
Weber's questions
because um I see that it's very possible
for private nursing homes to open up no
red
tape um and they're going to take
everyone that has any
money um but eventually for many people
that money will run out um as in the
case of my mother right now after all
the careful
planning um or you know someone as we
heard testimony this morning someone who
is in a nursing home with dementia
that's running you know 11 12,000 a
month for
care so do do you see that there's a
possibility that that if this were to
happen it would create a scenario where
there's high-end nursing homes for
people with money and we're reverting
back to basically the poor house for
people who are out of
money I guess again you know my response
to be the same response that I have to
representative Weber I there's not a lot
of data um if if you look at those few
states where they've gone forward with
this model we haven't seen that um so I
don't I I I don't see that as being a
realistic scenario with a small
population like we have what I do see it
is it's it's an opportunity to um you
know bring in transparency and and
explore other modes of operation and I
think the reality is right
now with the model that we have right
now um we are seeing access go down
especially in the rural regions um the
the bill that I'm going to be talking
about after this um talks about some of
the disparities between the urban and
the rural regions um and we have we have
had the critical access law and we've
had these Provisions we had the
certificate of need and then when the
certificate of need went away we
replaced it in 2016 with what we have
now and nothing nothing we have done has
gone to e expanding facilities I mean or
or or access in fact access has gone
down while our population has gone up by
close to half a million people so I I I
think that if we don't start looking at
alternative Solutions now especially
where we're getting into aging
populations um it it it's going to be
too late so um I mean I I I definitely
support um going forward with the study
I think the study is necessary um but
like I said I I think unbalance I think
the risk is not not too great and I do
have I do have folks coming up after me
that are much better subject uh expert
uh speakers on this matter than I am so
hopefully you can can uh save that
question for them and ask that question
because they may have some data
representative that I do not have
representative Paz off thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so following up on numbers from previous
question let's say uh if
alimer Services cost like let's say
$112,000 but if new facility doesn't
have to spend resources on reimbursement
negotiations uh and uh some other
compliancy uh stuff wouldn't they be
able to share some of those savings and
lower the cost
down well I think I think that they
would definitely and the hope would be
that you know we would have more
offerings and that those people that are
operating on that you know cast basis or
or uh membership basis would be able to
recognize these economies and offer the
services at at at a much reduced rate
than the $112,000 absolutely that would
that would be the Hope um as in terms of
the second part of your question I with
them sharing some revenues back I don't
think that that would kind of defeat the
purpose I don't know if that was what
you were asking for the second part of
your
question okay anyone else representative
Nel thank you Mr chair thank for taking
my question anyways
um I've been in medicine for a long time
um I've seen that the concept I think
that representative Weber was alluding
to is called cherry-picking and it's a
very real phenomenon that actually led
to the creation of Medicare and Medicaid
in the first place
um I do think that there's the potential
for this to happen um you know with that
said very early in my career um the
American Bar Association American
Medical Association both said that we as
providers have a responsibility to take
care of 10% of the population at least
10% of our time should be spent taking
care of the poor so what I'm wondering
is if in a bill like this to minimize
the cherry-picking effect you can
include language that they would be
expected to devote a certain percentage
of their resource is to taking care of
the poor either through Medicaid like
the County homes do or
otherwise so you're saying facilities
that would exist under this rubric would
be uh I think I mean if there was a
certain component of of that that was
potentially charitable uh but I think if
you were to go and say no we expect you
to take 10% of your population you know
from Medicaid or whatever what that
would do would be basically put you back
into the same thing representative Neo
that you were talking about this morning
where you I I I still have to build up
the infrastructure and and all those
things so I think you know if you were
looking at you know we the expectation
is that we have some kind of charitable
component maybe um you know and we could
have some discussions about that but if
it was oh you're going to have 10% has
to be Medicare or Medicaid now it kind
of defeats the whole point of it because
now you're you're going to have to come
and rebuild in that infrastructure so um
I I think at least that's where I'm on
but but I'm open to
discussion other discussion other
questions seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry
kerk Thank you Mr chair and for the
record yes my name is Jerry kerk retired
orthopedic surgeon and legislator and
I'm here uh again I was a little
confused earlier because there was a lot
of comment about critical access
hospitals which this bill does not have
to do with but that's the next one um
but I'm here to testify against just
section four of HB 548 because that
section would exempt nursing homes
skilled nursing facilities Intermediate
Care Facilities rehab hospitals and
Facilities which operate on the
membership model or exclusiv they
provide services on a basis of direct
payment from the patient without any
thirdparty
reimbursement from the requirement for
licensed Healthcare facilities to
provide services to all persons
regardless of the source of
payment okay you all sit on County
delegations and you should be familiar
with the finances of your County nursing
home that's where most people actually
finally you know understand how this
stuff works Medicaid covers about 60% of
nursing home residents but the
reimbursement rate of Medicaid is
significantly lower than the actual cost
of nursing home care so nursing homes
rely on the revenue from self-pay
patients and patients with insurance to
make up that
shortfall so what's the problem with
allowing some facilities to only accept
cash or members well first of all
healthc care simply does not function as
a free
market it's a basic human need healthc
care is not a luxury consumer good where
if the cost is too high you can just not
buy
it you we use most of us can afford to
pay the cost ourselves so if you're 80
years old and you just sustained a major
injury or illness or had major surgery
and cannot function independent home and
need Rehabilitation or a nursing
facility you can't just say well no that
product's too expensive I don't want to
buy it that's not a choice you're stuck
you're going to need to go and somebody
else is going to have to pick up the
bill and that's what we see in the
County nursing home with uninsured
Medicaid so on and so forth now again
the proponents of this approach often
state that just allows the free market
to
function however the free market also
Demands a Level Playing Field and I that
quite interesting that when
representative mlan was asked about well
what about having a 10% of the people
would have to be charity care and he
said well that put us back in the same
place yes it would level the playing
field which is not what he wants because
HB 548 would allow that small number of
for-profit Institutions to cherry-pick
the healthy uncomplicated ated patients
who can pay full cash price that shifts
the care of the sicker more expensive
patients and those with Medicaid the
uninsured or insurances that pay less to
the other
facilities they're still subject to RSA
1212 F and that leads to adverse fiscal
impact on those facilities and possible
closure of those facilities this bill
creates an unlevel playing field that
sets regular facilities at a
disadvantage compared to these private
ones so in summary for profit facilities
cherry-picking the well-paying
uncomplicated patients would have
significant economic impact on our
regular facilities the loss is sustained
by those facilities would just be
shifted to those who have insurance or
in the case of the nursing home the
County nursing home to the taxpayers
driving up costs for everyone else and
not changing total health care costs the
bottom line is I believe that the goal
for the Health Care System should be to
provide Health Care
not to provide profits from caring for
the wealthy while letting those who are
less fortunate suffer and die please itl
this bill and I'd be glad to take any
questions representative
wber thank you and good to see you
again my
pleasure so you stated that you opposed
section four because of the County
Nursing Home issue does that mean that
you also
oppose um section one which is also
about residential care and health
facility licensing well I mean it
exempts from the moratory and actually
it's not just the County nursing homes
too it's like any any U regular nursing
home would be potentially bothered and
yes I would I would also agree but um
but I just wanted to focus on that cost
shifting uh issue but I think that it is
a problem to say oh sure if you want to
make this one that can just cater to
well-off patients you can build it but
for the rest of you you can't so yes I
would oppose one but I because of time I
was trying to keep myself focused and
I'll just follow I'll just ask one more
question which is um do do you have a
concern that if people are able to pay
the costs of a nursing home which are
steep they also might prefer not to be
housed in a nursing home where there are
Alzheimer's patients who might be
difficult and bariatric patients who
might take up nurses time and
uh otherwise difficult and unmanageable
or more difficult to manage
patients yes um in a sense okay here's
an example it's the country club or the
public golf course you know do you want
to be with the Riff ra or do you want to
just be with with people of your own
socioeconomic status it'd be nice to be
the other way around and if we had a
billing you know remember many other
countries in the world solve this
problem by not having insurance they
just you know Elder Care is simply
something that they do in the Nordic
countries being one of the best examples
of that and they don't have to fight
with all this stuff um I think the other
thing that was brought up was that
question of what happens when they run
out so is that person just going to get
booted out on the street oh time to send
them to the County nursing home now
because they haven't got any money we've
sucked it all out so now it's time to
send them away that's the feeling I get
from this bill I know that's not the
intention uh representative mlan is a
good guy
I don't think this is his intention at
all but this is still what I think will
be the
outcome representative Nan thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question this
is kind of like
a it's not a nebulous question but it's
pertinent I mean it it it brings to the
mind question of how we in our society
view Health Care in general um is it a
public good is it a pseudo public good
is a private good I meant to ask this
question of Representative mlan but I
just curious words where you put it
because that has dramatic ramifications
for public policy and how we create
things is how we visualize that answer
well I think my final comment kind of
gave my sense about that I believe that
it is a public good it is actually a
fundamental human right to be able to
access health care and I do not think
again that the that it functions as a
free market we heard earlier today about
the difficulty of finding prices and no
matter what we do about it as long as we
have a system of insurances it's going
to be opaque nebulous and difficult and
I think that um it just simply doesn't
function the comment I keep making all
the time is you I remember when the
iPhone first came out I thought it was
really cool I actually know the Apple
watch really cool but it cost too much
money I didn't want it I could make that
decision but if you're lying on a
stretcher and you've got a cute
appendicitis or a ruptured appendix
you're not going to be able to start
looking around for a better deal for
who's going to do rap indomy and you
can't say I think I'll just skip it
because it's just too expensive health
healthare doesn't function like a
consumer good it's not a commodity it is
a fundamental human
right other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Greg
Moore from Americans for
Prosperity thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee always great to be back
in my old stomping grounds I know
representative McKay is the only one
left in the committee but but I do
always appreciate coming here uh for the
record my name is Greg Mo Regional
director for Americans for Prosperity
here today to testify in support of
House Bill 548 House Bill 548 gets at
the fundamental problem of the third
party payer uh third party Payment
Systems drive up the cost of care and uh
block the relationship between between
provider and patient and this bill is
trying to is trying to do one small
piece to to get it as the sponsor said
there's not a huge Market the vast
majority of granted Staters either have
employer sponsor insurance or have
government insurance and so it's a very
small pool but it is growing I'll try to
get to that uh I'll just say this bill's
passed passed the house a couple times
in the last few years so I don't want to
uh bring rehash too much of what I've
said in the past on this legislation but
the third party payment system based
upon some studies has shown to increase
the cost of Care by about 35% removing
that thirdparty payment problem
that you we have the opportunity to
provide uh lower cost lower cost
alternatives for individuals across New
Hampshire uh I will say that there was
there was a a group trade group of of uh
independent Physicians they recommended
just to understand the scope of this
that for every independent physician you
should have two billing Specialists so
you can imagine the cost that that adds
on top of of care uh I'd like to say
there's a little more urgency this year
uh as many of you may know back in 2010
with the affordable Care Act they
created marketplaces or exchanges and
those exchanges offered uh subsidies
called uh Advanced premium tax credits
for people up to 400% well in the early
2001 uh 2021 uh the American uh was
American Rescue plan lifted lifted that
cap so there's no cap you could get
these Advanced premium tax credits uh
that was extended two years it was
extended another two years and the
inflation reduction act but it goes away
at the end of this year and according to
CBO a study that the CBO did for Senator
Shaheen it's going to lead to 3.8
million more people who will not have
health insurance now these will be
people whose heal whose incomes are
above 400% of the federal property Li
limit which is 62,6 for an individual
and 128,648
and just smash it into New Hampshire our
share would be about 12 or 13,000 people
so we're potentially looking at having a
significant number of people who don't
have traditional health insurance we're
going to be looking for lower lower cost
Alternatives and House Bill 548 would
help get us there so uh in the interest
of time I'll stop there and and just uh
say I'd be happy to take any questions
you got 20 seconds to spare very good
any questions representative Woods um
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm not being a
economist or a actuary or anything like
that that helped me understand how
creating with this bill
basically where you mentioned third
party payers basically creating a
fourth-party
payer in essence I'm not sure I
understand well where because You' be
paying directly to I understand but
there there you know there's but that's
another mode of
payment okay well I mean I I I I I
definitely understand what you're saying
to the question sorry is that's really
basically putting it in a market based
which uh and I I guess I have trouble
understanding as has been outlined by Dr
kerk uh that it it really doesn't fit
our overall concept other other than a
business model and um we're we're trying
to get away from a business model it
seemed like this is getting us farther
into that perspective but help me out if
I'm really looking at this incorrectly
sure uh this actually creates a more
traditional relationship as you would go
to any any uh any vendor so when you go
to the store to buy to buy groceries you
pay them at once you buy the groceries
it's uh it would be a very similar
relationship you just pay pay for the
services once it's provided so it's a it
removes the third party pay payment
system and uh I I might add a couple
other issues that I'd like to to raise I
know that that was brought up in an
earlier testimony the issue of nursing
homes well we have a nursing home
moratorium right now we we I started
working at HHS in 2003 and we have we
haven't built the new incremental
nursing home bed since then because of
the moratorium so that's already in
place the second one I'd like to address
uh representative Nagel's question um if
you look at page two of the bill and
lines uh four and five you'll note that
in
Statute in the statute in the existing
statute um there you do have to have a
plan for for uninsured
patients so lines four and page two
lines four and five so that part is not
is not does not
change other questions representative
lamante uh thank you Mr chair well maybe
I'm reading it this wrong but it seems
to me that on line 12 it's saying that
um in the case of the nursing
home A and B would not apply they would
be exempt from having to cover the
uninsured
yeah I yeah no I I I think that that's
probably a I think you could probably
just keep keep be in if if this
committee's
desire and just follow up yes thank you
um but with regard to efficiency you're
saying that this bill would really by
getting rid of the third party would
really open up efficiency um I agree
that if we didn't have quite so many
private insurers things would be a lot
more efficient like Medicare for example
their overhead is only about 3% compared
to private insurance which you know is
anywhere to 12 to
20% so do you consider that maybe having
a Single Payer program like opening up
Medicare that would include long-term
insurance would be a tremendous um
efficiency savings for nursing homes
because then you wouldn't need Medicaid
at all well at the potential trade-off
of for example rationing of care and
things we've seen in other nations that
do that um it's particularly disturbing
I've seen some of the things coming out
of Canada where they're at trying to
euthanize people on a regular basis I
think that's a troubling troubling
concern no no it's a thing um and uh I
think there's a reason why uh people
come to America for our care people
people travel from across the globe to
America for our care and part of the
reason why we have that uniquely is
because we because of the payment system
that we do offer uh allows centers of
excellence to flourish whereas whereas
in these other countries you see it's
the the care is spread out over the
entirety of the
country representative Nagel I I just I
guess I want to just oh thanks Mr
chairman thanks a little having spent
over a hundred last year on creating a
prior authorization bill I guess my
question is do we not already have
rationing of care in this
country not not necessarily at the
provider
level um from a payment level we
do there's nothing stopping you from
getting that care there's nothing
stopping you from getting that DM
there's nothing stopping you from
getting that drug it's the third party
payment system that's cre in that
barrier in between the
two other
questions saying n thanks thank
you also signed up to speak is Ben
Bradley from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association thanks Mr chairman and
members of of the committee my name is
Ben Bradley I represent all acute care
hospitals in New Hampshire and all
specialty hospitals through the New
Hampshire Hospital Association we are
opposed to HB
548 uh we have concerns that this bill
could impede access to Services of a
health care facility is not required to
have a charity care policy this bill
bifurcates the Health Care System into
two classes of patients and sets up a
regulatory framework that treats
facilities differently based on whether
a patient direct pays it also appears
that facilities licensed with a
membership based business model would
not have to follow center for Medicare
and Medicaid services conditions of
participation which include important
patient safety and quality
requirements the way we read the bill a
healthc care facility licensed as a
membership based business model could
discriminate against individuals because
of the individual's inability to pay a
membership fee we do not believe this is
in the best interest of the patient
seeking care in these facilities do
not to not be assured that the facility
will treat them regardless of their
ability to pay Additionally the bill
sets up two separate Patient Bill of
Rights the existing Patient Bill of
Rights and the one established under
this
bill this creates uh confusion for
patients seeking Care at facilities that
offer the same or similar Services
specifically I'll give you my testimony
but I want to point out a couple of
items Roman 5 on page three line 14 does
not include no patient shall be
involuntarily discharged from a facility
because the patient becomes eligible for
Medicaid as a source of payment this
speaks to the exact scenario that the
representative pointed out earlier and
it's intentionally left
out Additionally the patient Bill of
Rights established under this bill does
not include
under Roman uh does not include the
under the existing Patient Bill of
Rights Roman 20 where it states the
patient shall not be denied admission to
a facility based on Medicaid as a source
of payment when there is an available
space in the
facility two other examples Roman 22 of
the existing Patient Bill of
Rights indicates that the patient shall
not be denied admission care or Services
based solely on the patients vaccination
status and finally on Roman 23 relative
to a patient's right to have a visitor
which was
recently enacted as
well we don't believe that this bill is
an appropriate model for licensed
facilities in New Hampshire and we ask
that you find it in expedient to
legislate thank you for the opportunity
to provide comments and happy to take
questions thank you representative Nagel
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question you brought up a lot of really
neat points because I did go over all
the Bill of Rights and had a lot of
concerns about the differences between
the two but between your testimony and
the last testimony it sounds like
there's contradictions in this bill that
need to be reconciled in terms of of um
whether someone with or without those uh
forms of payment can be involved or not
or how they got rid of am I wrong or is
that accurate did you read it um uh
respectfully I would stick to my final
statement which is to request the bill
be an expedient to legislate
other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Nick bis
from the Bedford ambulatory Surgical
Center my name is micone
for the record my name is Nick veis I'm
the CEO and founder of the Bedford
ambulatory Surgical Center uh started 32
years ago and uh when we opened up the
sky was going to fall hospitals would go
out of business and um all hell would
break break out so uh and I'm proud to
tell you that um that didn't happen and
there was greater access and
affordability to health
care I'm not here either to support or
kabash the uh the proposed Bill I'm here
to just bring out some highlights that
you should all be thinking about I've
been providing healthc care for 40 years
uh I've been in private practice I
develop surgical centers imaging centers
labs and uh I own physician practices
one recently in a North Country in
colbrook and so I've worn many hats had
my own insurance company your former
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services so I've paid bills as a uh uh
as a state employee Healthcare bills
that is um I've been a patient and a
provider so with all that being said
remember this as you develop policy
leading cause of personal bankruptcy is
Health
Care think about that you get sick and
injured and all of a sudden we kick you
and this country we kick you while
you're down um by bankrupting you that's
awful we can do better than
that New Hampshire offers a lot of
Alternatives that are far lower in price
point in our neighboring states because
we got rid of the co law most of it
remember that don't discard free market
forces or an informed patient or
consumer
but what's being presented and talked
about as a broad brush
here are you talking about nursing home
care then you're talking about lab
services I also started the one of the
leading Healthcare cost transparency
companies in America today Compass smart
Shopper I think there are 93 million
users today on
it people need to know what things
cost if they're going to use those
resources we should be creating some
natural checks and balances so that
there is some competition amongst
providers but there are times in your
life where you you don't have any
choice I know we could do a lot better
with a
blend of what you're all talking
about I mean Physician Offices Lab
Services you know you can pay as little
as $15
in a physician's office or
$500 for the same
lab I can offer state-of-the-art MRI CAT
scan services for $400 to $5500 versus
$5,000 in the same
Marketplace I can replace your hip and
your knee for less than
$30,000 all in
prosthetic physician fee anesthesia or
pay
$70,000 in the same
Marketplace half of the employers today
are self-insured they're paying the
claim dollar for
dollar price matters to
them please consider those factors but I
would also agree that someone at the end
end stage of their life that they
shouldn't be on a street we can do
better and for those of you who are
looking at a single-payer system just
because you now have coverage doesn't
mean you're going to get the
care remember
that thank
you any questions so representative
Nagel and then representative kof thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question I could have paid you to say
what you said about catastrophic health
problems because I've been doing it for
the last 35 years and it is devastating
yeah but that's not my question can you
do me I do me a favor and describe to me
what Bedford ambulatory Surgical Center
is and how it was created because it's
my impression it's more of a Cooperative
Venture than it's kind of its own out in
the oh no field type thing am I wrong no
it it it was started by a small group of
orthopedic surgeons and myself and and
there were no and and you know uh I
didn't know I didn't know anything about
ulatory surgery and but it was um The
Physicians needed to be more efficient
with their time they were losing near
block time and they didn't have any
control of their schedule and some
orthopedist surgeons in out in
California were doing our patient
surgery and so they came to me because I
they thought I had an understanding of
medical business so anyways we went off
and did it on our own we struggled for
the first couple years and we started
out with six surgeons and now we have 35
surgeon Partners but we partnered with a
hospital we partnered with
CMC but we were a position of strength
to partner with and every physician I've
been work with cares you all care and
you know you you shouldn't have the
mentality that you want it all you have
to do it all and so with that we came up
with a
great facility and 32 years later it's
still around strong and uh it's offering
the best price Poss surgical price
possible in our community representative
Kwal thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions so um you know I
understanding that uh there are a number
of success stories from other states
like the surgical center of
Oklahoma and understanding that the
current law which requires multiple um
basically requires you to AC accept all
forms of payment dates back to
2016 so you you were in this market well
before then um did you did you see a
problem before 2016 with um complaints
about you know sort of drawing away the
I guess the profitable customers or the
the best uh the patients who could
afford to pay more was there was there a
problem before 2016 yes there's always
been a problem obviously you know um
there's always going to be a pro it's a
complex issue and and it's an economic
issue you may not know there are three
different payments of
reimbursement that exists for health
care providers
three Medicare puts out three there's a
hospital rate three for the same service
but mind you okay there's a hospital
rate there's a hospital patient
Department rate and then is an
independent of patient entity
rate the hospital rate for the same
service compared to the independent rate
often times is
5X 5X
okay and often times if someone doesn't
have any responsibility because they're
in their Federal program they're going
to go to the hospital for they go to the
hospital for an
earache
okay that that system needs to change so
it it complicates the problems every
physician I have ever worked with and I
today have about 90 surgeon
Partners they all care they they don't
they take care of everybody
okay and we do our best as well as a
facility no one is scamming the system
or cherry-picking such on a regular
basis all right so um that is not the
issue they said that about ambulatory
surgical centers in New Hampshire okay
uh 30 years ago I also forgot to tell
you I was chairman of the co board for
eight years okay and I saw the
shenanigans that were being played then
to keep competition out that's all it
was it protected franchises I would see
CEOs of hospitals lie through their
teeth under oath
okay free market does have a think about
it is what makes America great okay we
need a bit more of it in healthcare but
at the same time we do need to take care
of those who can least afford the care
or and to protect them and there's a way
to do it
all right and we need some checks and
balances in place but with all that
being said it is complicated
unequivocally all right
unequivocally representative
Weber so would you agree based on what
you just said that it might be a really
good idea to start with a s a study
committee to study the data on this
absolutely before we with a very broad
brush yes suddenly change the entire
scheme yes study committee with the
intent to truly study this and not delay
and postpone it absolutely absolutely
because it is a complicated issue but
there are solutions and transparency is
part of the
solution okay it's insane that there
isn't any or very little of it it really
is and the people that are in government
programs end up costing the government
more because they end up into the
because they have no skin in the game
and they end up going into the emergency
room for their Primary
Care representative lontine thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
um but with regard to the three payments
for service um and the hospitals paid a
lot more um isn't that to try to
compensate for all of the unpaid
services that a hospital provides that
an Outpatient Surgical Center is not
going to provide great
question many hospitals don't don't pay
taxes they don't pay property taxes they
don't pay income taxes so that's one
subsidy they get paid more like
5x okay and we have the Dish payment in
New
Hampshire the The Meta scam
program okay where for uncompensated
care checks are written out to Hospital
Systems not to private practicing
providers who give who and I'm one of
them we treat a lot of Medicaid patients
and we get no subsidy at all and we get
paid far less and to my knowledge and
actually we're meeting with HHS soon we
haven't been given an increase in
reimbursement in
decades okay this is private
practice so we need to help priv private
practitioners Thrive not just be able to
get by the other there was a statistic
by the
way um that I don't that's very
important the overhead of doing
third-party billing by the way is about
30% now for a private practice 30% of
your overhead is
pre-authorizations and getting chasing
your money it's
ridiculous other question representative
Nel thank you Mr chair and thanks again
for taking my question and thanks again
for saying what I've been saying that
was an awesome comment you just said but
anyways with that said this is just for
clarification because I I I don't know
that we should be holding Bedford
ambulatory Surgical Center outl the
model that what's being proposed here
but it's a good model but I'm just
curious um does CMC have any ownership
interest in Basque or is it yes 42%
we're trying to get out it because it's
no longer no we're no longer partners
with CMC okay so it's now owned by HCA
and um we just want to be independent
for now let the dust settle and
but I do believe we need a strategic
partner long term um and I'm also the
CEO of the orchard Surgical Center in
Salem I'm the CEO of the National
invatory Surgical Center in NASA and um
and so they're all uh they offer a far
better physician experience as well as a
patient experience and a far lower price
point can I ask a followup followup what
is
strateg okay representative w inquiry of
the chair sure
uh I just we see we seem to have had a
very far ranging and an interesting
discussion about health care policy
generally but time is creeping on and
I'm hoping that perhaps the chair might
direct all of us because I'm one of the
worst offenders to turn our attention
strictly speaking to this bill because
we're already over time for the next
bill
okay representative
Nagel okay all right representative
delus you haven't asked a question
yet thank you Mr chair and I'll try to
be brief with this
ly um so and referring to this bill
would do you believe that this would
encourage more centers as you have or
would this would do you think this would
increase more avail I'm not so sure I
think centers like I like I'm involved
in and as well as I'm not the only
entrepreneur there there are many um
they would go to where there's a
possible need in that Marketplace okay
um and it's a laot of
Economics um again the this is more
elective care not urgent not emergency
care or nursing home care uh but there
are there are elective services um you
know it could be an urgent care center
uh for an example uh or walk-in Center
um that may want to go into a
Marketplace that um that may be far more
affordable for the patients uh in that
community so um it's it's that could
possibly happen I I know there was an
incident in Littleton uh and it actually
ended up going before the co and got
worked out but an urgent care center
ended up going to Littleton uh from what
I understand Littleton Hospital is still
there and so is the Urgent Care Center
and um and maybe the hospital ended up
buying the Urgent Care Center I don't
know but when you don't have people that
are in a position of strength no
dialogue takes place no partnership gets
worked out um so um but it can open up
the market
um thank you just one quick followup
quick followup would you believe that I
did use use your facility I had to drive
with my back completely out I have only
paid a fraction of what I had found it
would cost me elsewhere to have an MRI
on my back and I was able to uh deliver
a disc with that information to the
hospital the day that I went and it was
like
that glad to be of service any final
questions okay thank you thank you and
thank all of you for your service
also signed up to speak are
Danielle I can't read it but andorine
shley from Department of Health and
Human
Services good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Dorian
shakley I'm the manager of the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
Department of Health and Human servic
and with me today is my name is Danielle
waro I'm Council for the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
department and a legislative liazon um
the department is not taking a position
on House Bill 548 but we'd like to offer
testimony ma'am one second could you
spell your last name please sure w r b
ASM boy o y
s the department does not know what the
bill means when it states membership
based business model the department
needs clarification on what those terms
mean additionally the department does
not make licensing decisions based on
funding licensing decisions are made to
protect the health safety and well-being
of the residents of New Hampshire the
department would not exempt a facility
from lure based on funding the purpose
of Licensing is to ensure that
facilities provide safe and appropriate
Care thank you for your time and
consideration we're happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you any
questions representative
palazov thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so I think we
heard something about Oklahoma so that
other states already have uh system uh
suggested uh in this bill so how their
departments were able to handle it
could you please clarify your question I
sorry yeah you say the the department
won't be able to accommodate uh uh this
system but we heard that other states
already uh using it um thank you
representative I appreciate the
clarification I don't think we testified
that we would not be able to do this I
think our testimony is is that as
written we would need clarity as and
that we as a state in New Hampshire we
don't license based on funding we
license based on health and safety we
also um we
also I'm sorry I lost my train of
thought it's oh we would not exempt any
type of facility from licensing based on
a type of
funding other questions representative
Weber
so I haven't actually parsed the
language here in light of what you said
which was A New Concept to me but if in
fact what this bill does is say there
are no licensing requirements for these
facilities anymore and therefore you
have no jurisdiction over them does that
mean that these facilities have no
regulation in terms of safety patient
care and that kind of issue thank you
representative Weber I believe so we
would again need more clarification if
the entire purpose of the bill is based
on funding and how a a patient a client
a resident is going to pay for the
services we would not exempt such
facility because it's a funding
mechanism followup but my followup is
that as I read the bill and I have to
say I didn't read it quite as closely as
I ought to have because I've seen it
before uh but my understanding is that
it exempts facilities from licensing
requirements specifically so although
all other similar facilities have
licensing requirements these would not
because the statute says those statutes
don't apply to them and they a specific
exemption is that correct thank you the
way it is written now and is the way
that we understand it as well so if in
fact you were to pass this bill as
written it appears that there would be a
segment of facilities that are providing
similar services to similar New
Hampshire residents that would not be
regulated by our Bureau thank
you representative Lucas and then
representative palazov um in general
hospitals are required to be accredited
and they undergo inspections on a
regular
basis um what happens in this situation
with these
facilities so in the state of New
Hampshire RSA 151 deems all hospitals
licensed and other facilities in the
state of New Hampshire that accept that
are CMS certified are what we call
deemed licensing which means we issue a
license and they are responsible for
following RSA 150 1 and in and the
hospital rules should our CM we are also
I also oversee the CMS certification
state agency so if a hospital has been
determined to violate the law or the
rule then the department would have
interaction
however because federal regulations and
accrediting regulations are generally
more stringent than New Hampshire state
law and Rule that's probably not
something we would see
commonly um in a situation where a
facility did not take um accept Medicare
or Medicaid only private insurance or or
cash um what would be the body that
would uh be responsible for
certification that's a really great
question I believe I I can't think of
any Hospital in the New Hampshire
hospital Association is here um I think
still um they might be better able to
answer that question um I know that in I
I I'm unaware of any Hospital in the
state of New Hampshire currently that is
not CMS certified um there are nursing
homes that are not CMS certified and
those fall under the purview of our
health facilities Administration adult
licensing so the state does have
regulatory Authority Under RSA 151 and
the New Hampshire administrative rules
which I I think would be the same
situation if a hospital were to conduct
business in the state of New Hampshire
and not be accredited or
certified representative
pazo thank you Mr chair so follow up on
previous so department does not license
based on funding but my impression is
this bill ask asks uh to license based
on funding so my question is like uh is
it something uh does it conflict with
other RSA or does it is it based on some
your internal rules that you do not
license based on funding uh like I'm
just trying to understand if there are
some Amendment needed in different uh uh
chapter of the
law oh I'm sorry I thought um
representative McAn had a comment um we
would be absolutely willing to work with
representative McLean and any other of
the sponsors to determine what language
might help the bill um and what and then
we would be better able to comment on
whether we were in support or opposition
based on any amended
language anyone else representative
Woods uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um we're
looking at this as an exception to being
licensed can you think of anything
similar that is similarly not licensed
or is this the only exception that you
would be aware
of so thank you for the question
representative Woods there are a number
of exemptions that already exist in RSA
151 I do you have the rule in front of
you uh the law I'm happy to read those
off to you if you would like but I um
there are um primary care practices like
if you're a doctor that has your own um
your
own oh my God practice sorry um you are
exempt from license
so because your regulatory oversight
comes directly from the office of
professional lure and so that would be
the only thing I can think of off the
top of my head I can I'll be happy to
look at the exemptions and see if
there's anything
else I guess my my question was directed
to facilities I understand the the
individual practitioners they're still U
subject to licensing uh within the state
by virtue of requirement of being
whatever uh but I'm talking about you
know entities like these entities that
we're describing here in this bill so
this so reading out of RSA 151 this
chapter shall not be construed to
require licensing
of Physicians offices and related
facilities offices and related
facilities of other persons licensed in
this state to practice a health care
profession facilities operating as
community health clinics
and any other facilities Exempted by
rules adopted under this chapter might
be the only ones that apply out of the
entire list that could you what's the
RSA again RSA
151 colon
2 Roman
2 thank you you're welcome any final
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is David Ross
from the New Hampshire Association of
[Music]
counties thank you Mr chair um for the
record my name is David Ross and I am
the administrator of Hillsboro County
nursing home and I am testifying on
behalf of the New Hampshire Association
of counties um we want to register our
opposition to this bill um as it
relieves a couple of things um one is
that it relieves the moratorium on
nursing home beds the moratorium on
nursing home beds was implemented to
help um control costs in the state of
New Hampshire and specifically to help
Focus development of Care on
community-based um uh services this bill
um proposes to increase Community Based
Serv institutional Services rather than
Community Based services and that's
contrary to the goals of the moratorium
on nursing home care it's not a
transparency bill as proposed as was
shared at the opening of this hearing
today and I was concerned about duding
the conversation in discussions about
Hospital Services specifically the bill
addresses nursing home care specifically
and the moratorium on beds and that's a
very grave concern for US Representative
Weber um shared at the beginning of
today's hearing that there's concerns
about the impact to payer mix to all
nursing homes and that is definitely our
concern facilities that accept Medicaid
understand that Medicaid does not cover
the true cost of all care and it's
necessary for operations for us to have
a mix of payers providing a a service
provider that is only providing um
services in an unlicensed environment to
private pay individuals will clearly
deflect and divert individuals from
nursing homes that require a mix of
payers um as um representative lontine
pointed out um the concern about what
will happen with folks when they exhaust
their resources is a grave concern for
us as well um we see that this was going
to put greater pressure on County
nursing homes specifically as folks that
are only going to have no more resources
that they'll have to be come to the
facilities of Last Resort which are us
which will Pro provide a greater burden
on County taxpayers for
sure discharges are certainly concerned
and we're concerned about you know the
availability of services but growing
community- based care services is a
substantial component of the system of
care bill that was passed on by prior
legislative act our objective as a state
should be to develop community-based
services and and pour all of our
resources into that this bill also
directs the department to create a study
to determine um feasibility of self-pay
services or membership Based Services
and I would suggest that that actually
deflects the focus of where the
department should be spending its
limited resources on focusing on
long-term services and supports
long-term services and supports should
be really focused on developing
community- Based Services our frail
elderly population is growing at an
exponential rate the moratorium on beds
will help control the growth of costs in
institutional care so we have to really
focus on communitybased services this
bill proposes growth in in
institutionalized Services which is
contrary to any movement that we have to
make as a state to be able to provide
care for our frail elderly population
that is growing I share the Department's
concerns that this bill does lack um
clear definition of the term membership
organizations St wrapping up please
please St wrapping up okay thank you
very much you all that I am thank you
represented
Weber I just wondered if you had any
other concerns that haven't been raised
already that not you would like to share
with us no I do appreciate all the
concerns that have been shared today and
I Echo their
sentiments other
questions not seeing any thank
you okay also signed up to speak is
Brendan Williams from the New Hampshire
Healthcare
Association and Sir you've asked for
five minutes I'd really appreciate three
instead that's fine Mr chairman uh for
the record Brendan Williams I'm the
president CEO of the New Hampshire
Healthcare Association uh we represent
long-term care facilities including
nursing homes capable of serving over
5,000 Granite sters um we've heard a lot
of uh interesting testimony today a lot
of it's focused on Primary Care uh for
some reason but uh this bill uh what we
choose to focus on is the exemption that
it would make for nursing homes uh from
the bedm orium I heard reference to the
state of Oklahoma uh the state of
Oklahoma still has a certificate of need
requirement for nursing homes uh
Governor D santis in Florida when he
Exempted hospitals uh from the
certificate of need law there that was
longstanding did not exempt uh nursing
homes uh nursing homes are are something
different and that's been recognized by
um other states with certificate of need
laws uh because it really isn't a free
market uh given the preponderance of
Medicaid uh as a payment Source uh for
nursing home residents uh any disruption
uh to uh the nursing home Market would
not be uh un Ain to sort of the child's
game of Jenga where you pull loose a log
and the whole thing comes toppling down
uh that really is what would uh happen
here um there's also ambiguity uh with
respect to the bill uh it uh speaks to a
membership based business model but that
doesn't preclude third party payment you
could still get Medicaid payment under
that because it says or exclusively
provide services to those who are making
direct payments so in other words if you
were a member somehow of one of these
nursing homes uh you could be admitted
as a Medicaid resident which would drive
up a County property tax cost and uh
there's also a um sort of as been
mentioned before sort of a a patient
Bill of Rights light uh in this bill I'm
not quite sure why a lot of things were
omitted from the existing Patient Bill
of Rights as it applies to nursing homes
not simply admission or discharge based
on your ability to pay uh but even a
host of visitation rights and other
rights of uh human dignity uh that
residents of nursing homes in the state
of New Hampshire have come to expect uh
I just think that this uh this bill is
not ready for prime time uh we have a
lot of concerns I've shared them in a
letter Bob Dunn uh with the dasis of
Manchester would have been here he had a
death and his family was not able to be
here but his testimony has also been
distributed and Catholic Charities of
New Hampshire is my largest nonprofit
member uh with that Mr chairman uh I
would certainly take any questions and I
thank you for the committee's time thank
you any
questions not seeing any thank you
sir no one else has signed up to testify
does anyone else wish to before I close
the hearing seeing no one else I'm going
to close the public hearing on HB 548 FN
and open the public hearing on HB 223
and recognize the prime sponsor who is
once again representative Mark
mlan you wise representative you stayed
in the back you didn't have to travel
this far
thank you chair McDonald members of the
committee for the record my name is Mark
McLean representing Hillsboro district
15 which is uh Manchester Ward 8 I want
to thank everybody for the vigorous
discussion on hbf 548 and I already have
some notes in for an amendment on that
I'm here to introduce HB
223 uh the rural Health Care
accessibility act which amends RSA 151
colon 4 to allow for Health Care
Facilities that are not hospitals so
ambulatory centers birthing centers Etc
within the 15m radius of critical access
hospitals without giving notification to
the hospital so the purpose of this bill
is to allow for the expansion of Health
Care access over time in the rural
regions of the state by allowing healthc
care facilities you know such as
convenient MD and others to open in the
rural areas when a business case can be
made for the opening uh building outside
the 15 M radius of a critical access
Hospital uh might seem like a easy thing
to do and be you know a low barrier um
but uh 84% of New Hampshire's land mass
is classified as Rural and when you
overlay the exclusion zones of each
critical access Hospital on top of the
other it essentially leaves only the
Southeastern portion of the State open
to unrestricted Health Care development
so the federal government as I mentioned
in the prior testimony uh created the
critical access Hospital designation in
1997 and we adopted our current lure in
2016 the intention was to preserve
Hospital access in rural areas but the
result has been that New Hampshire
hasn't built a new hospital in over 40
years in spite of the fact that the
population has grown by 450,000 people
over that same period of time um I've
had legislative research search trying
to get me T Trend data on axis but as I
mentioned before it's really hard data
to get your hands on nevertheless I did
provide each of you uh with a handout
highlighting just some of the
disparities between rural and non rural
care and the anecdotal data about
declining uh rural access is absolutely
overwhelming we hear it on testimonies
uh in many other bills before this
committee and you can hear it on the
news every day on the ride home from
work so
um the federal critical access law and
our own facility licensure rules I think
that they've done nothing to expand or
even preserve rural access instead what
I believe they've done is they've only
insulated our rural hospitals as they'
fallen through a period of very long
decline while shutting out any outside
attempts at reform or innovation so this
doesn't mean uh the hospitals and other
facilities haven't made attempts at
internal reform I know they have but I
think that when they look to reform just
like any organization that looks to
reform they're going to look to uh
reform within themselves first as
opposed to looking at the system as a
whole and I think that's what we need to
do we have to look at what we need to do
to expand our access and not just look
at the hospitals in isolation so I think
that's why this bill is important I
don't think that there's a business case
for Mass openings of clinics and other
facilities in the rural areas of the
state so I again I don't think you're
going to see a Title Wave of facility
opens if this becomes law however um as
time moves on what kind of other
Innovations might occur by pulling down
the 15 Mile exclusion barrier today we
may be opening ourselves up to New
Opportunities tomorrow so I made sure
when I drafted the bill
that I would not allow for the building
of another hospital within the 15m
radius okay so I'm allowing clinics to
open up birthing centers to open up
within the 15-mile exclusion Zone but
I'm preserving
explicitly um the the the prohibition on
other hospitals and I did this out of
concern that allowing the presence of
another uh Hospital would jeopardize the
critical access status um of our
critical access hospitals and the
favorable reimbursement rates that that
status provides so I think as a result
the bill tries to to chart a middle path
to slowly provide greater access to the
rural parts of the state while still pre
preserving the critical access status of
our hospitals and hopefully discover new
ways to provide service and I hope you
will support it thank you Mr chair thank
you representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm just trying
to work backwards in my mind about where
facilities are in our state and I think
you made a statement about how much of
the state was excluded by the 15 Mile
exclusion was that your point because I
can think of an awful lot of places in
the state that don't that aren't 15
miles away from a critical access
Hospital well if you and put
unfortunately I had Mike represent mlan
but mic thank you very much guys sorry
um so there was a gentleman who had done
a study last year um not for this bill
because this is the first time I've
introduced this bill and what he did in
that study and I wasn't able to get
access to it and he's off at a different
conference so he couldn't testify today
but that showed when you overlaid all
these 15 Mile discs um it pretty much
covered
744 square miles
of real estate which basically just left
the extreme uh Southeastern part of the
the state not in an exclusion Zone with
respect to the the the 15 Mile exclusion
rate so um so that's kind of the the
state that we're in the sou eastern part
of the state is open to development but
the rest of stuff when you over link
everything it's it's kind of blocked
that doesn't mean you can't you know
apply but you have to go through an
onerous process this is just trying to
break that
down other
questions representative Woods uh thank
you Rich chair thanks for taking the
question um um in physics we always look
at how things apply at the infinity and
zero and that gives us some insight in
this particular situation Let's uh Edge
toward Infinity uh we have a hospital
and there's a 15 mile radius uh and we
have uh an ambulatory surgical unit come
in and then next year we have a
laboratory come in and then the next
year we have a birthing center come
in uh and then we next year we have a
convenient medicine come
in um could you surmise what would
happen to the critical care
hospital um
if if that was to happen then that would
put I think enormous pressure yes it
would um but I I I honestly think for
example if you're looking at
Lancaster I I just don't think that
anybody's going to be able to make a
business case that I'm going to be
opening up a convenient MD and an
ambulatory Center um and uh a birthing
center and a dialis center all in that
area if you look at um for example we
have the gentleman here talking about
Basque Imaging I think Basque is the
only other ambulatory Center that really
has has opened up in in the greater
Manchester area there you've got a
massive amount of population um and I I
just and and not only do you have a
massive population but you're not in an
exclusion zone so you could totally
flood it but even in in the most densely
populated area of the state you're not
seeing the scenario that that you rais
out so I think that if you were to you
know pull back that that um that
requirement in in in the extreme
Northern areas of the state I just I
mean if it's not happening in in
Manchester why would it be happening up
in Lancaster or Littleton so I I just
don't think that you can make a business
case for a massive penetration of this I
so I I think the fear I mean there
there's always uncertainty but I I I I'm
I wouldn't be too worried about that in
my
opinion other questions representative
Lucas yes um in a situation where there
is only one Critical Care Hospital in a
large geographic area and there would be
the development of an Ambulatory Surgery
Center and maybe a birthing center if
there are untour events at these centers
an unusual reaction to Anesthesia or
complication that's
unanticipated and the patient needs to
be transferred to the critical care
hospital how does this bill account for
the need for those Services by these
putative ambulatory centers that might
open thank you I mean I I I I think that
could be addressed you know in in the
same way that um the situation at Basque
might be addressed I mean if they if
they have that situation right there the
there are hospitals in the area just
like there would be your you're going to
have obviously by definition of this
bill a critical access hospital within a
15 a 15 mile range because outside of
that obviously you're you're Exempted so
you're going to have a hospital close by
that would address that
need other questions did that answer
your
question followup followup thank you um
well in the absence of the hospital
services being available should these
other facilities begin to take
away patients and
income how then will those facilities
address these emergencies that might
arise thank you I and I
think I I think that um as I said I I
don't see that you're going to have a
large penetration of these Services
because you're not seeing it in the more
densely populated areas of the state so
I think it's going to have a modest
penetration but it is going to I think
slowly expand service I think quite
honestly there are much greater stresses
on critical access hospitals than the
fact that a birthing center might open
next door I I think you know you're
talking about you know our reimbursement
rates and and you know the heavily
Reliance on on on Medicaid up in in the
uh in in the rural areas of the state I
think in my opinion those are pressures
that are going to carry a lot more
weight then I I happen to open you know
a dialysis center next to Alice or
something like that um that that would
be I I would think that would there are
much greater pressures at play on on
those critical access hospitals right
now representative
Weber I'm still working on
the the whole point of this
Bill you're saying that the bill will
bring more services to underserved rural
areas but for example where I live which
is an underserviced rural area in the
western part of the state Kean New
Hampshire isn't within 15 miles of a
critical access hospital and I don't see
anybody
clamoring to open up a lot of these
things there we do have a different
hospital there I'm just not seeing what
the need for this bill is frankly well I
mean in in a way representative Weber I
I think you're kind of making my point
because if you're in an area that is
outside of that exclusion disc and which
is like I said they all overlap and if
you happen to be in an area where there
is no overlap and so there is an
opportunity to put something there uh
the fact of the matter is it hasn't gone
there and and I think the reason if
that's true that it hasn't gone there is
because there's there's just not a
business case to do that and that's why
I'm saying this bill is not going to
happen and all of a sudden you're going
to see this Mass penetration all that
this bill is going to do is it's going
to say that as things change and the
demographics evolve um that there is an
opportunity if a facility can make a
business case hey you know what the
demographics have changed there's a real
need for a dialysis center here um we
think there's an opportunity and so
we're going to go forward with it I I
think what it does is it's preemptive in
that it anticipates opportunity in the
future but the fact like you said I
don't live within an exclusion Zone and
there's still nothing here I think
underscores the point that the evolution
is going to be slow it's not going to be
massive and so it it looks to the Future
follow up
so wouldn't a more sensible approach be
the one that we had outlined for us with
the Bedford Surgical Center where they
partnered with a
hospital because it was mutually
beneficial and shouldn't we be leaving
this in place and
encouraging those kinds of mutually
beneficial partners ships rather than
freestanding competitions where
everybody's building their little
fif I well I think if I and I don't want
to speak um I think Mr veis is going to
be coming up and speaking on this fill
again so he could maybe speak to that
but my understanding from his testimony
was that you know he partnered with CMC
uh right now that is kind of null and
void because of the merger with CMC but
he himself said uh and I don't want to
speak for him but you know that in in
the future he's going to be looking to
kind of reestablish that and I think
that reestablishment in the case that
he's saying is is is one of benefit to
both parties so I think if there's a
natural inertia towards that that's not
going to require any special
legislation um but there may be
situations where you know what um it's
beneficial or it's not beneficial and
there may be certain cases and I don't
want to micromanage where they say maybe
it's better that we kind of go alone um
and this would allow for that um and I
don't know uh with a convenient MD for
example if they necessarily always
partner uh with with the hospital and
there may be a case that say you know we
don't we don't want to do that so I
think what this does is just gives the
flexibility but where it is beneficial
I'm sure they'll seek it out
any final
questions okay thank you representative
mlan also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry kerk
Mark as Mark said round two um so for
the record again my name is Jerry kerk
and um I have a little bit of sort of
inside knowledge in this whole process
because I served on the sb97 study
committee that developed the language
that is oursa 154 sorry 1514 critical
access access hospitals provide
essential access to healthcare and rural
areas for the residents who would
otherwise need to travel very long
distances for their care this is
particularly important for emergency
services and maternity services they run
on razor thin margins they lose money on
services such as their 24-hour per day
full service emergency room and
obstetrical services which serve a lot
of people who are Medicaid and Medicare
or with no insurance those services are
critical to have available and they are
subsidized by the higher paying services
and the higher paying insurances just a
couple quick things to cover stuff CAU
earlier the reason they don't go about
25 beds is if they do they're no longer
a critical access hospital that's how
it's defined second we talked about the
15 m discs overlaying them 744 square
miles the area of New Hampshire is 9,300
square miles there's a lot of room I
live in a place where I'm more than 15
miles from two critical access hospitals
in any case um urgent care facilities
such as convenient MD they provide
evaluation of coughs and colds broken
bones illnesses all kinds of good things
like that but they do not handle major
trauma and they're usually open only
8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. look at their
website as a result they require far
fewer resources for Staffing and
Equipment than a critical access
Hospital which must be ready for a motor
vehicle accident a gunshot wound or a
case of appendicitis at 2: in the
morning with the staff and operating
room to handle it and regarding uh
representative Lucas's comment birthing
centers they don't do cesarian sections
you're in a birthing center everything's
going great suddenly the Kids in
Distress they go to the hospital they
need to have a cesarian section well
guess what the hospital has a lot of
cost keeping 24-hour a day Obstetricians
ready to do
that C-section that doesn't mean
birthing centers aren't good they're
great but they do have an impact um and
we've seen that with a closure of a
number of our maternity centers in
various hospitals in our rural areas U
so the point is that the establishment
of a nearby facility providing only the
relatively simple basic services from 8
to 8 8: a.m. to p.m. but not providing
high-intensity costly 24-hour a day
trauma care or complicated abstr care
will skim off patients with good
reimbursement from the critical access
Hospital that'll change the payer mix of
the critical access hospital and
possibly lead to its closure or
diminished Services outside facilities
cherry-picking the well-paying
uncomplicated patients would have a
significant negative economic effect on
critical access hospitals the losses
sustained by those providers would lead
to Cuts in Services as we've seen with
those closure or maternity centers as I
said this has a long history and I
served on the committee in uh for s sp97
with Senator Bradley the master of
compromise this was in
2019 we had multiple meetings and heard
from all stakeholders including
hospitals and Urgent Care Centers such
as convenient MD compromised wording was
developed with all the stakeholders
involved including convenient MD and
that resulted in RSA 1514a in 2020 and
the gist of this is just simply says you
got to let that hospital know if they
object there's going to be an expert uh
study and if that expert study shows
that there's a critical material in
adverse impact on the healthcare
facility then it would not the new
facility would not be licensed so the
point of the matter is that's really
kind of weird this bill well just I have
two sentences this bill seeks to remove
from this process all of the special
Health Services except if you want to to
a hospital it doesn't make any sense to
Simply discard the com the compromise
established by Senator Bradley the sp97
study committee and the stakeholders
without a good reason thank you thank
you any questions representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question um this issue of the
15 miles and well little why don't they
develop it outside uh sometimes uh
drilling down and you may have seen this
on your committee uh but malpractice
insurance uh Physicians facilities have
to have malpractice uh some kind of
insurance companies I can Envision say a
convenient MD wanting to do 16 miles uh
but their malpractice insurance says you
have to be within 15 miles to get is did
you run across that particular you know
yeah that it's something that's always
in the back of the mind of of
practitioners but yeah that particular
uh issue did not come up I I think um
it's an interesting question but I mean
in general again if you have a um a
complicated birth uh you know hopefully
15 miles you can get there reasonably
quickly but nevertheless it is a bit of
a
concern representative sa thank you for
taking my question um I just I'm not
trying to get too to the weeds with this
but what would be is there a defined
process to what that would go into
determining the need and where that need
is and like would it be have to be
really picky choosy say we have a really
big need for like say a maternity or
this or that in this area but is if it
for whatever reason wasn't cost
effective for you yet there need is
still there how is this would this still
be able to meet the needs that New
Hampshire needs by passing
this um I'm not sure I can answer that
question but the bottom line is this
isn't this particular
um 152 uh 151 D4 I mean um didn't so
much talk about needs it it ask he talks
about as we say protecting critical
access hospitals and they do need to be
protected because they need to be there
for the the other basic high level
services that are needed um so what
happens is I mean for example let's say
uh where I live which is a little over
15 miles from both Memorial Hospital and
Huggins Hospital a birthing center could
be a really good idea but it really
would be great if we're paired with one
of those hospitals so that they could be
working together and there's an easy
communication and so on and so forth um
so that you can if the need is there you
can still build it's just simply that if
you we'd have to notify that hospital
and if they say hey not a problem we
can't keep up with this particular issue
there no problem if they say this is
going to really undermine the our our
mission of providing care for our
community uh but again this is not
something they don't just say it and it
happens it there's an expert review to
look to really see does it have an
impact is that impact material an an
materially adverse impact if it's not
you go ahead but if it really is a bad
problem then you be say no you're not
going to license that person of course
again they might just jump out 16 miles
as representative wood said
representative
palazov thank you uh Mr chair so if our
goal is uh protecting critical access
hospitals right now we are protecting
them through this this restrictions so
can we monetize it can we put a number
uh if they're losing certain amount of
good paying patients can we just
subsidize them to to save them in this
situation and do you have any ballpark
estimation like what kind of uh
subsidies that would need to survive I
don't have all those details right here
but that's indeed what why if you're
defined as a critical access hospital
that does give you some subsidies that's
that's that's part of their whole
program is so that they can actually
exist and that's again why you would not
go to 26 because suddenly you then are
you know back to what any other hospital
is um sure I mean that if we if there's
the appetite here to throw a bunch of
extra money at the hospitals and keep
them afloat wonderful idea but I don't
think there is we did see an enormous
change when expanded medicaid opened up
because a lot of hospitals they were in
the red because they had so much
uncompensated care now they were
actually able to get only maybe 70 cents
on the dollar that's better than zero
cents on the dollar and expanded
Medicare Medicaid sorry helped save a
lot of our critical access hospitals or
any of the hospitals but critical access
are running on margins that are
generally about a percent yeah
representative
Lucas thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question so help me a little
bit I'm trying to find a way to
understand the position
of the ambulatory Center in that they
are wanting to operate at a profit of
course um and they are
generating also a small but significant
number of patients who are going to
require
hospitalization but in taking the profit
potentially from the same hospital that
they're depending on to accept the cases
that don't go well right in the
Ambulatory Surgery Center or the birth
Center how do
we mesh this all together well that's
where you get into what was just said by
represent poos off a couple moments ago
I mean if you if you said okay this is a
problem we'd like to have this thing but
we'll also subsidize the hospital so
they can have staff on on hand to be
able to handle that cesarian section at
two in the morning that's peachy but do
we really think we want to do that is is
there an appetite for a bunch of uh
Appropriations to do that I doubt it so
the issue is if you don't want to just
suck off all of the good paying patients
and leave everything else and all the
well it's actually not just the good
paying patience it's really The
increased overhead of a hospital that
has to be available 24 hours a day for
trauma care for maternity care and you
know you have to have then a bunch of
Obstetricians who can be taking call
that's a big difference than somebody
who's working you know 8:00 a.m. to 8:00
pm I think you know that thank you any
any one final question representative of
Theus
thank you Mr chair so my question is
what do you do with PE with a with a
patient like me that had a very severe
problem with my back I had been told I
needed to get an MRI and I needed it
like toot sweet so
I I called around to different
facilities in my neck of the woods to
see how much it would cost cost and it
was like cost
prohibitive and then I ended up calling
bask and it wasn't cost prohibitive at
all so I jumped in my car and in massive
pain drove to that facility and and got
what I
needed if if his facility had been
closer it would have been nice but I
mean I don't I don't know what how how
do you handle someone who like me who is
not going to to go to a place where
I can't even afford to to do what needs
to be
done well a couple things one is um I'm
not quite sure were you within the
catchment zone of a critical access
hospital and this other uh Imaging
Center was within that same catchment
Zone if we're talking about long ways
away it's irrelevant to what this bill
has to talk about um but the in essence
though it is a very mixed up messed up
system because the insurers and it's
often even considered proprietary
information as to what they will
reimburse for any given study and that's
what makes it such a mess to try to find
out the cost as we already covered in
detail this morning so yeah we ready to
move on I think I think we are um thanks
for telling me go early so I can go to
my next I know you have another hering
to go to next hearing thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Nick veis
from the Bedford ambulatory Surgical
Center
for the record I'm Nick valis I'm the
CEO of the Bedford ambulatory Surgical
Center uh former board chair of the co
board for a number of years and um I I'm
here to testify in support of this bill
to eliminate the Halo if you may
and I I have I had a prim large primary
care practice in
coldbrook and it was amazing how many
times people would just drive 3 hours 2
and 1 half hours to find lower cost
care the the
interesting observation here is that the
people who can probably at least afford
health care are paying the highest costs
in health care in the North
Country think about
that access affordability should be our
aim
and the leading obstacle to access the
care is the price of care leading cause
of me of bankruptcy is medically
related people are in high deductibles
five and $6,000 individual deductible
101,000 family deductible is the norm
people are
self-insured I think it's altruistic to
say you know we need to protect these
rural
critical access hospitals by creating
all this all these policies and Noble
intention but the people you're really
hurting are the people who need elective
care okay so I'll give a great
example Alex Alice pek Hospital in
Lebanon right critical access Hospital
guess what hospital it
protects Dartmouth Hitchcock
very expensive care the people in the
Connecticut River Valley are paying very
high prices in health care because
Dartmouth Hitchcock is protected by the
fact that it oversees Alis pect
Hospital there are many Physicians who
would love to send their patients to
lower cost centers in the Connecticut
River Valley but it's not possible and
the interesting part is the co process
and uh is Alive and Well in ver Vermont
Vermont has one ambulatory Surgical
Center
one it's a hospital dominated Health
Care
System expensive as hell for
employers
so the laws of Economics would govern a
lot of this people aren't going to open
up an ASC I'll give you an anecdotal
funny story years ago the athletic
trainer for the Montreal Canadian
called me and because because of
socialized medicine in Canada they
couldn't get their hockey players in
time in C you know in enough time
because time matters in sports right
seasons are only so long and he said hey
Nick let's open up a surgical center in
coldbrook and you know we met on their
way down to Boston the plate of Bruins
and uh I said this is impossible I said
you can't just make a living on Montreal
Canadians there none of population but
the interesting part about all that is
volume is important it is important to
those critical access hospitals as
well but healthc care is changing you're
seeing more people you're seeing people
more meta out right and catastrophic
problems I don't believe you want to
have surgeries in some of these rural
Health hospitals because the volume
isn't there to support the
Excellence so I believe econ laws of
Economics won't create a
catastrophe okay and the fact of the
matter is these this issue of critical
access Hospital protection is also
protecting some high cost centers so
thank you any
questions uh yes representative
lontine um thank you um and thanks for
taking my question again you mentioned
that the uh practice in holber was
Primary Care yes ma'am um and I don't I
don't know who passed out this I I think
it was representative
mlan um but when I look through that it
mainly is pointing to the lack of
primary care in the in the in rural
areas the lack of of rural Physicians
Pas
um percentage of population without
primary care but this bill does nothing
to be as far as the exemptions that are
removed moving it it doesn't seem like
critical access hospitals um they're
protecting against any other Primary
Care in fact that's the problem so
changing this bill does nothing to
change the situation with primary care
it's only for specialist I would agree
with that wholeheartedly I mean we there
is a shortage of primary care and I
still own Primary Care some CRI Primary
Care practices but this The Spill
doesn't address that issue it's the
issue of costs for an example an
MRI all right if you were in the
coldbrook market you'd literally have to
drive as far south as Manchester Bedford
to get a reasonable price now if you're
in a $5,000 $6,000 deductible and you're
paying $3,500 or $4,000 for an MRI and
you can get it for $600
$700 you'll get in a car and drive
unfortunately many of the patients don't
understand what the prices are but
but just to follow up but just to
clarify this bill won't change anything
as far as Primary Care Act that is
correct representative
sabert um well I also agree like a lot
needs to be done I'm having a hard time
getting past and somebody brought it up
about the liability that's often
attributes to higher costs at healthc
care facilities um in the first place
and we were kind of discussing that
about the iffy side of that in regards
to the distance and then also you know
what we were previously talking about
that it seems to me there would be
issues with liability as well I'm not
sure how you're able to
charge I mean do you have a example of
that if if you say it's so much cheaper
are you being covered by the same type
of liability insurance that can protect
a consumer if there happens to be a case
of malpractice sure uh yeah um yes all
the I I don't believe there I to my
knowledge there facilities operating
without medical malpractice insurance so
I think from a medical malpractice
standpoint liability is not an issue
here it's access to more affordable care
and if you can't afford it you don't
have access period uh they they it you
may have an MRI in at uh upper
Connecticut Valley Hospital that day but
if you can't afford the $5,000 or four
you know it's $3500 what you don't get
an MRI period
any final
questions saying none thank you thank
you and also signed up to speak and
actually the last speaker is a br Ben
Bradley from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association thanks Mr chairman getting a
little long in the tooth here my name is
Ben Bradley I am the the vice president
of state government relations for the
New Hampshire Hospital Association we
represent all 13 critical access
hospitals in New
Hampshire uh the hospital Association is
opposed to HB 223 this issue dates back
to 2019 when a legislative committee as
indicated by representative kerk was
established a study providing certain
healthc care services while ensuring
increased access to Affordable Health
Services in rural areas of the state of
note the committee recognized that
critical access Hospital
tend to have low patient volume paired
with high fixed costs these facilities
also have a payer mix that is heavily
dependent on public payers like Medicare
and Medicaid with a smaller share of
privately insured patients rural
hospitals have fewer admissions
compounded by declining rural
populations in many rural communities
that can make it challenging for
critical access hospitals to remain
financially viable threatening total
closure and access deserts for essential
Services otherwise only available over
an hour and then some away the
bipartisan study committee recommended
legislation negotiated by the interested
parties which is what became law RSA 151
4-a in 2020 this included engagement
with Convenient Care interested parties
at the table we oppose this bill because
it breaks face faith in the negotiated
statute from 2020 which we maintain is
an important and reasonable expectation
for new entrance seeking to provide
services within a 15m radius of a
critical access hospital let me be clear
about the process this is not
certificate of need current statute
requires any person or entity proposing
to establish an ambulatory Surgical
Center emergency medical care center
Hospital Birthing Center dropin or
walk-in Care Center dialysis center or
special health care service within a
15-mile radius of a critical access
hospital to give written notice of the
intent to establish a healthcare
facility with a description of the
facility or Special healthc Care Service
to the Chief Executive Officer of the
hospital by certified mail once a
notification is made the critical access
hospital has a Time limited opportunity
to share with the Department of Health
and Human Services their concerns about
the material adverse impact of the
proposed new facility the department
would then contract with an independent
third party to review and complete a
report on those impacts if the report
finds the new facility would have an
material adverse impact on the critical
ACC access Hospital's Financial
viability the new facility would not be
licensed if the report does not find the
new facility has a material adverse
impact the new facility would be could
be licensed notably the costs for the
report by an independent third party are
shared equally by the new facility and
the critical access Hospital the
department may have further Insight on
how that process has gone so far uh we
continue to believe this is an important
process that ensures critical access
hospitals remain financially viable and
able to m main vital services in their
communities for these reasons we do not
support HB 223 I'd be happy to answer
your
questions any questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so similar what I
was trying uh to ask honorable uh mror
uh about do you have a number of
potential losses for a critical access
Hospital like what percentage of paying
clients they could lose or like in their
General Revenue how much they could lose
if this becomes a low well in fact the
existing statute affords the opportunity
for the Department of Health and Human
Services to contract with an independent
third party to make those determinations
and decide whether or not it has an
adverse impact on the existing critical
axis hospital and so to your question I
don't have that information but I assume
that if there was a proposal that would
be contemplated and disclosed in order
to make the decision on the adverse
impact as intended by the existing
statute other
questions I'm not seeing any oh I'm
sorry I representative TZ uh we've heard
a lot oh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh we've
heard a lot
about the importance of critical access
hospitals and how they're I I like the
way you really uh describe low patient
volume uh lower uh private payer mix
lower uh rates of hospitalizations and
yet having higher costs and having to be
able to be available what kinds of
margins are the hospitals operating at
and is there any other information that
can help flesh out um our understanding
of the urgency of making sure these stay
afloat
um well currently my understanding from
recent analysis is that uh Hospital
hospitals in New Hampshire are running a
negative point4 operating margin uh so
they are affected by a lot of what's
going on now uh in the regulatory
environment and and other uh pressures
on the cost of providing care thank you
any other
questions thank you thanks
okay um no one else has signed up to
testify in HP 223 I'm sensing no one
else wishes to is that correct okay that
being the case I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB
223 that was the last uh Bill we had
scheduled for public hearings today we
do have an executive session coming up
um and I guess the question to the
committee would be do we want to take a
quick break or do we want to proceed
immediately quick bre quick break 10
minutes is that enough five yes five we
gotta get we got to get more okay oh
staff's hle
five
e
e e
to call the executive session to order
uh we have several bills that we're
hoping to discuss this afternoon uh
first one up is HB
54 um representative Nagel do you have a
motion I have a motion on to pass okay
and does anyone wish to second
representative lamon
seconds um I know there was a
subcommittee representative Nagel you
were chairman and representative Woods
was on it representative kofalt yes do
any of you wish to speak about the
efforts of the subcommittee you want to
speak
firstes okay representative Kofa uh yes
thank you so I had initially had some
concerns that um the combination of
Highly regulated plus profit motive
could potentially be a magnet for
um people's who whose whose motives were
not um necessarily aligned with what New
Hampshire has been trying to do with
medical cannabis however in the work
session we were able to drill down to a
much more detailed level and I I came to
the conclusion that there are some very
serious problems some of those problems
um result in patients either going to
neighboring states to uh to to purchase
cannabis or buying buying it off the
street which I think is an increasingly
dangerous proposition so um I I guess I
I feel like my concerns about what might
potentially be are far outweighed by the
very real problems that exist today for
those who are trying to help people uh
with with medical cannabis so um I I am
you know at this point you know having
having been uh on the fence I am at this
point pretty strongly in support of a to
pass on this
bill representative L Nagel do you wish
to speak to the motion of a to pass
or representative Woods you okay yeah um
I just just to add that uh to what
representative kofalt said uh we also
considered are the proper guidelines all
still in place and indeed uh the the
guard rails uh don't change uh at all uh
so I I think u in terms of the the
initial uh purpose was to provide a
product that was for patient benefit um
in view of the fact that it was still a
schedule one uh um
medication uh that is I think been
satisfied both from the standpoint of
providing a better Financial environment
so that they can the New Hampshire can
be competitive with Maine and and
Vermont uh but also uh HHS has been
very having at one point been a on the
board uh very strict uh in their uh
monitoring of these programs I think the
guidelines are are uh and guard rails
are still uh very much uh in place and
Will preserve that aspect U for uh this
particular um endeavor um I did offer
one other concern uh perhaps not totally
appropo of this bill per se but the
viability U of of these entities are
sort of what's in question uh my real
concern is uh the environment of of uh
relooking at all
aspects uh of government U interactions
uh and realizing that it's even even
though still a schedule one it's only by
executive order uh that the doj uh was
directed not to prosecute if in fact
entities were uh supplying Services
under a guidance of State legislation uh
and appropriate guidelines
therein given the reviews that are going
on uh I think there is at least some
risk
because if that were ever to be
rescinded uh that would completely undo
this program uh and all programs across
the
country thank you representative Nagel
do you have any comments sure um this I
really you know appreciate what the
state tried to do in creating this
program there were models in Arizona and
um Colorado in terms of the initial
Recreation or therapeutic cannabis laws
that were really gross ly flawed so they
wanted to avoid the mistakes that were
made in other states they thought they
could do that by forcing it to be
functionally a nonprofit the problem is
that they forced it to be a nonprofit
without any of the benefits that go with
being nonprofit meaning that you know
they couldn't uh declare 5 1c3 status or
anything like that and the problem is it
really adversely affected their ability
to get funding um representative woods
and I had both were on the testical
board at one time and I'm on the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board so we have some privy knowledge to
the finances and all I could think of
was I don't know how these places are
surviving and the problem is is because
they can't raise revenue they have to
get it in other ways at high interest
rates and the cost gets passed on to the
consumer which means that the price is
eternally high and there's no way you're
going to bring it down which means
that's why people have to go elsewhere
we were also told in the subcommittee
session that about 50% of the registered
patients in the state can't afford to
get it here they go out of state and
that's just a a recipe for disaster f um
I work with a guy from the NIH and
they're working really worried about um
fentanyl tainted cannabis down in the DC
area and he asked me very specifically
if we're seeing that here and I said I
have not personally but I'm sure it's
going to happen so we need to do
anything that we can do to prevent that
this will allow us to provide high
quality product hopefully at lower cost
um um and save our patients so that's
why we came to the conclusion we did any
other discussion on this motion
I'm seeing none motion is ought to pass
on HB 54 I'll ask l call the
rooll rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus rep kofalt yes RIP Nagel yes rep
poov
yes clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes yes rep Weber yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods
yes uh rep
Sebert
yes rep TZ
yes rep lontine yes rep hartnet yes rep
Lucas yes and rep McDonald
yes Ann bill it's an FN it's an early
bill right I believe
representative we that would have to go
to finance right Mr well the question is
can it go on the consent calendar if if
uh it used to be the rule used to be um
if there was no appropriation that could
go on the pent
but me says it's over 10,000 so I
probably just thank you representative
McKay but I don't think they'll let us
have that argument right vote is 18 to
zero motion passes okay and again
because it's an early Bill it'll it'll
go on regular
calendar okay next up is House Bill 392
representative mea do you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I'd like
to make a motion to retain HB 392 dfn
representative Drew second uh would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Amer I will keep it very
short and sweet
um it would just feels like we need to
do a lot more uh research and and
digging
into there's just a lot of information
we feel like we still need and some
things that aren't necessarily answered
yet and that we would like uh a bunch
more time to to do that
research um and I personally would like
to do that as
well any other
discussion representative
kall uh thank you I I agree age with
that statement I'm also concerned that
we might um be eliminating some some
positions or work that is quite
important to some people in New
Hampshire um in other words I I'm
concerned that this bill you know if we
if we send it on to the floor and gets a
house vote that we could have some
unintended consequences and I think it
would be it's incumbent upon us as a
committee to do that research and be
well informed uh before we send it on
and representative Nagel thank you Mr
chair I just was watching A Few Good Men
last night um for the 5,000th time and I
was listening to the end and of course
Jack Nicholson's speech is supposed to
be the cresendo and but but it's not
it's what happens after that it's when
uh Lieutenant um Colonel or whatever
Lance Coral Dawson says um he goes you
know our role as Marines is to fight for
those who can't fight for themselves
which is functionally a a a more
American statement of the story of the
Good Samaritan and the greatest
commandment and I was really impressed
with that and as I looked through what
this department does um they do do a lot
of really good things for people and um
I think this bill by itself as it's
written now is potentially has a lot of
unintended harmful consequences and i
would
support what we're talking about about
here but we have to remember the good
that these people do for a lot of other
people that really can't fight for
themselves
absolutely representative Woods thank
you yes I I like to emphasize that I too
feel that uh there some significant risk
of unintended
consequences um unfortunately words do
have meaning but when the words aren't
well defined especially in our culture
today a lot of the words are not well
defined
readings to a lot of emotional
reactions and I in physics you always
look at the outlier to give you an
example and I tell ask my
kids what's what's the worst conceivable
word you could have spoken in 13th
century Germany of course they don't
know I said that word is
zoom of course it has no consequence
today but words do have consequence even
though it was the worst thing you could
say in 13th century
Germany words now might have the
flipflop and so I I really really do
support uh taking a look at this and I I
completely agree I think we could make
this a lot
better thank you anyone else any other
discussion representative Weber I'll
just say my my preference would have
been to kill the bill outright but I
certainly app Claud the desire to know
exactly what we're talking about and
exactly what the consequences are and so
I will certainly support the retention
and do the work I was leaning in that
direction myself actually but
representative Nagel just sorry I wanted
to make one more comment just because
I'm the chair of the State Health
assessment um committee implementation
plan committee it's longer than that but
anyways um when I looked at the original
document that had been created before I
got there the word equity Healthcare
Equity appeared dozens of times in the
document and um you know I sat down at
one of our first meetings and I said
what does the word Equity even mean so I
dug this up from Stanford and they said
most committees that use that word have
no clear definition of what they're
talking about and and I think that we
spent a total of two days trying to
figure out what that word meant to us
and I think we came up with a really
good working uh definition but I think
that word is so unclear it's so visceral
and it's so problematic that maybe we
need to include as part of our
discussion going forward how we want to
use that word um and make it productive
so that people don't get harmed by our
interpretation I mentioned to some of
you earlier
today Governor Mel Thompson arguably I
mean everybody knows who Mel Thompson
was in his reputation the name of his
company was Equity publishing so uh so
that mean that name that word can mean a
lot of things representative kofalt did
you have a hand up ear did someone have
you oh I'm sorry representative Tes
thank you Mr chairman um I would say
that there's no question about a
definition of Health Equity it um we
just haven't had a conversation about it
we heard over two hours of testimony
with only one person in support
including um representative Jess Edwards
we also received almost
3,000 um uh indications of people in
opposition to the bill so I don't really
understand why we think there's much to
study we we heard a lot about how it
could be harmful for many different
kinds of organizations and individuals
providing testimony so um I don't agree
that uh talking about it further as
needed uh representative
mlan just you know to to respond to
representative t as to why I think
retention is important you know I I I
agree with a lot of what you say but
because there is a broader perception
and in some quarters a negative
perception of what Dei is if we don't
retain this it could potentially go to
the floor and pass and um there are some
unintended consequences here that we
don't want to allow that to happen so
this I think you know um I think
representative Woods nailed it and
retention is is the smart
go any other
discussion if there was no no other
discussion I would ask the clerk to call
a roll motion is to retain House Bill
392 rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep Nagel qualified
yes it's not an option rep PA off
yes clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep Weber yes rep McKay yes
rep Woods yes uh rep
seert yes rep tez
no rep lontine yes rep Harnet yes rep
Lucas yes
vote is 17 to1 motion passes not yet oh
sorry bet McDonald uh
yes remember representative Weber when I
used to do that to barara Griffin
representative Griffin and we
districting committee all
the I mean did Karen to rewrite this so
that your name is at the bottom
but okay well I'll have to try harder
vote uh 17 to1 yeah the final vote is 17
to1 motion passes the motion is retained
s the bill is retained 17
to1 okay next up and um we we were
thinking about perhaps dealing with HB
634 today certainly open for discussion
at least as to what we want to do with
it there is an amendment that has been
offered um
okay yeah I need a c
also um I will um I will say that I have
received a number of calls unsolicited
from the parents of artistic children
who think that the this uh Council
should be repealed um altogether it
hasn't met since 2019 and they feel it's
been very unresponsive and ineffective
but representative kofalt you've been
more involved in this
issue thank you Mr chairman so um I too
reached out to uh some of the uh parents
of autistic uh children and adults whom
I know and they uh without exception
said that you know the the the work that
is
described in the statute for the um for
this council is duplicative of work um
that is described in a different section
of statute for the uh quality Council um
I I applaud the sponsors um desire to
put um some some people on the council
with disabilities or family members of
people with
disabilities um or on the on the
Spectrum uh the the quality Council
already has that and um is has been
active the this Council has not met
since 2019 has not delivered an annual
report since
2017 um and if you read the two statutes
two sections of stat well if you read
the statute on the quality Council and
the original version of Bill or the
house bill 6304 as
filed although the wording is different
the mission is very much the same it's
about how can we serve people with
Autism Spectrum disorders more
effectively and so I I simply think that
that it that it's duplicative
um we ought to be furthering the work of
the council that is already doing this
work rather than um sort of re Reviving
a council that has not met in um in five
years and hasn't filed an annual report
in seven representative Weber thank you
Mr chairman and I think um I'm not sure
that I'm where I am on this at this
moment because uh I thought we had some
pretty strong pleas from Representatives
Stringham and Edwards that uh with these
revisions the council would be able to
complete what sounded to me at that
point like a relatively limited um um
Mission and um I'd love a chance to chat
with them and maybe some other people
before we dismiss it out of hand so I
was wondering if we could defer it for a
week and you know at that point uh we
might have a little more information
going forward all right and and in
regards to that then why don't we
continue uh that discussion and defer it
until next uh December uh February 19th
okay uh yes representative Woods um uh
could representative K he said there's
an that would be duplicative of uh could
you provide us what that entity and some
linkage or some some way we can look at
that I will be happy to send a link I
will tell you that the
um the quality council
is RSA
171a
33 and so if you do in the and there is
a a web page for it as well so if you if
you do I mean I I I will send the link
out to the committee um but if you if
you read 171
a33 um
section four um you'll you'll see that
it again it's it's different language
but it's it's very much the same kind of
effort that that we see in the in the
bill as as
introduced any other thoughts on HB
33 he none uh let's move on to HB 724 FN
representative Drew did you have a
motion on that I move to itl HB 724
representative merer I second I wish to
speak to your motion representative
Dr yes uh the
majority of
um I guess Republicans in the committee
at
least we we felt that this bill was
excessively um punishing of landlords uh
especially the option or the the the
procedure that allows that or
essentially forces the inspection of all
of the units in a building when a
particular uh lead issue is found in one
of those units uh this is very expensive
uh also in the testimony it came out
that even if
these uh dangers are abated for this
excessive cost it's not fully under the
landlord's control to stop it from being
reintroduced into the apartment uh
because the the one of the testimony um
one of the testimonies talked about
simply moving some furniture around
could cause that lead Hazard to
reappear uh in the in the uh unit and so
we feel that this is too much and it's
not there there definitely is a problem
we know we have a problem there's a lot
of old housing in New Hampshire but this
is not the way to address
it representative Weber
I understand that this is an issue that
may be of concern to landlords and I've
heard them about it over the years
endlessly uh but the damage to landlords
is economic and the damage to children
can be
lifelong and so I think anything that we
could possibly do
to ensure that we're giving our kids the
best possible start in life is well
worth doing
um I will note that the signin sheets
were
um um 108 in favor seven opposed one
neutral so there's a great deal of
support for this bill outside of here as
well other
discussion representative Woods yes um I
I do have concern I understand the
economic aspect and uh but U just being
very CR about the whole thing we're not
here to protect protect somebody's
pocketbook as representative rber said
we're here to protect the public and
their you know uh health and so forth um
and in this is is the uh meeting the new
standard and that would be uh pushed
back so we wouldn't Meet The New
National Standard of 3.5 it would remain
at five unless we do something else so
uh you know I understand the economics
and I
all that uh but uh I I just don't want
to lose a 3.5 as the new standard I
think that we we really be
remiss any other
discussion representative
lontine uh well being a residential
property provider myself rental property
a landlord um I make a lot of my husband
and I make a lot of effort to keep
apartment in good condition and um if I
were to find a child in our
building um had high l i mean I would
feel it really responsible thing to make
sure that other children in the building
aren't at risk um I I think we should
prioritize the health of the children
over the desire of a landlord to not
remove risks in the building that they
own when it's harming children so I I
don't think it's ask asking too much to
investigate every unit I think it's
entirely appropriate so I won't support
the itl oh sure representative Drew as
as we discovered in the testimony the
risk is not
removed when you perform a lead
abatement it is it can happen again and
again the risk is not removed it may be
reduced but the cost of that reduction
is extremely high and there are other
better ways simpler ways less expensive
ways to protect kids and families from
that
exposure representative uh L
montain oh well I disagree I think that
that was the suggestion that kids are
getting lead poisoning from um
applesauce Lids or things like that
those are extremely rare right the main
cause are are are living in
Old housing where there's peeling lead
paint um so
one you know if a if there's a lead
abatement occurs and then later there's
a little Nick on a stairwell from a
piece of furniture being moved that is
not likely going to cause a new exposure
for children so I disagree with that
argument representative Maser I recall
to that um from
testimony that someone mentioned that
when they were going to purchase a house
they actually knew it was disclosed um
in the report that there was a a
presence of lead and but they proceeded
to purchase the house anyway so that
that then the option then Falls to to
the buyer renter whatever because it
seems like that is is a thing now that
is now reported in there so then the
decision can be made on the people
buying or
renting representative
saber they they just um I just to add to
that they like when we bought our home
they just it's pretty much a a warning
saying your home may contain lead
because it was built before or after a
certain date and so it doesn't really
definitively say if you actually have
lead or not so I think that's important
to point out um another point was um
someone who had come the former
representative who came to testify in
regards to you know um landlords also
have the option if they're buying a
building and they get that same warant
you know if they ask for a lower price
it does have lead you know and bargain
at a lower price which would seem
economically sound and then put that
money into just doing a the abatement um
that's another option as well that was
brought up
so other
discussion see representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh it it happened to me I have
very mixed feelings and I'm worried
about
voting uh with without being uh very
clear in my mind uh it was hugely
expensive it was very traumatic we ended
up in court uh so that I think I'm not
objective and I don't think I should
vote good but you can rule one way or
the
other okay I've never heard of a recusal
in committee but I guess it can
happen no
absolutely I've just never run into it
before I've never run into I haven't
either okay well that makes me feel good
then you've never okay that's fine
representative M being thoughtful okay
any other discussion
I believe so you can
abstain we don't have an abion process
have to vote have to vote unless you
recuse yourself for a particular cause I
mean you you I mean I'll be glad to call
the perk if you want me to yeah why
don't you but I I'm thinking
that um I know I know if there's a
conflict on a house vote that that you
should declare it but on a committee I
didn't know know that so
but and again I have no objection I just
I've just never went into
it um but what why don't we pause just
want he's available if he's available it
won't take long if isn't available then
um that makes it
tricky you're calling a cell um
okay did give everybody a cell that's
true
sounds like she
start they've never talked about
so so
this she said how are you
doing she said
okay so should I withdraw the motion um
if we're going to move on to another
bill yeah we can't have we can't I'll
withdraw the motion so we can move on to
another bill okay and representative mea
do you withdraw you a second yes okay
we'll go back we'll go back to this bill
um you know at the end all right next up
is HB 751 represent mlan I believe you
have an
amendment we doing 751 we're going to
come back to 724 because it's I just
wanted to clarify with the clerk so
uh I'm sorry Mr chair you caught me off
guard that's fine
uh I I'm trying to
find I did have an amendment for
751 which I handed out last week is
and 220 H right I yeah
220 okay um does everybody have a copy
do most people have a copy from last
week uh 751
FM do we need to have get any copies of
the amendment for
anyone well I think I don't have
representative Weber she can have my
copy I can talk to it that's right I was
giving out last week but you weren't
here repr paza you don't have a copy
either
or okay anyone
else all right representative
mlan at the end day I'll go for memory
everybody can keep me on
thank you Mr chair so um so we need a
motion representative mlan on this yes
oh so I uh I moved
uh Amendment Z sorry 2025
d0220 a motion is what ought to pass
ought to pass now second you wish to
speak to your motion yeah so um thank
you Mr chair so this amendment uh takes
we had the subcommittee uh last year
where we uh kind of paired down the bill
um and we uh got rid of the uh the
residential and really uh reduce the
scope but uh what the amendment does is
the the amendment takes things even
further um because what it does is
rather than having the second uh like a
a new certification process which was in
the original bill as introduced after to
the subcommittee this basically takes uh
the
um takes and rolls it into the existing
uh regulatory framework for health care
facilities and so there were real
opportunities with respect to um
efficiencies basically they would just
need to have one person for oversight as
opposed to you know maybe more people if
they're creating a separate
certification and it still does retain
the position of the uh edsman subject to
um available funding so I think overall
it basically it keeps the narrowed scope
but rolls it into an existing regulatory
framework instead of the separate
certification much cleaner and I hope
you'll support
it thank you representative McLean any
further discussion on the
amendment nothing
we will yeah we will wait for the chair
to go
further just
seeing Christ Grant might have terms of
insight on the
recusal
sorry they don't go
up okay so
there's so there's no other discussion
on the amendment okay no since there's
no other discussion we'll I'll ask the
cl to call the rooll motion is ought to
pass on Amendment two uh
0220 rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep kofalt yes rep Nagel yes
rep poov yes clerk votes yes rep marel
yes rep McGrath yes rep Weber yes rep
McKay yes rep Woods
yes rep uh
Sebert
yes rep TZ yes rep lontine
yes rep hartnet yes rep Lucas yes rep
McDonald yes vot is 18 to zero motion
passes okay representative mlan do you
now have another motion
yes Mr chair I'd like to move a to pass
as
amended okay and I'll second do you wish
to speak to your motion yeah thank you
Mr chair um I think that the testimony
that we had last week um was very
compelling and and really highlighted
the fact that there is genuine need for
this bill and that just reinforces
testimony that we had last year um and
especially compelling for me was hearing
the woman in Corrections you know who
realized to her horror that she had sent
maybe you know people forever you know
in to be taken advantaged of and and and
she said that sent her off on an 11-year
mission to kind of put some barriers up
around substance abuse treatment in this
state and and and her comment uh we have
never been this close and and and that
really moved me and I think renewed my
sense of purpose with respect to this
bill um last year we said no because it
wasn't ready but we did put the work in
and so I think that's the difference
this year um I know that there are some
people that you know are a little bit
skeptical about bringing in new
regulations I understand that I just got
beat up by the committee for two hours
about trying to you know go after and
and ease back on some regulations but I
don't I don't think that all regulation
is bad there there is a place you know
for regulation if if you if you do
without any regulation any law you end
up with something like the Sudan or
Haiti and that just that just kind of
breeds tyranny and I think there is a
real tyranny um in in in the substance
abuse Arena where where people are going
in and the Tyranny is is a tyranny of
the the Predator uh the abuser and and
and even falling into relapse so um I I
don't see this bill and and the
regulation it brings as being tyrannical
I see it as a Defender and I see it as
actually providing freedom for some of
these people that want to be able to
navigate the treatment landscape without
fear of being taken advantaged of uh so
I do hope that you'll support the bill
other discussion representative hartnet
yeah I'm a big endorser of this bill and
uh just thinking about alcohol and drug
treatment uh regulations we're uh
stunningly
unregulated in this area we have I
believe a ton of work to do in this area
if we want to realize an alcohol and
drug treatment infrastructure that's
integrated into criminal justice child
welfare and the broader Health Care
system so I think this is certainly a
you know a piece of that so I'm a big
endorser of this thank you
representative uh Nel I just wanted to
thank representative mlan for for all
the work that he put into this bill I
think he did a fa fabulous job on a very
important subject um I've been working
with people with mixed chronic pain and
drug addiction now for a long period of
time and it's very comforting to know
that when I make a referral to somebody
that I could have some willingness to
know or some ability to know that I'm
sending them to a quality place um
having done pain management for a very
long time I'm also aware that the more
often you see a late night infomercial
or a billboard on a street it kind of
reminds you of the unsavory of this area
and this is a place where people do try
to profit at other people's expense and
I'm really glad to see there be some
level of oversight so as a practitioner
I appreciate this other
discussion Yuri uh me representative
palazov I'm
sorry just uh to reiterate that uh I
will be voting against this bill and
it's not just because of
ation but also because I believe that
this bill will lead
to potentially to more abuse because uh
when the idea was uh born uh last
session one of the driving force was a a
case that was uh outlined on NH HPR
certain step podcast but that case was
exactly what this bill will increase
that case was
in facility under DHHS oversight and
currently our state is being bankrupt by
other cases that were under DHS
oversight so and now we are
punishing those who were not under DHHS
over side by bringing him them in into
system uh I think first we need to make
sure that the HHS will uh clear up uh
facilities under their oversight and
then we can increase then we can give
them money but this bill will give them
more power more money when they like
cannot protect people under their
oversight so I cannot go alone with it
thank
you other discussion representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman so I I too
will be voting against this motion I um
I appreciate the concerns that have been
brought forward I would like to see
something uh done about it unfortunately
I just don't think that um creating a
you know a whole new category of
regulated entities is the answer I did
speak to a friend of mine who is U very
active in New Hampshire in addiction
treatment and um I I was you know it was
not a long conversation but I was trying
to get a sense of uh
whether he felt this was uh a necessary
step or not and he uh was very clear
that he did not believe that this was
necessary and um I I simply don't uh I I
think we create a lot of potential
problems when we uh when when we add
this much um new regulation to
um to to an entire domain of of uh
treatment other discussion
seeing none so the motion is ought to
pass as amended on HB 751 FN I'll ask
the clerk to call the
all r merer
no R mlan yes rep damus no rep kofalt no
rep Nagel yes rep poov
no clerk votes no rep marel yes
rep McGrath
no rep
Weber yes rep McKay yes rep Woods yes
rep Sebert
yes rep TZ
yes rep lontine yes rep hartnet yes rep
Lucas yes re McDonald yes
vote 12 to six motion
passes okay is there going to be a
Minority Report
or I will write a Minority Report
okay um who was that Jim kofalt writing
The Minority
Report and and mark You're the
representative mlan you're writing the
majority report right yes sir
Mr okay what's the
verdict what the clerk said is that it
is entirely appropriate to recuse
yourself in committee it's it's best if
it happens at the very beginning of the
process but um there is apparently
representative McKay a form that the
clerk will need and you can't take part
in any part of the process um but
recusal in committee is entirely
appropriate are we able to proceed on
that vote then and on that that bill
or I think so I I I didn't ask
specifically about whether he needs to
fill out the form before we take the
vote okay I didn't get any sense that it
was a problem
okay well he sat through the hearing
well he can sit through the hearing
anybody that doesn't anyone I mean the
the people who accuse themselves on the
floor of the house sit through the house
too it's it's questioning um making an
amendment doing those sorts of
things okay well um since since that's
come up then why don't we go back to 724
now representative Drew I moved to itl
HB 724 and representative merer I second
any other discussion beyond what we've
already heard I think representative
Nagel this is really more for the
landlords in the room but you know if my
kid gets exposed to lead gets lead
intoxication and I can show it's from
the apartment that I'm renting I have
legal repercussions don't I don't does
that put you at risk as a landlord that
that I can come after you with you know
pretty hefty lawsuit I would
imagine you guys know if it wasn't just
yes um speaking as an attorney I think
you have a
absent of any other circumstances I
think you got a pretty good
lawsuit representative Dr my
understanding is that if it wasn't
disclosed yes in fact there was a case
in Manchester a few years ago that's
been on TV that was exactly that there
was a young child who got lead poisoning
and died and the uh landlord tried to
cover it up by faking the forms and
essentially got caught and sent to
prison so this is like a followup
question um would it not be in the
landlord's best interests that this law
exists to protect them from such
circumstances there already is law with
in terms of lead abatement it's this is
adding to the existing law it's not the
only thing
there okay any other
discussion representative Woods yeah
just emphasize that if we vote this down
we're also voting down the new lead
level there are two things here one
we're talking about the financial aspect
uh for the homeowners or for the
landlords but we're also we're talking
about kids too and creating a new lead
level for as a criteria so keep keep
that in
mind thank you other
discussion saying none ask the collector
call the roll motion is itl on 724
rep merer
yes rep mlan yes rep damus rep kofalt
yes rep
Nagel rep palazov yes clerk votes yes
rep Markel yes rep McGrath yes rep
Weber
no rep
McKay rep Woods no rep seert
no rep TZ No rep lontine no rep Harnet
no rep Lucas no R McDonald
yes vote 10 to seven motion passes then
to 7 to one right uh does the recuse
count as a no vote I I think we have to
put it down as well just say refused
yeah put yeah just it's not an abion
it's a refus
right do I assume a Minority Report or
anybody would you like to
that representa do okay thank
you all right so representative lontan
will do the Minority Report
representative Drew will do the majority
report okay next up is um 756 FN
representative kofalt did you have a
motion on that uh yes I move in
expedient to legislate on 756
FN okay and I'll second that um would
you like to speak to your
motion yes
um this bill would um established that
before entering child care or School a
child would have to to
um would have to uh be tested for for
lead um we already have the requirement
in New Hampshire that children be tested
for lead at age 1 and at
age2 um furthermore it would impose um
some administrative requirements we have
heard that that's simply a checkbox but
if you read the bill it actually says
that child care facilities and schools
would be required then to send out
notifications to parents
um so I do believe that it creates an an
additional administrative burden for um
for private businesses and schools um
and it's something that
uh should not be necessary as we're
already requiring a lead uh test at ages
one and
two okay representative
Weber I just want to point out that as I
read this
um one of the concerns and I wasn't here
for this hearing but we've heard this
bill before uh was that kids wouldn't be
admitted to schools and it doesn't say
that they have to have if they have not
had the lead testing which is required
all the school has to do is provide the
docu and document the notification to
the parent that lead testing is required
and um give them educational materials
once again lead poisoning is a
lifelong condition and the more we can
do to Abate that and ensure that kids
arrive at
School C well able to learn and become
very productive members of society we're
going to save ourselves a great deal of
payment of other kinds of funds down the
line so I think that not passing this
bill is not
only giving up one more chance at
getting that kid taken care of but it's
also Penny wise and pound
foolish so I will vote against
itl representative Nagel thank you Mr
chair thanks um you know I'm taking my
own question um I I I agree with that um
the the ripple effect of lead and sephy
opathy Lead intoxication is is scary um
the cost ratio for every dollar you
spend for the value you save is anywhere
from $10 to $200 it's it's it it it to
me this seems like a trivial effort to
create a really substantial to prevent a
really substantial problem um and
therefore I'm going to support the it or
whatever it is we're voting
for against the
a representative
Weber I also should have mentioned that
the signin were 94 in favor seven
opposed and one uh
neutral
represented he was talking while I was
sorry I was talking to oh talking to
miss Brant repeat like the whole thing
well just what your what your end result
was that you you I so the the motion is
itl correct then I'm going to be
opposing that is that what you want to
know is that correct
yeah this job's too
complicated any other discussion
representative Woods uh yes I I to me it
doesn't go far enough in the sense that
this is restricted U to the physical
exam part and the
initial part is to Public Schools uh to
me it should be all schools uh why are
we parsing out Public Schools um all the
schools should be equally uh
impacted any uh representative Lucas um
I did make a note during the testimony
that approximately 21% of one- yearolds
are not being tested currently and 31%
of two-year-olds are not being tested so
I think a third layer is very helpful
thank
you uh representative AAS
uh thank you uh I was impressed that uh
Jackie Cowell who is a really well
regged person in the early childhood
World um suggested that this would make
more sense if it happened in the in the
in the physician's office because
they're going to the get form oops to
get the form anyways and so I'm
wondering if there'd be an appetite for
an amendment and um um you know for
considering because a sort of like if
you map process process wise they have
to go to the doctors anyways and the
doctor could just order it and the
doctor's office could provide the
handout and so I I appreciate the need
to have another a stop Gap because of
the numbers of kids who aren't getting
tested if the form is required for
entrance anyways then that seems like
that would be a better
place thank you u i saw another
representative Nel the juy had up a
moment to go yes yeah I think I'm going
answer both of those or I mean from a
public health point of view the more
points of Entry that you use the more
likely you are to get the important data
that you need I mean my kids went to Boy
Scout camp and the forms I had to fill
out you know you had to check all this
stuff off it wasn't that big a deal and
then if something was missing you found
out it was missing and then you
remediated it wasn't that big a deal and
you know i' say yeah the doctor's office
this place I I don't have a problem with
doing it in more than one place um and
that that's how we pre avoid making
mistakes we do it in the operating room
all the time the more people that ask
the question the less likely mistake is
going to happen H oh I do
I'm I guess it's I'm glad you're to hear
you're R well you're not retired yet I'm
still good thing I don't that's very
it's very reassuring to hear that
especially when you're not a patient
any other discussion on the motion
representative
lontine uh yeah I feel that um if
they're going to the doctor's office
they're getting the physical exam and
that is already being brought to this
the school so it's just adding it on
that um but I think it's one more step
that if they show up at school and they
haven't they don't they happen to miss
their two-year well child and never got
tested for lead it's a way of checking
for that I don't think it's overly
burdensome just another form to make
sure but it could capture a lot more
children who have high Leeds that and
there's nothing being done about
it representative Nel sorry one more
comment but if you're catching this at
six you're too late so that's the value
of of child care because you're catching
them at younger ages I mean six is way
too late you need to know this way
before then so representative Woods uh
just to disagree with my uh colleague um
it's never too late because uh if you're
having a low level of contamination it's
cumul the point is it's cumulative it
doesn't just stop at a certain level so
if you're getting a high exposure at age
one that may be the end of the story
right there but if you've got a very low
level you have a chance to intervene and
if by age six you pick it up and it is
at a low level then you still have a
chance to intervene so I just offer
that okay thank you any other
discussion seeing none we'll proceed to
the vote I'll ask clerk to call the
rooll motion is itl on 756
FN rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep
Nagel rep poov yes
clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep Weber no rep McKay no
rep Woods
no rep
Sebert
no rep TZ
No rep lontine no rep hartnet no rep
Lucas no rep McDonald yes
uh N9 to nine right yeah without
recommendation well we need another
motion right of octop pass do oh that's
right I'll move oop pass okay represent
T you
second second okay so representative TZ
moves
and representative weever
seconds hold on and you'll write the
report representative
Taos okay we have to oh well that's true
hold on hold on hold on sorry motions
ought to pass moving by rep TZ
representative TZ moves representative
Weber
okay no what would the Third Way be
you can't do interim study the first
year of the session right wouldn't have
to be
retained and I don't think retention is
going to change a lot no I don't think
so okay we ready we're ready uh clerk
the clerk is ready to proceed motion is
ought to pass on HB 756 FN rep maor
no rep mlan no repus no rep kofalt no
rep
Nagel rep poov no clerk votes no r
marel no
sorry rep McGrath no rep
Weber yes BR McKay yes rep Woods yes rep
Sebert
yes rep TZ yes rep lontine yes rep
hartnet rep Lucas yes and rep McDonald
no vot is 9 to9
Ty okay so I'll go be going to the house
Flor with no recommendation but the
first motion be considered under house
rules will be to pass right
sure do we have a majority with you
don't have a what you have is you have a
statement in favor of ought to pass and
a statement in favor of itl so it isn't
a minority or a majority most but I
think we do need to sort out who's doing
the writing so they sure get that
started yeah and the vice chairman needs
to know for her Green Sheet
too okay
great are you doing one or
two representative T is going to do the
statement in favor of to pass okay all
right so representative kofalt for itl
representative Tas for OTP am I correct
and representative kofalt you're doing
756 and uh 63 oh 634 we skipped I'm
sorry1
750 give him just the time to turn okay
yeah he's doing The Minority Report for
751 that's correct
okay okay I have nothing else for the
executive session um are we all set you
have a question
AV the first stud and have to out at a
time in
November interim study is only available
in the second year and you give a
report but you don't
the bill and interim study is a motion
that has to go to the floor of the house
all bills have to be
voted we could also justed
it
it and with interim study the decision
the interim study has to be approved by
the
that's right but the final result of
interim study does not go to the house
that's right it's a report that anybody
can do whatever they want and the only
motions that are appropriate are either
to recommend or not recommend forut
legislation that's
right it pays to have a fmer speaker
protm on the committee
here okay again I have no other business
to come before us today uh an executive
session uh we do have a full day of
hearings for next Wednesday any other
questions before we
adjourn seeing n We
Stand seeing none IE stand
adjourned
come for